e
well good morning
everybody back again good to see
everybody post election um I just want
to check uh senators representa is
everyone here from that you guys are
expecting hey
Mike it was it is representative Wilder
were we expecting anybody else from the
house okay or in Senator gray I don't
think anyone else from the Senate was
coming okay just wanted double check and
be kind of be respectful make sure
everyone was here well it is great to
see everybody here and obviously a big
welcome uh to uh governor elect a um
very excited in terms of working with
her and her transition as everything
moves forward um one thing I will will
say just about the transition process I
know we're here to talk about the budget
is we're very lucky in New Hampshire in
that um every transition always goes
very smoothly I think this one will go
exceptionally smoothly but the fact that
um you know this Governor Le doesn't as
did I didn't have to come in and rehire
a whole bunch of new agency heads and
restart the whole process um it really
is an amazing advantage to keep the uh
operations of the state moving smoothly
to having opportunities like this where
our current agency heads are coming in
and talking about a budget process that
the vast majority of which maybe all of
which uh will continue on through
through the legislative process as well
and that continuity I think gives New
Hampshire always an upper hand over a
lot of other states uh especially as it
as it pertains to moments of
transition our teams are the same the
folks on the ground are the same whether
you're talking about Mental Health
Services or DCF or whatever the needs
may be um those needs are constantly
being met regardless of of what might be
happening up here in conquer and uh it
really is a smooth process and and well
underway I I I was there eight years ago
I I know I know the uh Governor Le dead
is being absolutely overwhelmed um but
it's great um and a big thanks to the
folks over at safety where all the a lot
of these issues of transition are
happening they've provided a great
resource uh for her team so as uh as we
all know the state budget process it
really is the most important uh we can
say document but really process uh that
comes before the state every two years
and it isn't just in what is on the
final piece of paper it's the
opportunity to talk about not just the
individual agencies what's happening on
the ground the public testimony which so
many folks across our state uh
participate in the subcommittees the
house process the Senate process um it
has its checks and balances but that's
all really driven to transparency and
making sure that we talk about what's
what's happening out there uh where we
can push where we can pull where some
programs might be Antiquated uh and we
can always challenge our self and strive
to do better um uh I was reminded this
morning you we've obviously come a long
way since 2016 it's eight years ago but
it's more than that it's we as a lot of
us call it pre-pandemic um the whole
world is very different in terms of how
we
operate um what the priorities are uh
some of the efficiencies we found some
of the um uh Capital uh Investments
we've been able to make not just with
the federal funds coming in with arpa
with our capital budget process those
have been uh very fortuitous for the
State of New Hampshire but they all they
all complement what we do on the
operational side as well um I've always
said that if if we have a progrowth pro
bus model uh that drives the success in
terms of the opportunities that the
government will have government
opportunity for its that it can create
for its citizen is all driven on having
a successful business successful growth
models uh and we've been able to do that
especially uh standing out from the
crowd here in the Northeast we've been
very successful we
uh you know pre pandemic eight years ago
we had deficits in the education trust
fund today we have over $200 million
surplus uh we have we had 5060 million
whatever it was in the rainy day fund
today we have nearly $250 million
sitting in the r rainy day fund now
those aren't funds to be dipped into for
General and obligation you know
long-term obligations uh they're really
there for a rainy day there's a a reason
we call it a rainy day fund and uh over
the years I think the legisl has been
very cognizant very responsible about
that you know the other the other piece
I'll throw out there the kind of good
news piece more on the capital and
one-time spending side is we've been I
think very successful successful in um
uh drawing down our debt I think we have
about 30 Monica maybe at the State
Treasury I'm doing these numbers off the
top of my head but we have about 30%
less debt than we did just eight years
ago in terms of the overall debt load of
the state that gives us and our credit
rating actually went up of all things we
hadn't had that in over 40 years so um
econ ically we are seen as strong we
have a great credit rating we can borrow
at low rates if we have to so we have
this back stop uh in case of emergencies
if we need to or for larger Capital
Investments as the legislature may
choose coming down the road so um
there's opportunity there really is on
the operational side that's really what
these hearings are about where we bring
in all the different agency heads we'll
start with the Department of Revenue not
quite yet Lindsay good to see you um uh
we'll bring the Department of Revenue up
up first to talk more on the uh spending
side in terms of their Department
obviously the uh house Ways and Means
and the the Senate uh will will get
involved a little more on the revenue
side as well and uh as we get closer to
that um well as the governor elect gets
closer to that February budget address
um we I I have no doubt the agencies
will be providing a lot of information
on where these Revenue projections are
we've been very fortunate in the past uh
not just the past eight years but
specifically this past year we had about
$125 million surplus uh over the first
year of this bium I think we've been
about even um uh you know since then
which is great so we're still sitting in
this current budget with a with a very
healthy Surplus um but uh the realities
of inflation the realities of the cost
of living as much as they're hitting all
these uh all of our families and
businesses across the state it hits
government too we've had pay had to
increase pay here to maintain and um you
know and rightly so to maintain our our
employee base our staffing base uh so
those labor costs have gone up as
they've gone up everywhere else and so
obviously something to be built into the
next budget process uh we've always been
able to cut taxes we've always been able
to have surpluses uh it doesn't happen
just with math on the paper it happens
really at the at the heart of it with
good management I think the legislature
I'll also say we'll see where it goes
this year but you know I think we've
established a very good lapse process
here making sure that there are lapses
built into the budget that there's a
cushion in there if you will um in that
process looking at vacancies how we
treat vacancies in the state is a whole
different ball game now uh given that we
have had a very high
vacancy rate in certain areas um how the
budget is determined in certain um
agencies uh sometimes I I can tell you
it's a little Antiquated um they're
looking at census counts in certain
areas or or demands on an agency in
certain areas that maybe were made sense
pre pandemic but post pandemic there's
all these uh additional opportunities
the onetime spending that has come in
from the federal government has been um
again a very fortuitous for the state
for the um it's it's created a lot of
opportunity I'll I'll I'll say I think
our teams and and I think Charles
deserves and his team deserve a lot of
credit um in the legislature especially
I think we've done a phenomenal job uh
spending that money very responsibly on
one-time spending that's a very
important point because we have not
created long-term obligations within our
agencies that now have to be covered
with our our business taxes or or our
other General Revenue taxes other states
have I think fallen into that trap I
think we we've really minimized it as
those funds have come in over the past 3
4 years there's also been a lot of
programs that have been created on a
temporary basis right for a uh temporary
uh an infrastructure program coming in
um a development program coming in with
arpa money sometimes we say okay we're
going to create uh positions but they're
only going to be a couple years to
manage those funds to manage those
opportunities that come and you know as
a lot as as always been anticipated a
lot of those positions will go away
that's just that's the way it was
designed um as that that onetime money
comes in we're kind of heading towards
the back end of that all the oper
dollars have now been allocated
um and uh as we kind kind of come
through that we hit more of a of an
auditing phase uh through through those
dollars and we can reduce the number uh
or take you know pull some of those what
are now vacancies out of the budget so
there's a lot of opportunity there to
constantly manage making sure that the
dollars are going to the programs we
need through the agency phase that
started a few months ago I went to all
the different agencies and we gave them
individual targets now they all amounted
to about about a four if you added all
the numbers up it came out to maybe
about a 4% reduction but we tried to be
very specific uh with the different
agencies in terms of the targets that we
were setting up um I'd remind folks that
we've had you know double digit growth
and and increases in uh the our ability
to increase in spending here over the
last eight years so you know asking
these agencies to look at again those
additional dollars that may have been
spent as part of managing the arpa money
uh as well as looking at their actual
vacancies uh you know creating those um
employment opportunities for those
positions uh that have to be filled
based on today's needs um and in doing
that there's no reason um that we didn't
think that they could uh reduce it by
about approximately 4% if you looked at
over the overall numbers the good news
is they all came back uh with very
minimal disruption sometimes absolutely
no disruption in any of the current
programming uh across the state so I I
my that's my long way of saying my hats
off to all the agency heads I think for
for kind of digging in looking at their
numbers challenging themselves um again
on that management side of things and in
you know I think if there's ever a
mission that we have set out here it
really is to uh Empower our agency heads
to be the best managers that they can be
and and overall I think they've they've
done just a real phenomenal job with
that so now we'll kind of get into that
actual budget process looking at exactly
what the needs are this is really one of
the uh initial steps of it where we kind
of hear firsthand from all the agency
heads in terms of of of their uh needs
what is a necessity versus a want um you
know that's always kind of the um that's
where the rubber meets the road um and
again obviously the the governor will
present her budget uh in early February
the legislature will have at it I'm sure
they'll just maybe they'll just agree
and just uh just sign it next day that
would be
great no Senator Grace smiling maybe
there's a possibility um governor
governor
Lea I did cut several million dollars
out of the last budget that I got in the
Senate so well several million is
manageable when you're dealing with a
few billion um okay and and again just
as a reminder also talking about General
funds we're talking about the federal
dollars that come in as well um kind
really on both sides I mean there's
really two sides of the same Ledger uh
that really have to be have to be
accounted for here um am I missing
anything James no that's it
Charlie no
okay so with that we'll ask um um
commissioner step to come on up and
present the agency phase of the budget
and requests for the Department of
okay good morning Governor good morning
governor elect other panel members nice
to see you thank you for allowing me the
opportunity to present the fiscal year
2627 operating budget from the
Department of Revenue
Administration with me today uh is
assistant commissioner Ora lamir and
business administrator Shelley gerano
the mission of the Dr is to fairly and
efficiently administer the tax laws of
the State of New Hampshire collecting
the proper amount of taxes due incurring
the least cost to taxpayers in a manner
that merits the highest degree of public
confidence in our integrity further we
provide prompt and constructive
assistance to Municipal units of
government in the manners of manners uh
matters of Budget Finance and the
appraisal of real estate together we
developed a thoughtful operating budget
that will provide the resources for our
team to administer the tax laws of our
state for another two fiscal years in a
manner that's consistent with this
Mission as the primary revenue
collection agency we are aware of the
current Revenue Trends and have worked
hard to produce a budget that's
consistent with the targets
provided in fiscal year 20124 the Dr
collected 2.9 billion in state revenue
with total expenses of less than 22.7
million some of those expenses are for
activities unrelated to revenue
collection such as local assessment
reviews and state aid when those
unrelated costs are accounted for our
cost for collection is just over 1 half
of
1% the slides included with this
testimony explain how we're able to
build a banal budget that continues to
be an unparalleled return on state tax
dollar investment we look forward to
working with the governor and the
legislature as you build the next
flipping to slide three of the
presentation this just provides a
highlevel overview of the Dr the Dr is
made up of the administration unit which
is the Commissioner's Office legal and
tax policy and other back office
functions the audit division that does
exactly that those are our Auditors we
have instate Auditors multi- entity
Auditors multi-state Auditors Discovery
Auditors and tobacco auditors
next our Collection Division those are
the folks that are collecting amounts
that are past due for which the appeal
rights have run taxpayer services
division they do all of our document
processing they man our call center and
they perform routine taxpayer
maintenance lastly our Municipal and
property division is made up of the
municipal unit which is currently busi
busy setting your local property tax
rates our property appraisal group uh
utility property tax and gravel and
Timber so those are just a highle
overview of the
Dr on page four you'll
see the FY 2627 agency budget kind of at
a very high level so you have fiscal
year 25 adjusted authorized fiscal year
26 are efficiency request and fiscal
year 27 efficiency request you'll see
that our budget is approximately 85%
General
funds from the education trust fund we
pay out the low and moderate um property
tax relief from that um
fund and the agency income is a
combination of flood control payments
which we make to municipalities based on
flood compacts with Connecticut and
Massachusetts and also Debt Service on
our Revenue information management
system also known as
rims both years are consistent with the
targets that you provided Governor
fiscal year 26 was adjusted for rent and
maintenance fund increases and fiscal
year 27 was adjusted for the same as
well as salary and benefit increases for
positions that were funded in fiscal
year 26 again this was consistent with
the information provided from the
Department of administrative
services at the bottom you'll see our
position counts um for fiscal year 25
and then our efficiency requests for
27 providing some more detail on page
five
our current funded position count is
reduced by 18 positions in the
efficiency budget so we're reducing our
full-time positions to 135 classified
and unclassified and five part-time
positions uh the positions that we are
UNF funding include nine tax Auditors
five tax examiners two administrators
one pargal and one utility appraiser all
of the positions that we propos to
unfund or currently
vacant our general fund operating budget
is 70% salaries and benefits so we are a
department of people not programs or
things so when it comes time to make
decisions it usually comes down to
positions our budget requests fully
operationalize the Department's Revenue
information management system known as
rims Capital expenses um for that
project will end on
12312 uh the department received
received
$3,160 th000 Capital appropriation to
modernize our system and create rims and
those Capital funds are ending so we
have converted all of those ongoing
costs now into our operating
budget the operating budget will also
fund a conversion of rims to a
cloud-based platform so we are currently
using Hardware on premise Hardware that
is over at 27 Hazen and we will be
converting or we would like to convert
to a cloud-based platform going forward
forward the budget also includes funding
for additional rims support audit
positions and assistance in the hearing
Bureau hearings Bureau we included as
prioritized needs other reductions
include out ofate travel training and
equipment and the budget um office the
division directors and our other
managers worked really hard to build a
budget that was conservative and
accurate and we request funds for needs
and not wants we really went line by
line division by division and made sure
needed on page six this is the first of
the Department's prioritized needs I'll
mention though that the dr's efficiency
of budget as submitted maintains all
current operations but there are a few
places where the Dr has requested um
additional funding in the area of
prioritized
needs the first is for additional Rim
support we would ask to restore funding
for one full-time equivalent vendor
consultant from our fast Enterprises
vendor and one Dr administrator who
would serve as our project
manager we currently have six um fast
Consultants we call them fases um housed
at Dr currently the budget the
efficiency budget funds four consultants
and so this is a request for one more at
five
on page seven we also have a prioritized
need to restore funding for four
positions in the audit division and
funding for the associated out of-state
travel these would be two instate
Auditors one multi- entity auditor and
one multi-state auditor and then the out
of state travel would support the travel
Bureau on page eight our last um Dr
specific prioritized need is to restore
funding for a paralal in the hearings
Bureau um we recently implemented an
easier way for taxpayers to appeal any
tax notices that they receive they can
now do that electronically it's much
more convenient for them but it's likely
going to increase in the number of
appeals that we receive and so this
position would help support the increase
in appeals while still maintaining an
efficient
process the last two prioritized needs
um one was from the Department of
Information Technology and the other was
from the Department of administrative
six on page nine just some updates about
what we've been doing for the past two
years with our or past year and a few
months with our current operating
budget with respect to rims we upgraded
to the latest version which is called
core 21 and that went live just last
month in
October that was paid for by arpa money
um those are really one-time funds uh
our maintenance costs did not change um
the core 21 upgrade um enhanced security
through tokenization and authentication
it's a modern coding language we're told
that the new language will be um much
have much greater appeal to those that
are recently graduating from four-year
um computer science programs and it also
increased the efficiency and ease of use
for taxpayers tax practitioners and our
staff as well
well also relative to rims as part of
the funding for the rims project there
was a large portion that was paid by
capital and then there's a portion that
the state will pay back through
additional Revenue uplift and so we
track the amount of Revenue uplift that
rims has generated so this is money that
we did not receive or would not have
been able to receive in our prior
software but with the upgrade we've seen
um additional
Revenue so revenue revenue uplift for um
existing taxes attributable to the imple
implementation of rims reached 14 and a
half million in fiscal year 24 and we
are at 31.1 million of additional
Revenue to date since the system was
fully implemented in August of 2021 so
just about three years after
implementation we've generated $31
million we do that in a variety of ways
in fiscal year 24 we sent out reminder
to pay letters so it's very simple we
sent out a tax notice and in our old
system we would just hope you would pay
and if you didn't pay then you'd be
converted into a collections case now 30
days after we send that first notice the
system automatically sends a reminder
that generated $5.4 Million last year
very simple automated taxpayers
appreciate it because everyone's busy
they lose sight of it they get a nice
reminder
um the system also allows us to use
federal tax information so that's
information provided to us by the IRS to
make sure that state and federal filings
are consistent with the increased
security of rims that we didn't have in
our prior system we have greater ability
to use this information that generated
$7.1 Million last year and then we now
have a feature through the system that
allows taxpayers to sign up for
automated payment plans if your payment
plan is simple and it falls within
specifications that we've identified you
can go on to the portal you can sign up
for yourself with very little or no
interaction from the Dr and that
million the way the statute reads we can
transfer up to $4 million per fiscal
year into the Rim's Debt Service account
and so we obviously exceeded that amount
this year so the full 4 million was
transferred into the general fund and
then we'll pay the um the supporting
Debt Service
other other budget priorities for the
current budget fleet vehicles we have
upgraded our fleet vehicles we have all
wheeel drive hybrid vehicles to help
ensure that our appraisers and our
collectors can perform their work out on
the road and the hybrids cut down on gas
forward and lastly on page 10 we made
some additional technology upgrades with
arpa funds I mentioned the enhancement
of the rim system to core 21 we also um
purchased a new high-speed scanner that
allows us to Pro process paper forms and
checks um that increased throughput
speed is anywhere between 10 to 66%
depending on the settings um
automatically separates documents so
that requires less upfront work of our
staff and reduced manual data entry as
the camera and resolution of the of the
system is much better and so it's able
to read the information more
clearly we we also upgraded our
Equalization web application this has
expanded functionality to include dr's
Municipal assessment review and
revaluation monitoring and also a
modernized platform for our Equalization
ratio studies which includes mobile
ability for our folks out in the
field lastly I just want to take a
moment to highlight the fact that
customer service remains a priority of
the
Dr in fiscal year 24 and fiscal year 25
to date we have maintained a rating of
three or higher on a a scale of 1 to
five from 99% of our customer
satisfaction surveys and those are
surveys that callers that call into our
call center receive at the end of their
phone
call also for customer service the
initial launch and subsequent upgrade of
Rim's online portal Grant at tax connect
continues to focus the needs on the
needs of taxpayers and practitioners to
date we have received over 48,000
external users so that's pretty
remarkable and the core 21 upgrade now
allows for the ability to pay review and
update your payment plans review power
of attorney information submit a dis an
appeal or dispute request and submit
certification requests and I wanted to
take just a minute to if I could read
some of the
comments that we received from our
customer service um surveys so in our
call center There's an opportunity at
the end of the survey for folks to leave
a voicemail and just make a comment or
ask a
question so folks um some of the various
comments have been this was such a great
experience I didn't want to call a
government agency but it was as smooth
as could
be I'm a small business owner in New
Hampshire and I very much appreciate how
quickly I'm able to call and speak with
someone you guys are great I work with a
lot of states and you're the easiest to
contact I'm a new Resident to New
Hampshire and I'm very pleased with the
service you
provide I'm a CPA located in New York
you have a very pleasant staff and it
should be recognized this type of Quick
Service is rare in state
government and then similar comments
there's a survey when you utilize the
granite tax connect portal you can
submit comments at the
end folks have said much better than it
used to be I'm very satisfied this is
easy to do rather easy for un
technologically savvy people like
me this is actually one of my favorites
um the two returns submitted today were
assisted by two employees who were the
best state or federal department
employees and the best online software I
have ever encountered in my 22-year
career since graduating from
Northwestern in 1962 with a major in
accounting and the University of Chicago
in 1971 with a major in management
information systems I also passed the
Illinois CPA exam in
1967 so we very much appreciate the
feedback that we receed and I think this
is just a testament to um how seriously
we take our job and how seriously we
take customer service um I'm will stop
there and I'm happy to answer any
questions great thank you terrific job
as usual um I guess we can see if anyone
questions yeah I I have a a question um
commissioner thank you um I'm going to
start off with by giving you a a a
compliment and that is that uh the the
rims project is is widely regarded I
believe as one of the state's uh most
successful IT projects over the years
and as part of that you've had uh
employees from Fast Enterprises embedded
in your team uh they are productive but
they are not cheap correct uh can you uh
just talk a little bit about the return
you get on that investment and is there
a less costly way for that to do this
the same input that they would provide
you that's a great question so one thing
that fast Enterprises does differently I
think than some of the other software
vendors is James as you mentioned the
staff is embedded here they move to New
Hampshire they live here with their
families they don't fly in on a Monday
morning and fly out on a Friday
afternoon they sit in the department we
treat them like our own um they come to
our department-wide meetings they are on
all of my email Communications unless
it's something about you know submitting
a time card um we treat them as if
they're our own um their cost as you can
see from the prioritized
need is roughly
$450,000 a year for a full-time
equivalent um however rims is has been
very productive it produces significant
Revenue uplift and we have really tried
to figure out the right balance between
utilizing the fast
consultants and also utilizing our own
staff so fast has the opportunity for
you to just sign on for blanket
maintenance and support and you pay a
flat fee and you get what you get we
have opted to do time and materials so
we can very much control the amount of
support that we need we can ramp it up
or ramp it down within the budget so
that we're getting exactly what we need
but we're also utilizing our embedded
DOI
staff in our last operating budget we
received funding for two additional
developers so that we could make sure
that we are developing rims alongside
the Consultants so you heard me say
we're currently at approximately six
Consultants the efficiency budget funds
four I think we can do it with four I'd
feel a little bit more comfortable with
five which is why we included the one
prioritize need but this was something
Governor that we discussed after the
last budget which was kind of SC maing
back the Consultants but finding the
right balance and I think we're almost
there um and I'm confident that that
done hi hi um I have a couple of
questions one is on the on the uplift on
Revenue um you transfer 4 million a year
when is that expire is it 20 years so we
will transfer $4 million a year until we
hit $40 million so if it if we were
guessing that means 10
years that was a joke well kind of um it
would it would be 10 years however the
first year we did not transfer the full
$4 million because rims was had only
been operational for a few months um so
so the first year would have been what
fiscal
18 the or 19 first year was is sorry no
that's
fine the first year was fiscal
21 oh because we went live oh yeah yeah
yeah in
81921 um
and we will do this for a little
over seven years remaining I had okay so
these next two budget years and then
some then thereafter if we continue to
prod prod $4 million a year which I have
we produce $14 million this year so I
have no reason to believe that the
amount would fall below the $4 million a
year and that's just a direct hit to the
general fund correct we do it by tax
type so we identify the amount of
Revenue that we a revenue uplift from
business taxes from interest and
dividends tax from meals and rentals tax
those are the three taxes at this point
and because we are over the $4 million
we PR rate it and transfer up to 4
million based on those tax types so to
date we have deposited 14.17 million so
we have
2.83 million to go so $4 million a year
we will do do deposits for seven more
years cool okay
um you have a you have a very easy to
understand budget I don't want anyone to
get misled about future agencies from
that um the uh but I had one question
question about um you know for the most
part your everything on your list is um
understandable your transfers to
doit um go up more than a million this
year but they're also 3 million more
than 24 they go from 3.4 in 24 to
6.5 in 26 which is did something happen
that is as we have operationalized the
cost of rims so the capital budget is
ending and we've needed to shift the
support and ongoing support and
maintenance for rims into the operating
budget so that's what you're seeing
there um and
in this F in this budget fiscal year 26
and
27 we are going to move into the
operating budget about $800,000 of
software maintenance a year and about
$750,000 um of cloud maintenance as we
transition to the cloud
Cloud so those and those were capex
before those were capex before okay and
so we essentially achieved The increased
cost there by reducing our position
count that was that was the balance we
needed to make so that we would still
meet the Target and we do still meet the
target okay that was it all right I'll
now okay great well thank you guys
really appreciate
it uh we're going to to have uh one more
um agency come up prior to taking a a a
FIV minute break um I'll now invite the
Attorney General to come up uh with the
good morning governor sonunu governor
elect aad and esteemed members of of the
panel it's good to be with you this
morning to present the budget for the
Department of Justice for fiscal year
2627 joining me this morning to my right
is Kathy Carr our director of
administration and to Cathy's right is
Tom Kemper our deputy director of
administration we were able to lure Tom
back to the office um to help help us
primarily at least right now with the
operations of the YDC settlement fund
which you'll see um from our budget not
that we're talking about that today but
from our budget the dollars flowing
through that settlement fund are bigger
than than our budget so we needed some
additional help to to manage those
dollars um I always like to start off
our presentation by talking a little bit
about the the various roles of of the
Attorney General and I of course know
the governor-elect is very familiar with
this the attorney general is is the
chief law enforcement officer so
provides supervision and Leadership to
law enforcement throughout the state the
Attorney General is the chief prosecutor
so we prosecute many cases in the office
we also supervise all criminal
prosecutions around the state the
Attorney General is the chief legal
officer so we defend the state when the
state gets sued and we provide legal
councel to every branch of state
government it's always interesting for
people to learn that we actually are the
lawyers for the judicial branch when
they're sued for for administrative
things so the the legal role the role of
the chief legal officer in the Attorney
General's office is a broad one and then
the attorney general has just broad
common law powers to to protect the
public and of course the attorney
general has to serve as the head of of
an agency the Department of Justice so
the Attorney General serves various
roles and the Department of Justice is
the office that helps the Attorney
General carry out that mission which
again is is a broad one but I think we
all agree an important one we have 1995
total authorized permanent positions so
we're not asking for any additional
positions in the coming budget and we'll
go through um those
details the next page of of the
slideshow here is just an organizational
chart for the office so this is a this
gives you a picture of the operations of
the office
um generally the office is broken down
into two major functions civil and
criminal so there's the division of
public protection which generally is
either the criminal or the enforcement
side of the office that division
contains the criminal justice Bureau the
Consumer Protection Bureau and the
Environmental Protection Bureau and then
we have the division of legal councel
which is with a couple exceptions
generally the Civil side of the office
so that is where we do civil litigation
that's where we do client counseling we
provide legal counsel to all of the
state agencies that division contains
the public safety and infrastructure
Bureau which basically just does civil
litigation and client counseling for the
Department of Safety and the Department
of Transportation and that division also
contains the charitable trust unit the
election law unit and the Civil Rights
unit so there's a little criminal work
that goes on in the division of legal
council because the election law unit of
course does do criminal work when it
prosecutes voter fraud cases the Civil
Rights unit at times might do a little
bit of criminal work but generally the
office is broken down into public
protection which is mostly criminal and
enforcement and legal counsel which is
mostly civil the office also contains
the chief medical examiner so the chief
medical examiner is part of the the
Department of Justice so that that is
that is a part of the Department of
Justice which is outside of those two
divisions and then the director
Administration oversees sort of the
administrative parts of the office the
business office victims compensation it
infrastructure and um the Train the
training operations of of the office one
thing that is new in the office the last
few years is the solicitor general so
the office has always done a lot of
appet work it's had a chief of Criminal
Appeals in the past but in 2018 the
office established the position of
solicitor general to oversee both
criminal and Civil Appeals in the office
so this organizational chart provides
just a good kind of operational overview
of the
office the next slide is really just how
the orc chart looks in the budget system
so it's it's a little bit redundant but
that at least gives you a sense of how
many positions exist in both the
division of public protection and the
division of legal council and then how
many positions exist within the chief
medical examiner's office and within the
division of Grants management so this I
like to say that this is more like the
how the the organizational chart looks
in the system it's not really the
operational organizational chart but at
least gives you a sense of where the
different positions are located we don't
break positions out by every single unit
and Bureau because it would get a little
unwieldy but certainly if there are
follow-up questions on that we can
breakdown moving into the Department's
efficiency budget request which is on
slide
six now this requires a little bit of
explanation because when you first look
at it it looks like we are are
operational costs are increasing which
which is not the case but I'm going to
go line by line here and explain
in general funds this is a little
confusing it looks like our general
funds are going up from fiscal year 25
to fiscal year 26 but we had a an
interesting part of our budget in 24 uh
25 which is that for fiscal year 24 we
had $4.3 million appropriated for fiscal
year 24 but which did not lapse until
the end of fiscal year 25 so the idea
was rather than appropriate $2 million
in fiscal year 24
and 2 million or two you know roughly 2
million in fiscal year 24 and roughly 2
million for fiscal year 25 it was
appropriated in fiscal 24 and just in
lapse until fiscal year
25 because of that there is $2 million
that shows up as fiscal year
$24 in the system but it really is
should be under fiscal year 25 and so
that's why our Target was we did we've
met our targets here but that's why our
631755200 dollars were about 22.5
million and the math there works out if
you do the math a 4% reductions about
$900,000 so that that explains why the
general funds look like they do if you
go down to the next line the federal
funds our federal funds in our budget
are basically grants that we take in and
then sub Grant out so our federal funds
are going up not because we're spending
more federal funds on our operations but
because we anticipate getting this
amount of Federal grant dollars to
subgrant out um so it while the state
may be reducing its budget I think it is
generally not a surprise that some of
the increased federal spending is still
rolling out in increased federal grants
and so our typical practice has been if
we anticipate getting federal grants in
we budget those grants in the budget and
we budget them to to subgrant out so
that is why it looks like federal funds
are going up they are but they're not
going up for operations they're going up
because we just anticipate having more
grant money to Grant out inter agency
funds is pretty consistent with with
what I think you would expect to see
because of the Target and then other
funds we have an increase there BEC and
the what's really driving that increase
are a couple of things mostly I think
fees associated with the operations of
the chief medical examiner so so adme
fees are not going up but we for for
instance for for cremations for for
viewing the body we charge a fee every
time we do that and we are seeing the
number of views go up and when views go
up travel costs for the admes go up
because the admes have to drive around
to different funeral homes to view these
bodies so this number is going up it's
not going up because of additional
people it's not going up because of you
know doing new things we haven't done
before it's going up because it's just
directly correlated to to the the number
of views we're doing in the office of
the chief medical examiner that that's
just one component of it but that's an
example of why that that number is going
up my understanding and our
understanding is that these numbers
comply with all directives and all
Targets and of of course if for some
reason there's a thought that that
increase shouldn't happen we will will
change that but because it's directly
correlated to what what is happening and
what the chief medical examiner is doing
um it I think it's consistent with all
all of the directives we got for the
budget so that is the efficiency budget
in a nutshell um and with that I'll move
to the next two slides the next two
slides just provide sort of a
snapshot of what percentage of our
efficiency budget is General funds
federal funds other funds inter agency
funds Highway funds so this is really
just repetitive of what you just saw but
it's just an easy way to see what
percentage of our budget falls into what
category so as you'll note the dep
department is less than 50% generally
funded but much of our non-general fund
dollars are not operational dollars
they're dollars we we take in and we
slide nine is just to Note new general
fund spending again this is all within
the Target and it's not really for the
most part new things we have some salary
and benefit adjustments just for
increase in salary and benefits to
account for raises and and for benefits
going up we have um an increase in the
the lease line for the chief medical
examiner because they will be moving to
new space right now
well we currently lease space from
conquered hospital and conquered
hospital has a vacant building that
they'll be renovating that the medical
examiner will be moving into our lease
payments are going to go up under that
uh new lease again everything's within
Target but we just wanted to note what
what spending will go up and then we did
have a couple of small general fund
increases where we changed the funding
stream for a couple of positions in the
office of victim Witnesses system
assistance so we had a couple of victim
Advocate positions that were I think
partially Federal funded partially
General funded and we change those to be
fully General funded again though it is
target moving forward a couple of slides
to slide 11 these are our prioritized
needs and generally the prioritized
needs break down sort of in really into
victim service
and other law enforcement functions the
first big prioritized need are victim of
crime grants so we we've talked about
this a lot the last few years the
Department of
Justice receives funding under the
federal victims of crime act so we call
them Voca grants and over the last I'd
say five to six years the annual funding
received for those Voca grants has been
about $10 million we subgrant those
dollars out to the Coalition for
Domestic and Sexual Violence all of the
crisis centers we subgrant those dollars
out to Child Advocacy centers we
subgrant those dollars out to County
attorney offices to provide victim
services and Department of Corrections I
think some County Corrections so
generally we subgrant those dollars out
to organizations entities all across the
state to provide victim
Services those federal funds are being
reduced and the reasons for that are a
little hard to pinpoint but generally
the victims of the VCA Grant dollars
have been funded by criminal fines and
penalties Federal Criminal fines and
penalties those numbers have gone down
meaning that there's less money to
subgrant out to States so the we've been
left with a gap and we had been able to
fill that gap for the last few years
because the state had saved and
stockpiled extra Federal grant money we
filled that Gap through through our
funds because at one time we thought
this was just going to be a temporary
dip a few years ago Congress passed what
they called the Voca fix was which was
to divert some other revenue streams
into the victims of crime fund the VCA
fund that fix though has not has not
worked so we expect that Federal
reduction to maintain so in our
prioritized needs we have at least for
consideration basically filling that Gap
with General funds um I acknowledge this
is not a typical thing we do in the
state we typically do not use General
funds to pick up programs when federal
funds are reduced but we've had these
discussions the past couple years we had
these discussions with the legislature
with the governor and while there have
been no promises to anyone as to what
will
happen I think coming out of those
discussions we all agreed that at least
that it would be on the radar for
consideration and so just to be
transparent and make sure it was seen we
put that in our prioritized needs but
that is the biggest prioritized need
that we have H happy to answer more
questions about that this has been a
quite a history with this program with
voke over the last few
years the next prioritize need we have
is a is a human trafficking Grant we
took this out of the budget in order to
meet our Target this has been a grant
that that the department has has put out
for the last you know probably 5 to 10
years and it funds a position the human
trafficking task force and it also um
funds A it traditionally has funded a
position at a at a County Sheriff's
Office although we're not currently
doing that now so we lapsed a lot of
this $200,000 in fiscal year fiscal year
25 so this is this is something we would
look to put back in for fiscal year 27
we were able to fit this in the budget
in fiscal year 26 and be within Target
we were not able to fit it within the
budget in fiscal year 27 to be within
Target the next prioritize need is is a
small one but it would be converting a
part-time Cal Case Investigator to
full-time and the numbers there are are
listed and then at the bottom here this
is not technically a prioritized need
but I think it it should be
noted the child advocacy centers
received $3 million at the $3 million
propriation in hb2 that money is
actually appropriated to the doj so that
it can be granted to the child advocacy
centers and the internet crimes against
children task force received an $800,000
appropriation in hb2 uh for the last
bium and we just note that we would
anticipate requesting those same
Appropriations to hold them level it's
not really a prioritize need these these
at least since I've been in state
government this money has come into the
budget through hb2 Appropriations so we
just anticipate doing the same thing but
I wanted to note it here on the
prioritized needs list because it if it
is ultimately funded at hb2 it is money
that's appropriated to the doj so that
we can subgrant it out to the child
advocacy centers and to the the internet
force so that is our prioritized needs
um the last two slides here we just have
some helpful stats I won't go through
them one by one but the first slide here
just gives you a sense of of what the
Department's doing and and some of the
numbers some stats and then the last
slide which I always like to include
because I think in budget season it's a
helpful reminder that the doj does bring
in some money so this this slide here
just shows you the money that that comes
in and also the money that we that we
manage so it is the budget presentation
and I think it's a it's a good reminder
that we bring in some money too we don't
just spend it so with that happy to take
any questions great thank you Mr
attorney general uh with that I'll kind
of go around see if there's any
questions either from our friends in the
legislature
Charlie yeah I did J go ahead uh one one
quick question if you could talk about
your uh vacancy rates and how they've
changed since we did this two years ago
especially the luck you've had or
success you've had in hiring attorneys
yep it's a great question so our our
vacancy rate right now if you count
permanent positions is about 12.68%
so it's higher than we want it to be it
is certainly better than it was I think
a couple years ago I think this I don't
want to speak out of turn I think the
state averages is it 15 to 16% it so I
think we're I think we're under the
state average but we're we're still not
exactly where we want to be if you only
count permanent positions our total
vacancy rate is is 10 uh
26% so that is that's across attorneys
and staff we
have 13 vacant attorney positions right
now that's out of a total position count
of 88 what I would note for that though
is we have more attorneys than we had a
few years ago so we have we got a lot of
positions in the last budget and I so
part of what happens is we we fill a new
position one example is the data privacy
unit the legislature create passed the
new data Privacy Act we have the new
data privacy unit an attorney internally
is taking the data privacy attorney
position so now we're trying to fill
fill that position but we we have 13
attorney vacancies we have more
attorneys than we did a few years ago we
got a lot of positions in the last
budget and I'm going to say this it's
not the type of thing I think an agency
head would usually say I think that we
we may have more positions than we need
we may have more we may have some
additional positions we can unfund but
we also have additional positions we're
trying to
fill Ken wer just got really excited
yeah no we appreciate that we appreciate
that again it's definitely one of the
more important agencies in terms of you
never want to say well I can't help you
because we didn't hire enough attorneys
to help you to a citizen right so you
always want to make sure you're you're
plenty staff but finding that happy
medium I think is is obviously a
critical critical
Ro good can I um I just had a question
the the one is the um just a note about
hille 2 requests because I suspect some
people are listening um over the last
few budgets we've done spending in House
Bill 2 which is
unusual and um was I think a um a clever
way of of trying to set aside money um
that might not recur for a one-time
spending it's very unlikely in the in
the upcoming budget that there will be
extra money that can be spent so so I
think we're probably likely to go back
to the the old reality where Hill 2 does
not include dollars in it and that just
heads up because you may need to come up
with a
um some alternate arrangement for that
the other thing I wanted to say about
about vacancy rates just because it will
come up a lot
um a lot of people in the audience are
well aware that I hate vacancy rates I
think it's like the worst measure on the
planet um how many positions you have as
a measure for example the state
currently has a 16% vac so-called
vacancy rate many of which positions are
not being recruited and we have more
people working for the State of New
Hampshire today than it any time since
2011 um and it's worth noting that and
largely because of some of the
initiatives the the outgoing Governor I
guess I should say has taken but um I
would bring that up
um secondly have you done any thought
about let's say your target changes have
you internally done some thinking about
where you would find those
dollars we have absolutely Ely so we not
asking you to tell me them now we've
been through the budget and we have a
list of additional things um you
know yes I I won't list them all but
we're ready if if additional cuts are
done okay great well thank you Mr
attorney general thank you guys for for
coming up we're going to take a a five
minute break and then we'll continue on
with the Human Rights Commission yes uh
and some of the other ones throughout
you
e
I ask everyone if they could take their
hearing and next up is the Human Rights
Commission looking forward to your
presentation hi good morning thank you
so very much for the opportunity to be
here my name is Katrina Taylor I'm the
acting executive director our executive
director Anie Malachi could not be with
us today um so I have the pleasure of
presenting our budget to you folks today
um so once again thank you for your time
just a quick overview of the commission
um we are the state agency that enforces
the laws against discrimination in New
Hampshire um we're comprised of SE seven
volunteer Commissioners who are
appointed by the governor an executive
Council um and we established in
1965 and we eliminate discrimination in
the areas of employment housing public
accommodation and just as of 2019 we now
do public education K through
12 um we also do education and Outreach
and we have a workshare agreement with
the EEOC so they provide us 15% of their
funding our current organization
chart um is on page 17 of our
presentation as you can see Governor
executive counsil our commissioners the
executive director we currently have
eight full-time investigators one
full-time intake coordinator a part-time
intake coordinator a full-time paralal
and our secretary position is currently
vacant right now um but we did meet so
we did meet our Target budget for this
pass by NM um on page 18 you will see
that work share agreement that I
referenced with the
EEOC um they pay us on a voucher based
annual um process our average yearly
contract with EEOC is about
195 um so as you can see we are very
good at meeting that contract or
exceeding that
number um getting into the numbers on
the past few years over at the
commission you'll see we have seen a 60%
increase in cases filed um which is a
very significant jump over the past 5
years um and as such the backlog of
cases therefore also grows so that leads
us to my prioritized needs where we are
requesting a couple different things we
are requesting two more
investigators we are requesting a
mediation specialist and we are
requesting a Learning and Development
specialist which would be more of an
Outreach coordinator which could provide
some training and education um to both
those State agencies and businesses and
state and I think that covers it so I'm
have representative wer thank you uh
what do you think caus this increase in
in these
cases part any particular thing yeah
that's actually great question I think
part of it our executive director in the
past couple years really has done a good
job Outreach of
getting um I want to say the employee
side of Outreach so people know that we
exist and I think at the same time we
need to counter that with the employer
education for prevention of these
complaints um so I think we've done a
good job of letting folks know what
their rights are and where to find us
but not so much a good job of letting
these so is there any particular
Department that seems to have more
complaints than
another well we do state agencies and
private businesses any business that has
six or more employees and we also cover
um some federal contractors depending um
so there are depending it's usually
depending on size so the more employees
you have the more complaints you might
have thank you thank you
I have a question for you when when a
case is filed on average how long does
it take to get that case
resolved and um what's sort of
the you know if if I were to file a a
case on average how long would that
really be if you'd be able to resolve
that case and I I see you have the uh
average cases pending is that total
outstanding cases from the charges that
were filed or cases that were filed in
the Char to the left yes so those are
what are waiting to be assigned to a an
investigator for a while we only had
four investigators so as the cases came
in you can only assign so many per month
as they go out um so right now because
we had been able to increase staff it
took only less than a year to get the
case actually assigned which previously
we were looking at two years before a
case was even assigned so to get it
fully resolved depending which Avenue we
offer different avenues for resolution
um but if you're talking about just for
a full investigation with one finding
probably about a year and a half to two
you Hi how are you good how are you good
um you have cases uh average cases
closed cases pending assignment I I
suppose there's a third category which
is cases closed case pending assignment
case currently being worked on right yes
I would say yeah that depends on how
many investigators we have our
investigators carry a case load of an
average of 30 at any an average of 30
and so you probably have about and you
have um how many of your investigators
are full right now um I have three
vacancies right now that I am
interviewing for so we should be fully
staffed by the end of the year so are
you carrying about 150 cases on the book
so speak yeah okay no that's good to
know and you have three vacancies is
that right yes that's right okay did you
unfund any in your budget I'm sorry I
don't believe we
did no okay and what are you when you're
not acting director I am an investigator
I've been I've been with the commission
for 11 years as an investigator oh
that's great well I I wish you luck we
actually hired in my agency somebody who
used to work there who turned out to be
wonderful that's the problem is all the
other agencies keep poaching my inv
investigators took one as well so well
there you go I'm going to keep them but
all right sorry sorry but thank you yes
you're welcome I try to train them and
off any additional questions no seeing
none thank you very much for your
much would like to call up now the
Liquor
okay agenda okay yeah I H Li commission
okay I'm sorry Employment Security is
morning committee members uh for the
record George captis Commissioner of
Employment Security to my right Deputy
Commissioner Rich lers and to his
immediate right business administrator
uh Jill
Revels I want to thank you for your time
today we were we were all set we were
getting ready to head for the
door uh want to thank you for your time
today um so I we've got a quick
presentation we'd like to give to you uh
the Department of Employment Security
receives no state general funds the
majority of its non-matching federal
funds come from
usdol our Bayan budget projection is
based on knowledge and expectation of
the continuation of our core programs
Employment Services unemployment
insurance and labor market information
the department also receives
supplemental funding in the form of a
point 2% diversion of employer State
unemployment taxes for administrative
support in order to cover cover uh
funding shortfalls and from which $6
million annually is deposited into the
training fund administered in connection
with the job training program without
this 2% diversion of employer State
unemployment taxes the state would only
be able to maintain six of the 12 New
Hampshire Works offices the department
offers a variety of services to
claimants job Seekers and employers and
12 full service offices and two
itinerate offic is located throughout
the state therefore Personnel Service
and benefit costs comprise the largest
portion of our overall budget Personnel
related costs comprise approximately 61%
of our budget uh when unemployment
claims increase as was experienced
during the pandemic New Hampshire
employment security receives additional
federal funds based on workloads and
excess of our base budget workload
counts a growing economy and low
unemployment rate like New Hampshire's
currently experienc results and
decreased funding for New Hampshire
employment security the total number of
full-time nhes staff is currently at
282 and uh the highest point of Staffing
reached during the pandemic was
355 equivalent positions in April of
2020 uh during the 2020 21 pandemic the
department managed to pay over $2
billion in federal and state
unemployment benefits to over7 75,000
granted state workers which was more
money more more money and more people
paid than during the prior decade
combined the department of Information
Technology costs comprise approximately
12% of our overall budget uh with this
budget uh Employment Security supports
approximately 23.2 full-time equivalent
do positions with 16 that are embedded
in Employment Security uh Employment
Security relies heavily on technology to
administer all our programs but more
importantly unemployment insurance
programs therefore in addition of class
27 doit our software equipment and
equipment related maintenance budget
represents approximately 10% of the
overall budget the job training fund
receives 6 million annually which
represents about 10% of our overall
budget this fund provides support to
employers and individual job Seekers the
remaining 7% is comprised of General
operating exp expenditure such as
telecommunications postage utilities as
well as assistance payments under the
dislocated worker program which is
administered by Employment Security with
anou established with uh Bea beyond the
unemployment program Employment Security
also plays a significant role in
connecting uh hiring employers and
available workers including uh were the
provider of the most job fears in the
state both both virtually and in person
in partnership with the economic Affairs
business and economic Affairs and the
community college system last year we
did 60 job fairs throughout the state
which was a combination of virtual as
well as in person and we've done 46 uh
as of the end of September of this year
Employment Security also provides
employeers with opportunities to conduct
small recruitment events and we maintain
the state Libor exchange which employees
are able to recruit for for open
positions and job candidates search for
work nhes also provides the New
Hampshire Job portal as a simple and
quick recruitment portal for candidates
to quickly connect with employers
additionally New Hampshire employment
security has been charged with
administering the job training fund
since
2019 and with the 6 million annual
allocation from employer unemployment
taxes it's able to provide the following
programs the work invest program which
provides 50% reimbursement to New
Hampshire employers for costs associated
with delivering training to existing New
Hampshire workers uh the work now New
Hampshire which provides Financial
supports and one-on-one Readiness
Financial supports for individuals
enrolled in Medicaid Medicaid expansion
tanif and snap Work Ready New Hampshire
which is available to all community
college system campuses provides job
Readiness training and professional
skill enhancement for New Hampshire
residents since taking over the job
training program in late 2019 employment
security has expended over 6.8 million
for 405 work invest New Hampshire grants
to support New Hampshire Employers in
delivering training to the workers over
6.2 million and work now New Hampshire
assistance to help individuals prepare
for and secure employment and 3.6
million for Work Ready New Hampshire
also as part of the Department's role in
administering the state's unemployment
program we're also responsible for
administering the New Hampshire
unemployment comp uh the comp trust fund
of out of which unemployment benefits
are paid and into which employer
unemployment taxes are
deposited the unemployment C trust fund
has been hovering around 400 million
since April of this year this is about a
100 million more than prior to the
pandemic several factors are responsible
for this healthy solvent state of the
trust fund New Hampshire continues to
experience low unemployment claim volume
we've experienced about 19% growth
nearly 9,000 in registered employment
establishments prior to the pandemic New
Hampshire has grown its Workforce by
about 4.5% or about 25,000 additional
jobs since before the pandemic also we
received about 109 million in pandemic
funding New Hampshire has been able to
grow the trust fund to Historic levels
all while maintaining the lowest average
unemployment tax rate in over 30 years
and one of the lowest unemployment tax
burdens in the country lastly but not
necessarily a budget related item for
the Department it's important to note
that we continue to partner with charlyy
and uh the department of administrative
services and administering the state's
voluntary Paid Family Leave program this
currently provides paid leave coverage
to nearly 22,000 New Hampshire workers
this coverage is available to all New
Hampshire employers and to all New
Hampshire workers and with that I
conclude our remarks and we look forward
to working with all to provide continue
providing the essential services to the
Hampshire okay thank you uh quick
question for you you currently you have
as you said 282 people that went up to
355 at the height of the pandemic uh to
deal with the the massive yeah the
temporary high unemployment well and the
during the height of the pandemic you
got to remember that you know on Friday
of that week everything was fine on
Monday everything collapsed so basically
when we're talking
355 we had the additional staff that
were working we were all working seven
days a week at that point just to get us
through because there was no time to
train staff to bring staff in and train
staff in order to assist with the
workload so so as of that Monday the
Monday the pandemic started we were
basically everybody in the department
was working uh was working the overtime
hours Monday through Saturday uh Sunday
through Saturday excuse me and uh to to
Encompass that 355 number it was the
equivalent of
355 with with the state's current low
unemployment rate I take it the 282 are
are sufficient but my my my question is
how much would the unemployment rate
have to rise or is a matter of how
quickly it rises in order for that 282
that you would need more employees for
that um so great question so one of the
lessons we learned during the pandemic
is that when you get to those High
volumes and claims that there was a lot
of uh uh problem points in our system in
terms of not only for customers but for
staff and being able to work efficiently
so we've made a lot of changes to allow
for staff to be able to deal with those
High volumes without the additional
Staffing um you know depending on how
high the claim volume were to go whether
that be um something comparable to the
uh Great Recession that we saw or
something comparable to more more mild
downturn like we saw in the early 2000s
uh we think we can deal with a lot of
that um through the improvements that we
have made and we continue to make to the
I would just note that you have your
predecessor former commissioner Reen
watching over you in the back of the
room I suspect you came only for
this um your grants line in your in your
department summary went goes from about
two and a half to about 5 and a half are
those the work those are the work grants
pretty much the job training
sure so um class 73 I believe is what
you're referring to well I'm I'm looking
at the department summary page okay and
uh uh page two grants and grants
Administration 2.4 in fiscal
24 and it's 5.4 I presume that's money
set aside for the job training grants
correct okay and in 24 we didn't expend
as much that's an up and down kind of
thing it is an up and down correct okay
good and just to add to what Jill had
mentioned so any money that's not
expended in the job training grants that
does waterfall back into the trust
you thank you very much for your
it now like to call up the New Hampshire
good
morning director of Information
Technology and Diana kryon from our
legal staff our mission is to provide
secure retirement benefits and Superior
Service for those of you who have seen
nhs's presentation before the message is
the same while we still have some
challenges in front of us we are pleased
with the Positive funding progress we
have made and the operational
improvements which have been implemented
over the past several years the nhrs
board and staff are committed to
promoting the sustainability and
stability of the retirement system
nhrs has approximately
48,500 members and 45,000 retirees and
beneficiaries it is managed by 13
trustees and investment oversight is
provided by an independent investment
committee consisting of six members as
fiduciaries they are obligated to act
solely in the interest of the system's
members and
beneficiaries with the exception of the
state treasurer who serves ex aicio
trustee and investment committee members
are appointed through the governor and
Council and serve three-year
terms consistent with our prior
presentations we have two handouts an
overview with highlights initiatives
strategic challenges and a highlevel
budget overview and a copy of our
strategic planning document which will
speak to our
goals the nhrs statutory administrative
budget which does not include any
funding from the general fund
encompasses all internal non-investment
related Administration costs including
projected it costs at full value our
satutory administrative operating budget
for fy2 is 13.6 million and our budgets
for FY 206 and FY 27 are 19.3 million in
FY 26 and 19.5 million in FY 27 based on
on fully funding all staff board
authorized positions the budget was
created as part of a three-year
strategic plan to address deferred
initiatives and areas put on hold over
the past five years to do the focus on
the major upgrade to our 20-year-old
pension Administration
software the increase is primarily
driven by it upgrades modernization
projects and salaries and benefits to
support new staff positions aligned with
the Strategic plan as you probably know
the New Hampshire retirement system is
not an executive branch agency but is a
statutorily created pension trust
although its expenses flow through the
state those costs are reimbursed from
the retirement trust which in turn is
funded by contributions from employers
and members and investment Returns the
budget which is before you today has
been fully vetted and adopted by our
Board of Trustees who are responsible
for approving a budget which is
appropriate for for the system before I
go into deeper detail on the operations
of the retirement system I would like to
share these key facts about
nhrs nhrs provides a modest pension
benefit the average annual pension
benefit is just under
$23,000 more than 60% of our pension
recipients receive less than $25,000 per
year nhrs benefits are funded by member
contributions employer contributions and
investment return returns nhrs
Investments have achieved an average
annual net return of 7% over the last 10
years which puts us in the top third of
public pension
plans nhrs benefits helped support the
New Hampshire economy in the last fiscal
year nhrs paid out more than $1 billion
in pensions and more than 40 million in
medical subsidy
benefits Approximately 80% of retirees
live in New Hampshire and spend their
money here according to the most recent
research released by the National
Institute on retirement security retiree
expenditures stemming from state and
local Pension Plan benefits in
fy2020 supported
8,234 jobs in the
state there is a plan in place to pay
down the nhrs unfunded
liability as everyone knows nhrs has a
significant unfunded Actuarial acur
liability you all
5.5 billion as of June 30
2023 there are 14 years remaining on the
payoff of the UN original unfunded
liability which existed in 2007
subsequent gains and losses occurring
after June 30 2017 are amortised over
periods of no more than 20 years on
average roughly 80% of the employer
contribution rate for state employees
goes toward paying off the U all
employer cont contribution rates for the
four membership classifications employee
teacher police and fire will decrease in
fiscal years 26 and 27 for the second
straight 2-year rate cycle the decrease
is largely the result of strong
investment performance over the 5-year
period ending June 30
2023 actual member experience from July
1 2021 through June 30 2023 and
relatively minor adjustments to
demographic and economic Actuarial
assumptions adopted by the board in
June because the member payroll
increases annually the total dollar
amount paid to nhrs by employers is
expected to increase
slightly the nhrs trustees continue to
strengthen the plan by adopting updated
Actuarial assumptions recommended by the
systems
actuaries because of its strong
constitutional and statutory Foundation
nhrs is on the path to full funding the
retirement system is making good
progress on paying down its unfunded
liability a slow steady decrease in the
liability is projected in the coming
decades with a corresponding increase in
the funded ratio which increased to
67.5% in fiscal year
2023 please note that we are still
waiting for the fiscal year 2024 funded
ratio to be finalized by our actuary but
we expect to see a small increase I'd
like to take a couple of minutes to
review the highlights documents and then
Finance director Marie Mullen will
present highlights from our budget the
budget overview document that I'm going
to be talking from you have in front of
this over the these are some highlights
from the past year we transitioned to an
updated pension Administration system
platform which replaced a 20-year-old
system as you can see from the chart our
pension plan plan funded ratio is going
in the right direction we've been seeing
steady increases Year bye this past year
we realized
88.8% on investments and the threeyear
5year 10e and 25e returns for the
periods Ed June 30 2024 were 3.4 7.7 7%
and
6.3% respectively the retirement system
assumed rate of return is 6 . 75% all
returns are net of fees compared to
members of the Kalen public funds
sponsor large Universe greater than $1
billion and HRS performed better than
70% of its peiod over the past
decade as I mentioned earlier each year
every four years we get an experience
study prepared by our actuary and this
time for the first time in more than 20
years the actuary did not recommend
reducing the assumed rate of investment
return which is currently
6.75% and in this past year we also
issued the june30 2023 financial
statements and the gby 68 and 75 reports
opinions and initiatives to improve
efficiency we revamped the strategic
planning process and developed a
three-year strategic plan for fiscal
years 25 through 27 we have modified the
fund's asset allocation reducing the
allocation to Global equities from 50%
to 40% increasing the allocation to
private credit by 5% and allocating 5%
to infrastructure a new asset category
for nhrs that is expected to reduce
volatility and provide steady cash flows
the allocations changes are being faced
in as appropriate o over a multi-year
time frame beginning in July
we have also launched an upgrade of the
nhrs member and retire online portal my
account and we've maintained and
expanded various cyber security
enhancements designed to protect the
there were eight bills related to our
statutes that were enacted by the
legislature and signed into law and all
of these required significant database
modifications I will now turn things
over to director Finance Marie Mullen uh
good morning uh to present our agency
budget um just a a reminder that these
do not include any funds from the
general fund and this was created as
part of our three-year strategic plan to
address deferred initiatives and areas
put on hold over the past five years due
to the focus on the major upgrade to our
20-year-old pension
system the 2-year 38.7 million budget
includes a 41% increase for FY 26 over
fy22 and a 1% increase for FY 2027 over
FY
2026 these increases are primarily
driven by it upgrades modernization
projects and salaries and benefits to
support new staff positions aligned with
the Strategic plan it's also important
to note that our administrative budget
is 1% of our overall budget for the
retirement
system um many of the costs are related
to the investment expenses uh for the
system in that uh in that
regard So Below in the chart um below uh
you can see the salaries and benefits
and information technology lines uh for
information and Technology um the
proposed increase is attributable to a
backlog of projects um we're looking to
um Implement uh software upgrades for
our financial system we're also looking
to provide better customer service by
implementing um an app for our my
account for members to be able to see
their information online as well as um
upgrading to the cloud in many of our
areas uh that modernization is also um
the increase in salary and benefits is
PR primarily related to additional
positions to support those projects uh
these positions um are needed in
temporary positions as well as
consultants to help Implement these
projects and uh these those costs would
be utilized during this time frame to to
help Implement and supplement uh the the
staff shortages that may be needed for
specific projects
for all the other costs uh the primary
increase is related to the addition of
Consultants again to provide
implementation services for the various
IT projects as well as um increases
we've seen due to um the cost of uh
living increases related to operations
including utilities repairs and
and we open up for any questions you
have for our our
budget okay thank you representative
Wilder thank you I continue to be
disappointed at your um Returns on
investments and of course that's the key
uh source of the of the benefits that
we're paying out and you show your your
three-year return of
3.4% uh in some of those years when I
went to look up what was the investment
that year
I couldn't find anything but we assume
6.75 you don't you don't uh publish it
when it's a low return these are much
lower than my own Ira that has
reasonable returns and I'm assuming you
have similar Investments or similar
Investments are available to you so I'm
hoping that some of the assumptions that
you made to pay off this this deficit
were increases in employment by the
state which I don't don't think is
happening not only because of more
efficiencies in in it but also with the
problems with hiring we have a 16% rate
so I think you should reexamine some of
the assumptions made to pay off this
debt because if if we're not employed at
the rate you presumed or we're not
increasing employment at the rate you
presumed the the funds won't be coming
in so I think you need to look at a lot
of your figures especially
the investment returns have been
disappointing in previous years and you
know now even now they're still a little
bit below what some of us are making in
our own Ira so anyway that I'm hoping
you yeah um I was wondering if you could
my my question relates on page three of
your presentation I just want to make
sure I have these numbers correct in
2019 your budget was
8 um the actual 8.7 million going up to
roughly 13.6 million in 2025 and that's
roughly a 57% increase on top of that
57% increase you have now passed a 41%
increase for a total increase from 2019
to
20127 of a roughly
123% am I reading that correctly
uh yes you are in in 2019 is when our
pension gold implementation began so
that's where you're seeing the increases
over that fiveyear period we had a uh a
significant um our main software system
of pension gold was upgraded and began
in that year so that's where you're
seeing the increase there is
incrementally each year we we had to um
pay those implementation costs for that
software okay and when your when your
board passed the 41%
uh increase in your budget uh what sort
of Outreach was done to uh to your
constituents whether it's to the to the
legislature or the unions to the cities
and towns that pay in uh how are they
notified or involved or what Outreach
please um what we did did did was we
work work we work closely with our board
and staff to develop a strategic plan to
come up with initiatives that were had
been unaddressed over the five past
years the pension the pension
gold pension Administration system took
basically all of our bandwidth over that
fiveyear period and because of that we
were not able to do other routine
maintenance and so is we're based so
what you're seeing in FY 25 26 rather is
basically 5 years of deferred projects
that we were not able to do while we
were conducting the upgrade to our
software hi
um I think I'm reading this right that
of the 19 to 24 increase 1.8 million of
it was pension gold
of the $5 million increase and that 2.8
million in your current budget goes to
about four between four and four and a
half is that
right I'm seeing your software line at
4.1 yes Y is there another line that I
should look at to get I what's the
equivalent PG V3 budget number for let's
call it
26 if you were to do it
ballpark uh the
the pgb 3 is included in that 26 and 27
number so we have ongoing annual
maintenance now that we have to provide
for pgb 3 so that is now included in the
it budget instead of being broken out
separately and as well as the new
projects we have for U ongoing so it's a
subset of the 4.1 yes that's correct
okay and included in the it budget we do
so have some additional enhancements
um that need to be done to the system as
well cool okay um can you one thing that
jumps out in looking at your budget your
class 45 line which was 7.2 million in
24 dips to 59,000 yeah walk me through
that uh that was uh with regards to some
hb2 legislation for a one-time um TSA
$500 so there was $7.1 Million yeah yeah
yeah okay um and that's how it gets
appropriated uh the general funds get
appropriated it gets put into our budget
so then you don't see that in the future
years so I knew there was something
wonky um my next question is on the uh
paying off the UA um what year did we
start paying off the the the ability
through like we did a 20-year plan I
think it was maybe it was a 30-year plan
to pay off the initial unfunded
liability which was a big number like
four or five
billion um yes that began those that
plan began in
2010 so that part will be paid off in
2030 yes and how many no no it's 30
years it's 30 years okay 2040 how many
billions is that well right now it's
approximately $5 billion and then
there's another um 500 million that
represents gains and losses that have
been accured since 2017 which has a
separate 20-year amortization period so
we're paying off the five billion over
the 30 years from 10 to 40 and we're
paying off another half a billion are we
getting further it sounds like sounds
like every year we're a little bit
short no we are getting ahead every year
we have finally turned the corner and
each year the amount the total amount of
the unfunded liability has been
decreasing but simply because we're
paying it off like we're we're acre
more right like in theory if we weren't
acre more the you wouldn't have to pay
off another 500 million right we do so
we get further behind no we do pension
plans work
in this manner every year you would do
AC additional liabilities because we
have
408,000 members that are working and the
benefit and their salaries relates to
additional benefits that get AC Creed
each year so that increases the
liability so the 500 million that you're
paying off over 20 years is just sort of
ongoing business it's always going to be
another 500 million no we we're hoping
that that will be fully paid off by the
end of that 20
years and no more
acred there may be depending upon if
there's gains or losses but generally
barring a
recession W yes it's it's all trending
down okay good Senator gr um correct me
if I'm wrong but the 500 million that
we're talking about comes from
legislation that has passed during those
calendar years and that affects the rate
at which you would charge but since you
don't set the rate until a couple of
years afterward a lot of times then
there is this liability that's
outstanding which increases the unfunded
liability which is subject to being paid
off in that 20-year
period um yes thank you um Senator that
is one of the reasons that the unfunded
liability since 2017 increases is
benefits see no more questions thank you
very much for your testimony thank you
and next we have now we have the Liquor
good morning good
morning pleasure to be here thanks for
having us I'm Joe Malik I'm the chairman
of the Liquor Commission and with me is
our CFO Tina deir
I'm going to just run through a few
comments before we get into the budget
before Tina gets into the
budget so just to speak a little bit of
regional
competition New Hampshire's two
bordering states uh Vermont and Maine
are both control States they have a
little bit different model than we have
historically they do not have any
state-owned stores they're private
retailers that own the stores and they
make Revenue off of the markup through
through those stores and a percentage
that they take Massachusetts Connecticut
Rhode Island are open States and they
have a mix of local package stores
grocery chain stores and big box
stores and in Massachusetts there's a
Total Wine in spirits is the largest uh
liquor alcohol retailer in the United
States with revenues of over six billion
dollar uh in 2023 they have 270 stores
in 2016 States Total Wine added 18
stores new locations in 2023 across the
states and they're planning 20 new
stores in 2024 and
2025 uh they're our largest competition
they have a total of eight stores in
Massachusetts which they have built
since
2015 and they have four stores in
Connecticut and Connecticut and
Massachusetts combined about 30% of our
take
so Spirit sales to retailers in the
United States are continuing to decline
AR expected to decline in
2025 as premiumization slows down data
from Wine and Spirits wholesalers uh IE
wswa which looks at wholesalers uh and
retailers sales they've audited and uh
more than 450 retailers Nationwide and
they they believe that the negative
trends for spirits will continue in 24
and
25 we saw this trend starting uh in
2023 according to drink marican analysis
these are a few things that we look at
Spirits declined by 2% by volume in the
United States in
2023 and the most interesting note is
this was the first dip in the category
of alcohol sales in the United States in
years so based on the wswa data source
the spirit sector uh seeing a decrease
across the states uh at
5.65% for 2024 and they're expecting
another 5.4% in 2025 they run a June to
do so sip Source analysis which is
another contributor that we use has
attributed the downturn and the
regression to the pandemic consumer
levels broader economic challenges to
Consumers as well as and most
importantly cannabis substitutes for
alcohol across the states and a move
general we'll move to the the
handout and look at page two just a
couple of quick notes that the Liquor
Commission is
self-funded we're in a separate the
that's a separate fund outside of the
general fund and no general fund
Appropriations are used to maintain the
operations of the Liquor
Commission uh we are reside and live in
RSA
1763 which is down the bottom and those
are the those are
the outlines of the commissions to
operate profitably to maintain proper
controls effective and uh responsible
operation of the commission and provide
service to our customers of the
commission and at this point CFO Demir
will take you through our budget thank
you very
much good morning so starting on page
three you'll see our Revenue estimates
and since we are self-funded our
projected revenue is dependent on the
budget we are requesting so
unfortunately with the industry T
industry Trends and the um no increase
in the budget for FY 26 and only an
increase for steps and benefits in 27
the revenue projections are relatively
flat and you'll see that on Row
one row two and three are the transfers
per the two rsas governing Revenue
transfers prior to the general fund the
rsas are listed at the bottom of the
page and have been calculated in our
plan numbers the first transfer
requirement is under RSA
17616 that's the 5% of Prior year gross
profit um it was 10.7 million in 24
incre and 25 and then increasing to 10.8
and 10.9 in 26 and
27 line three is the transfer per RSA
126 AA colon 3 and is estimated by HHS
for the granted advantage in FY 24 it
was 7.2 million this year it's increased
to 12.2 million and for FY 26 and 27
it's at 12.6 and 13
million so for the total transfer of
other funds on row four you'll see in 24
it's 17.9 million increasing to 22.9
million and 25 and then 26 and 27 is
23.4 million and 23.9
million line five then is the
calculation of the liquor Revenue
transfer to the general fund which is
flat with the increase in Revenue um the
slight increase in Revenue being
transferred to those other funds and
then on line six is the beer tax revenue
which continues to be flat and then line
seven gives you the total transfer to
the general fund so I'd just like to
quickly note that in the National Trends
you've seen the percentages what they're
expecting people to be down and what
they actually are down we aren't
experiencing that type of of loss here
in in the state of New Hampshire but we
are experiencing it just being flat so
shape on page four is a listing of our
major expense categories and they
correspond to the table and the line
numbers that we've identified on page
five uh salaries and benefits are 45% of
the total budget and the area with the
largest increases 1.7 million or 3.4% in
FY 26 and 1.5 million or 2.9% in FY
27 the FY 26 increase is offset by
decreases in uh technology hardware and
software doit debt services and workers
comp um that's to come to the budget
Target number for 26 that's equal to 25
and then the increases in FY 27 are
associated with the position step
increases and benefits and then FY 27 is
also offset by some decreases the
services so on page six and seven this
shows you the annual breakdown by class
and accounting unit you'll see the
breakdown is consistent for both years
for the class and by the accounting type
or the accounting unit um as mentioned
FY 26 is flat and FY 27 operating budget
uh increas is 1.3 million or 1.4%
plus the
$500,000 transfers to HHS I did forget
to mention on um page five you'll see
that uh line 12 we've included the
transfer to the alcohol fund into
granted Advantage as a budget item to
tracked so back to page six um by class
the largest category is salaries and
benefits at 45% % and then the transfer
to HHS is 20% and then our rents is 10%
and the rest are fairly minimal and then
by accounting unit uh store operations
is 79% of the total
budget you'll see that's the same on
page seven same similar
breakdown on page eight is uh our
organizational structure the commission
is m is currently made up of three
divisions that report to the chairman
and the Deputy Commissioner this chart
shows each division with the number of
unclassified and classified positions
assigned along with the list of areas of
responsibility and one of and one of the
things that we'll be asking for in hb2
that which has been in our audit
findings for the last couple of years
which we've waited to put into place
till we've launched our new NextGen
system we've gone from the old system to
the new system this year we're nine
months in the old system and three
months in the new system but we'll be
asking asking for a Director of Finance
and audit which would be an additional
director to the commission and it's
something that the LBA is suggested uh
and we're in agreement with it now that
place so back to uh page 9 through 13
these are summaries of the divisions as
listed in the budget uh request with
page references to the book and there's
a pie chart that shows the breakdown by
class category and explains the changes
so on page nine is the office of the
commission they're overseeing all
operations of the commission with the
primary goal to increase sales and
maximize profits while operating in a
cost effective and efficient manner uh
salaries and benefits in 26 uh decrease
is a result of one position moving to
the division of
administration and the operations has a
net increase of 115,000 in FY 26 this is
for um reallocation of indirect costs
and then decrease in current expense and
contracts and then FY 27 is the increase
for salaries and
benefits on page 10 the division of
enforcement uh includes enforcement
licensing education and grants the
division is responsible for enforcing
alcoholic beverage laws enforcing youth
youth access to tobacco and providing
licensing education and support to to
over 6,100 lenses the 26 um increase is
a result of moving five part-time
positions from other divisions for a new
outlets on page 11 the division of
administration this includes uh Finance
HR audit inventory control and legal and
then also moving in 13 positions from
other divisions for moving in real
estate the uh maintenance department
along with a newly created uh Systems
Support for the new nextg
system and you'll notice that those are
eight positions those eight positions uh
as part of the restructure of the
commission uh with the new nextg system
these will just be people that will
support the next gen system and we are
working with doit currently now to look
at we're having a final meeting with
them this week to look at changing the
structure of our
doit in order to help with the financing
of some of these systems again this is
part of the audit mention and uh we have
a wonderful team in place it's really
been a good system uh the most important
thing for us about this system is that
when we changed over the the biggest
goal was that the the folks that are in
the stores didn't notice the change and
and the licenses didn't notice the
change that was the biggest piece and
90% of that has been achieved we had
some issues with larger licenses and
ordering which has been taken care of
but for the most part through the summer
no one noticed any difference in the
stores the the product went one way and
the cash came into the registers and
that's what we're here to do so thank
you so moving on to page 12 the division
of marketing and Merchandising this
includes marketing merchandising
advertising the retail store outlets and
the HQ Warehouse the division oversees
the buying marketing selling and
distributing of products through all of
our channels to promote sales and
maximize profits uh the FY 26 decrease
is are from the position moves um
there's a reduction to debt services and
the technology Hardware software and
utilities uh FY 25 3.9% or 2.7 million
increase mainly for salary oh I'm sorry
benefits just quickly like to comment
there that we run all of our Outlets all
of our 62 Outlets with uh
268 Personnel full-time personnel which
is quite an achievement in itself and in
the in the vicinity of about 700
part-time
Personnel so on page 13 workers comp and
unemployment comp um workers comp is has
decreased and the number is based on the
um previous Trend and unemployment comp
is
flat the last slide is um additional
changes in a a capital request um that
we just wanted to bring attention to uh
the additional changes are for those
eight positions as we've looked at the
restructuring to move them out of the
division of administration and move them
under marketing and we're looking to put
in a new capital request that has
recently come to light um to replace the
current licensing Enterprise solution
Software System known as um mllo my
office online it's a platform is
reaching its end of life and we recently
learned that oplc and D are moving away
from the original plan of an Enterprise
licensing solution for multiple state
agencies and the Liquor Commission is no
longer included in that licensing
software so in order to maintain our
Licensing Operations we need a new
licensing
platform which is estimated at about $4
million currently but we still have to
do further
research we'd be happy to take any
questions you may have thank you very
much thank you representative
wer uh thank you thank you commissioner
as somewhat unre related area your
mention of the facts that some of the
surrounding states were losing liquor
sales to
cannabis so some of the that that did
not come up in our discussions of
bringing cannabis to our state and
legalizing it I would request that you
show me some
data from the other states where after
they went
legalizing uh cannabis it's a effect on
their liquor sales so that I can bring
that up excuse me when we when we talk
about cannabis again that it's not
without some effects on some of our
other Revenue I think that's an
important point that has not been made
at this point that if that's going to
we'll hear all how we going to make
money here but if we're going to lose
money there we've got to take that into
account as well so I appreciate those
those figures you mentioned certainly
okay I just have a a quick question when
you were here two years ago one of the
uh largest issues that you were facing
is is finding sufficient workers to keep
your stores open uh in the hours that
you you you wish to has that problem
been resolved satisfactorily can you now
do you now have a sufficient employment
base to keep all your stores open to the
hours you deem necessary we have a
number of positions that we were given
in the last budget that we have held
some we have not been able to fill and
we are still quite frankly having a
difficult time filling positions uh
quite frankly the rate of pay at $165
dollars an hour is not keeping Pace with
the Private Industry so we're still
seeing a lot of folks that part- timr
specifically uh which obviously we rely
heavily on with 700 plus or minus uh we
have seen us not be able to hire in the
times that we have we have exp expanded
the hours in the stores uh with the
cutbacks of the stores through covid and
through attrition as we open larger
stores like the new store in Keen we
just opened a couple weeks ago we're
finding it a little easier to run the
stores because we have the larger
footprint and not so many smaller stores
so that's a benefit to us but that
Private Industry is still paying $189 19
$20 an hour where're at $165 an hour is
still a challenge so the answer is yes
and no we've certain we've certainly
been able to hire some additional folks
and that's been great and I think that a
lot of folks that are coming out of
retirement that previously had enough
funds to live but due to the economy now
don't we've hired a lot of people out of
us I'm car hi I'm curious how many
um how many vacancies you have roughly
right now and I know it's a number
that's in flux but I wonder if you could
divide them among full-timers I know the
part-timers are up and down um can you
divide them into the the the uh
merchandising section and then the other
three so the 280 marketing and
Merchandising which I think is mostly
store operations and then the other 87
or 90 Whatever It Is So currently we
have 26 um vacant positions there's um
one in finance two in finance and
the there's two it looks like in
enforcement and then the rest are in
store
operations and I'm sorry that's 23 you
said 26 currently
26 so it's like 22 in in uh although not
bad on
286 um I noticed in your agency budget
your your position count doesn't change
and so I assume all that I'm guessing
that this just means you're yes okay and
that's also true with a house bill two
item you want that's replacing an
existing position because it's not
listed here no that would be a new
position oh it's not in your agency
budget no no it's not I I would I'm
going to say this probably a lot of over
the next 3 days um House Bill 2 um over
the last couple of years has been used
weirdly um in large part because of
surplus funds but technically nothing
Financial should be in that document
anything financial needs to also be in
house bill one and and so and maybe not
in the agency phase but just make sure
that when you do your budget because you
can't have anything in House Bill 2
that's not accounted for in house bill
one absolutely cuz I think there's not
going to be if I were guessing Surplus
money
I think the governor guessed that too
when he said he said in the opening
something about 4% reductions that was
what he was guessing
break okay we're going to take a a
couple of minute break and uh we'll be
e
okay thank you we' like to resume the
hearing and would like to call up now
Agriculture morning commissioner
morning on my button for the record I am
Sean Jas commissioner of the Department
of Agriculture markets and food I have
with me this morning Michelle tibo our
administrative assistant and Joshua
Marshall the assistant
commissioner um I will try to give you
back some of your time and be as brief
as I can uh and this budget has been
developed to meet the efficiency
expenditure targets provided by the
governor's office the goal of the
department is to retain current Staffing
levels and maintain the Integrity of all
programs as a result the following
programs have been affected by a reu
reduction in general funds cost of care
fund the state Agricultural Fair grants
the agricultural land
preservations uh program and the Farm
Ranch stress assistance program all of
those have been reduced to roughly
20,000 uh on average for each of the two
years and I think you have
can uh access what what was in the
budget they're pretty subst stantial
reductions uh based on previous years
the Department of Agriculture gives back
to the general fund uh about 200,000 a
year meaning that we are cash positive
to the state uh by about that amount and
we expect to continue to remain cash
positive um the fund balance for our
agricultural products regulatory fund at
the end of uh fiscal 27 we expect to be
1,684 th000 in graded Pest Management um
by the end of the same period about 1.1
million that's important because of
something I'm going to to mention um as
we go through here we are in order to
maintain the budget we are relying more
on these These funds we are drawing them
down to maintain our Personnel level
this is not sustainable forever I've
said this in the past but the fund
balances are are decreasing over time
this is also where we um
are pulling have pulled money from in
the past for the animal data records
based program when I became commissioner
in 2017 I said I hoped at the end of my
tenure we will have brought our um um
systems up to the 1990s um I'm PL
pleased to say that by the end of this
fiscal year we will be in the 21st
century and all of our programs will
have been uh modernized the uh animal
database program is live now and has
been for some time in the testing phase
it has not been required for everyone to
use it but they will be using it um by
law by the first uh part of
January and um the weights and measures
program which some of you may remember
was developed by a sex offender in the
state prison in the
1980s um that will finally go away by
March uh Lorraine Merill name will come
off of the certificates issued they
won't have to put mine on a sticker
anymore uh we did have a uh contract in
place when I became commissioner but
that was a total failure and we have
pivoted and we now have the program we
need I just think it was important to
mention the it part of things we have
two
requests um in the governor's phase and
um that's they're both minor they're a
uh
moving of money around and I think you
will have those I can certainly go over
them in detail if you want but those
have been emailed in
um
and
finally uh well as part of what we've
done to uh comply with the governor's
request we will be purchasing uh no new
vehicles with general fund money in the
next bium uh no Personnel requests are
made in the in the B bium either and um
we are trying to do something which we
hope the governor's office will go along
with we trying to be more transparent
with some of our
expenditures um for many years um the
what was the product and scale testing
fund which did undergo uh legislative
changes this year um essentially was
used as a slush fund for travel there
was no real transparency there we
attempted to change that in the last
biennium we were unable to do that again
so travel appears in lines where it
hasn't before because we want you to
know where it's it's coming from and we
don't I I have never been somebody who's
been in favor of funds that you can just
use willy-nilly and I been trying to end
that and I hope that the governor will
support that um I want to mention a
fiscal item that we will be requesting
uh really the only one that involves
expenditures We'll be asking to be
submitted as a bill and that relates to
the testing of electronic uh vehicle
charging stations under existing law we
already have the obligation to test
these devices but we don't have the
budget for the testing equipment or the
Personnel to carry out this
responsibility additionally we also
believe that the fee schedule that we
would need to apply to this does not
work as we believe it should the bill we
anticipate having filed will address all
these issues given the budget
constraints and the initial startup
costs we will be asking that the first
Year's costs come from our dedicated
funds as we believe that this program is
vital to Consumer
Protection uh but we have not asked for
it to be part of house bill one or
two and we'll be glad to answer any
questions
Hi how are you I am I'm well thank you
commissioner um Josh good to see you I
see you everywhere um the um you have
two revolving funds that you list on the
on the back page of your presentation do
you have a handful of other revolving
funds the that are little I think we do
have like hearing officer fund yes that
that is it's not really it is a fund per
se but it's capped at 75,000 per year so
from fines that money goes into there up
to a maximum of 75,000 and over 75 5,000
goes back to the general fund and we
this year are sending money back to the
the general fund okay and it's that that
when you say you give back to the
general fund over 200 Grand a year
that's more than just your laps that is
more than our that is more than our laps
that is so we are cash positive to the
general fund you know and it varies it's
been I've seen it as high as 700
$800,000 um I think down into the 70s
but on average um we are cash positive
to the state general fund to the tune of
100 200,000 including
lapses okay that's good I I was looking
at your unrestricted Revenue um because
you collect something like 20125 uh fees
Etc that show up as unrestricted Revenue
in the other line I think um and you're
budgeting it at 3.3 there's something
weird in 25 where it's budgeted at 6
million is that just a weirdness that
you're not really going to raise 6
million I'm looking at like the fourth
or fifth page of your all right I of the
agency but page eight of the agency
budget document turn to Michelle for for
that answer hopefully that's why we have
Michelle
right you see what I mean looks like
there's a huge increase in weight we
Master repair licenses but like way
Master there's 2.2 for this year I
presume that just means you're not going
to get 2.2 this year and that it's going
to look more like 24 like 24 is more
real and you use that to build
26 that is correct okay that'sa so like
when we're when we're tracking when
we're building the revenue line for the
for the budget let's say we should be
using three for things that are current
probably budgeted in 25 at
six yes
got thank you very much very good we
were able to give you a little your time
that like to invite banking give their
good
morning good
morning for the record my name is Amelia
gal and I'm the bank commissioner for
the State of New Hampshire with me is
Christina Martin our director of
operations at the banking department and
Deputy Commissioner Mike
Moran thank you for the opportunity to
provide information about the banking
Department's budget
proposal the banking department is a
consumer protection focused regulatory
agency that supervises a wide variety of
financial
institutions uh I did provide a handout
kept it to one page because I'm also
going to try to give you your time back
um i' like to start my hand out with the
Department's mission statement because
everything in our budget directly
relates to the mission statement and
directly supports that mission statement
the department accomplishes its Mission
by conducting examinations of licensed
chartered financial institutions
investigating consumer complaints
bringing enforcement actions when
necessary for violations of Law and
providing Financial education Outreach
uh to New Hampshire
citizens the budget structure of the
banking department is set up in two
divisions the Banking and Trust Division
and the consumer credit division the
Banking and Trust division oversees the
activity of 17 State chared Banks seven
credit unions and 44 non-depository
trust companies and family trust
companies uh within those trust
companies are the trust companies manage
about $ 1.6 trillion in assets um and
New Hampshire banking department is the
primary or and or sole um regulatory
authority over those institutions and
those institutions are predominantly
located outside of the State of New
Hampshire so travel is required to
examine them additionally we have I
believe one that's located outside of
the United States
the consumer credit division oversees
several thousand Consumer Credit Credit
lenses so thank mortgage companies uh
payday payday lenders small loan lenders
um retail sellers so auto dealers who
take Finance applications and finally
money transmitters so like PayPal um
meta um several large money transmitter
organizations the banking Department
amongst those two divisions has 53
positions assigned to it including two
two currently vacant attorney positions
which we are actively recruiting for and
hope to fill uh
shortly um moving on to our funding
structure uh the banking department is a
self-funded
agency um what that means practically
speaking is at the start of each fiscal
year we get an appropriation over the
course of the year we collect fees and
fines application fees examination fees
Etc which are credited to that
appropriation at the end of the fiscal
year any shortfall between the
appropriation and the those fine fine
and fee amounts gets um collected
through an assessment on our chartered
and licensed entities we usually only
have to do an assessment on the
chartered entities usually there's
enough fees and fines generated by the
consumer credit entities that we don't
them moving on to our budget proposal uh
the banking Department um was directed
to Flat fund to the adjusted authorized
amount for fiscal year
25 um we were permitted in the second
year of the budget proposal to um fund
statutory and Contra contractual
increases in salaries and benefits so
this was a challenge for us because we
are an agency that's nearly 89% salaries
benefits Etc we don't have a lot of
stuff that we can cut um so how did we
accomplish that directive um in fiscal
year 26 we defunded one of our two doit
positions
um we currently have a project underway
to move most of our data that we
currently um utilize at the department
into like a vendor manage manage system
that's paid for by the dues that we pay
to a
um organizational dues that we pay to
our the conference of State Bank
supervisors um and additionally we are
trying to move out of access databases
for our internal recordkeeping system
and into a more modern cloud-based
system um and because of that project we
felt comfortable defunding the one
position and uh feel like we can move
forward in that position um we also
defunded an attorney position that was
embedded at the doj that we no longer
use we didn't use the services of so we
defunded that
position for fiscal year 27 we cut
funding to our travel and training lines
um while we can live with this cut it is
going to have a fundamental impact on
how we accomplish our mission during the
pandemic we disc we learned and
confirmed that we can do exams offsite
for one or two exam cycles and feel
comfortable with the risk associated
with that however conducting
examinations fully offsite repeatedly
does increase the risk to New Hampshire
consumers and the reputational risk to
the state as a whole um it's very
important that we set foot in the
entities that are licensed and chartered
by us to see what is going on boots on
the ground and all
that um in fisc in fiscal year 2024 we
conducted approximately 370
examinations um in fiscal year 25 we are
on track to conduct over 400
examinations due to statutory changes um
that require us to now examine all the
retail sellers in the that are licensed
by us in the state of New
Hampshire um we feel comfortable that we
can absorb that increase because we've
been able to reallocate examiner
positions across divisions um to do that
effectively we have to train those
people to be able to examine a bank one
day a money transmitter the next day and
so on um so that does mean that we have
some increased training needs for those
examiners because many our most
increasing area at the department is in
complex fintech um companies that are
ever changing so training is very very
important to us so that our examiners
can go out and competently examine those
entities um and I am concerned that cuts
to that training line May exacerbate or
put us behind the curve slightly on
those training needs but I do think we
could live with it uh so that's kind of
it for my substantive presentation about
the budget um I would draw your
attention to the end of the handout um
in
2023 um we did um achieve uh facilitate
over $1 million in restitution for over
2,000 New Hampshire consumers um
additionally we facilitated resolution
over over
100 consumer complaints in calendar year
2024 to date um I also include a link to
our strategic plan if you want to see
any further details about what we do at
the banking Department what our plans
are going forward um I am proud of the
work that the department does and I'm
questions uh the examinations you do uh
are they more uh obviously they're I say
traditional scheduled examinations but
to what extent are they situationally
based and and why I ask that is when
when interest rates uh shot up over the
last few years uh especially over the
last year uh a number of banks we we saw
the well publicized case out in
California had significant liquidity
crisis does that increase the amount of
examinations you're doing here locally
or is it just something or or okay
you're saying yes so you could just go
into that in a little more detail sure
so um are we do have regularly
scheduled examination set by a statute
um some entities get examined every 12
months 18 months 24 months some are
three years some are five years it
depends on the entity type so those are
routinely done outside of that we have
the ability to go in if we get a lot of
consumer complaints about an institution
so when I started at the banking
Department it was the height of the
mortgage crisis and I was an enforcement
attorney so we went in and did a lot of
um you know unannounced sort of
visitations or investigations where we
went on site um and those were
particularly locally for the most part
at the time um so it is really e
economically driven um with the
liquidity issues going on we are keeping
a close eye on that and we do have um
for our banks we have co-regulator we
co-regulate banks with the federal
government FDIC or the um fed um so we
do increase our visitations on site but
a lot of that work can if it depending
on the nature of it really depends on
do you do you uh in your in your Dunning
of in your not done assessment okay your
assessment of people do you assess the
Banking and Trust divisions and Consumer
Credit divisions separately and as a
entity so they have a different set of
people you build and you only build for
those costs correct so we act that's why
we have it in two two buckets for the
purposes of the budget people are
assigned to either bucket do you do you
do an internal cost app for admin yes we
do like for you yep yep all of us uh at
this table for example are split I am
paid out at the banking division he's
paid out of the CCD division but CCD for
her too um so we do track we try to keep
it an even split um based on you know
how many entities etc etc so instead of
instead of an allocation you do a you do
a just like you're here I'm here yeah
cuz like we try to keep it even it gets
complicated if we have to split a
position in half so we tend to do whole
positions you say you tend to do you
have any I don't think we did at one
point in the past but we don't currently
okay I would prefer not to because I
think that is complicated I like to keep
things very very simple Yes simple and
and I I just I asked we actually
internally in a couple of places went
the opposite direction because it but it
was over like 40 places and it was it
became inaccurate in your con Consumer
Credit you have a you have a giant
increase in your class
49 can you explain that remind me which
one's
49 like it goes from our grand to 142
grand I'm looking at page 23 of the
agency
budget yeah so that's the
EAP division and you're going to stop
doing EAP nope nope it did change can I
get back to you on that yeah no that's
fine I just yeah it sort of jumps yeah I
think it's tied to EAP so I'm not sure
it's just the cost we get from DHHS
yeah I'm guessing it's more than a grand
next year though if it was 142 this year
well
so because your employee count probably
didn't go down that much no it did go up
though sorry it did go up our employee
count increased to 53 whereas I think
before we were 49 or 50 50 mhm right so
I would guess then that you would go
from like 142 to 150 not 142 to one I
think we we also had money in there for
two part-time positions that we never
used so we eliminated that out of the
budget too and I think that might all be
in because that's I think 49 is payments
oh and that's also the payment to other
agency it's the doj position that I
mentioned so that's where we paid that
I apologize let my brain that actually
probably makes more sense yes that does
make way more sense I apologize that's
okay no big deal I'm not as good with
the class numbers is no nobody nobody he
us except Michelle okay thank you thank
you now we like to bring up the veterans
home
good morning I'd like to uh wish you and
especially your residents a very happy
belated Veterans
Day on or off on now yes thank you very
much we appreciate
that um I'm Kim McKay I'm the Comon of
the New Hampshire veterans home and with
me today I have our CFO Jennifer dog we
do have a a lengthy power presentation
but I promise you I'll I'll pul through
it pretty quick
uh just for those who don't know about
us uh in 1989 or excuse me 1889 uh to
take advantage of the federal assistance
the governor at the time made up the
board of managers and started the
veterans home so in December December
3rd we will actually be having uh our
anniversary of 134 years and in 134
years there's been 11 commants which is
pretty impressive there's only been 11
leaders there we are made up of a board
of managers that oversees our some of
our operations so we have a unique
position with the board of man managers
and they are made up of 12 members who
are appointed by the governor and
confirmed by the executive Council
commanders from the American Legion the
veteran of Foreign Affairs and the
disabled American veterans and nine
citizens make up our Board of managers
two of those 12 members are are um
members in our res our residents in our
facility one one male one female and the
board has oversight of the veterans
benefit fund operations as well as who
the commant is um so that's a unique
situation in itself that they oversee
how we spend that uh donated money that
comes from our community to support all
of our veterans organization or um
recreational
activities today we are a long-term
Intermediate Care Facility and we offer
a broad range of residential medical and
nursing care for veterans only this is
unique because most states have um
bigger or many more veterans homes so
they can offer a placement for spouses
or Golds our parents as well but we
unfortunately have only one veterans
home and uh we focus on the veterans
we're licensed for 250 residents we have
been budgeted historically for
225 residents and we have 384 staff as I
spoke last time and I will probably keep
speaking to you our greatest challenge
has been recruiting and retaining staff
um with the clinical side and the uh
Support
Services again uniquely we have um we
are uh licensed by the VA and we are um
enabled to uh act get pum payments
through the C 38 CFR
5141 and residents um the veterans
either have partial pay or full pay for
their stay with us us our mission
statement of the New Hampshire Veterans
Home is to provide the best quality of
life for New Hampshire veterans with
dignity honor and respect and our staff
um are very honored to serve those who
have
served I talk about achievements because
it's really important to show where
we're going and where we've been uh we
had created a LNA training licensed
nursing assistant training program
because we have the biggest need in the
uh nursing field and so in April 22 we
started that course and we've had seven
courses and have rendered 30 new
lnas um and now they are working with us
we have also created a licensed
medication nursing assistant program
which allows lnas who have at least a
minimum of a Year's experience to be
able to take a course to become um have
the ability to pass medications under
the supervision of a nurse and so we
started that program February 2024 and
we now have 10 new elemes in our um in
our
Workforce in 2024 we were awarded the
outstanding energy efficience project um
with a sponsorship provided by
eversource and Das um we had a light uh
facility wide lighting Improvement
project and our hope is that it's going
to save us about 50% on our utility
bills for lights uh they replaced every
single light in our
facility we've also improved our
security by adding additional security
cameras we were uh awarded some enhanced
monies um through the sweep and um we've
been able to in Phase One improve our um
technology structure through our
facility we use Med carts that use um
Wi-Fi and so it was spotty in some areas
and now we are able to offer the Wi-Fi
coverage throughout the facility as well
to our residents and phase two will be
to to have that all upgraded and take
place with the new equipment updates for
conference rooms to allow to have uh
care plan meetings with families and
calls with families who are not able to
come to the
facility one of the proudest things I'm
um I'm going to speak about is the
admissions process historically uh it
has taken about a year to be uh from
step one of admitting uh doing your
application to the admission and we've
been able to cut that down to 3 to six
months months now uh sometimes so fast
that families are shocked because it's
so quick uh they they were uh planning
it to have like a lot more time to uh
make that final decision but we are now
moving really quickly and we're up to uh
3 to six months before they um are
offered a bed and we have looked at our
contracts that we had and we're
minimizing occupational and physical
therapy contracts that we had by going
to a previous model where we had a
full-time physical therapist so we
reclassed a position position and we've
hired a physical therapist who will
oversee our therapy department um and
cut some of that contract money down as
well as have a benefit to our veterans
where they aren't going to have to pay a
co-pay uh they right now sometimes
refuse therapy because they don't want
to pay a co-pay that they were being
contractors our staffing as it relates
we um and I didn't know that Charlie
didn't like um vacancy rates and those
kind of things so we'll just slide right
through that Charlie um I particularly
like the way you did your slide okay all
right all right thank you um so with our
current vacancy rate of 45 for L uh
about 46% for lnas and 39% for nurses
we've currently capped our consensus at
140 uh to meet the needs um with that
said we plan to go to the
225 and I think that we're on the right
path we've had some nursing management
changes so we're looking at how we can
more effectively use our staff so with
the current numbers right now we're uh
toying with the idea of going up to 150
and uh as we are able to recruit we plan
to increase that for recruiting uh
efforts we've enhanced our efforts by
attending job fairs posting on College
platforms like handshake uh local
newspapers interestingly that still
brings people in from our local area uh
and adding the ability to obtain uh cus
continuing education units that sounds
like a small thing but for a nurse or an
LNA who needs to maintain their license
uh for us to have a very small cost with
a uh educational program called
Healthcare academies we're going to be
able to provide cus for those people
with licensures um which will then
attract more people that can do it on
work time we've also Consolidated
partial units to maximize staff on full
units uh We've expanded light duty to uh
work programs so that when people are in
light duty they can come back and do
something maybe that wasn't a nursing
but something else that's still going to
help us where we have vacancies uh We've
increased the number of volunteer
opportunities when the facility and
without our volunteers we would be lost
they do so much for us and our veterans
and we continue to a mandate of 4 hours
per pay period for nursing um to meet
the minimum
requirements our strategic key uh
priorities this year or the next two
years grow the veterans the veteran
resident census that is one of our key
we want to meet all the need anybody who
needs a place with us we want to be able
to offer that and uh open the door we
want to reduce the number of vacant
staff positions we must always meet the
VA survey requirements that's how we are
paid and that's how we are licensed um
Health Life Safety initiatives like the
camera system so we can see if someone
had a fall did they hit their head what
were the circumstances how do we fix
that uh vehicle and Equipment upgrades
um one of our um veterans had told one
of the
um politicians that was walking through
that he is embarrassed to get in our
rust bucket of a bus and so we do have
uh some vehicle upgrades that we're
working on uh one of them uh we did get
a new bus but our other bus is quite
Rusty so we're working on getting those
done it infrastructure upgrades like I
spoke about uh updating our conference
room so families can communicate with
their loved ones more easily than trying
to do it on a FaceTime iPad the ongoing
Building Maintenance we have some
capital budget projects that speak to
that our building is aging as most state
buildings are and then the Veterans Home
Building addition uh we had money set
aside in 2016 that had been waiting from
the state side we committed to a project
and the VA has um now come through with
those funds so we are 100% designed is
completed for a 20 bed private bathroom
unit um so that that neighborhood can
offer a higher dignity it also will have
more bariatric beds on those units so
that we can meet the needs as we
see the executive summary we did
discover um with some uh help from our
friends at Das that we had not been play
paying something called class 42
additional French benefits
postretirement and so we need to add
that to our budget which has uh
increased our budget and um pay our fair
share so um we did add that into our
budget um and these other uh additional
fundings uh you will see are based on a
census if we don't hit that number then
obviously we would lapse that money back
um but they're around salary benefits
due to step increases food costs um do
you do you want me stop oh okay I
um techn technical technology upgrades
um part-time positions and prescription
drugs um to accommodate the increase in
the veterans
census again I have already said we are
250 beds we have 225 for Budget uh we'd
like to try to keep that budget um and
increase our staff and uh increase our
um veteran count I do say here that we
have uh 21 applications in process and
we have 12 um already approved so with
134 of veterans today we have 33 waiting
and so we know that we can move up
fairly quickly if we had enough staff to
do that um and we believe that the
Staffing is getting better um because of
the raises we are seeing more nursing
applications which is great um so we had
a census goal over the last two years
we've increased about 16% to of our
census and we want to keep going so that
nobody is looking for a bed we lose a
lot of veterans um who go to other
nursing home settings because the
families have a crisis and they need a
bed right away and we haven't had that
ability to offer that but we're moving
in that direction with a three minimum
um weight period most families are uh
going through the process so we can
offer those beds
quickly our current census is 134 we
have some pending admissions right now
to go up to 140 um we have 122 men and
12 women and our average AG is about 83
years um we have over 30 people right
now in our resident uh in our residency
with uh overage 90 and we actually have
one veteran who will be turning a 100 in
January so it's it's been great um this
is our median yearly census you can see
that it kind of dropped down and we know
what caused that in in
2021 um and you can see where it's
starting to move up and we're hoping to
keep going up over the next few
years this is our resident uh discharge
and admissions um so our discharges were
um quite they dipped down during covid
um and they're still a little high um
but that is to be expected when you have
an age an average age of 83 years
old uh branch of military I always add
this to anything I do because it's
always competitive um the Army still is
the most representative with 56
residents Marines are 10 Navy 38 Air
Force 25 National Guard uh two and coast
guards three so um army still wins we'll
see what happens at the football game um
conflict era served we have four w war
two veterans and if anybody had a chance
to see the union leader on Sunday they
did a big u p uh big news about us and
our four veterans they highlighted them
uh career conflict we have had we have
31 Vietnam is our largest 77 and we
anticipate that to be growing we do have
one Gulf War resident and we have 21
that either served during war uh peace
time or have not identified uh a time
frame when they
served is this your snapshot you like
Charlie the vacancy
snapshot um so this will tell our
vacancies in our field um and again we
still um we still have a need we have 82
and I really focus on LNA and nurses
because that those positions can dictate
whether our census is higher or lower um
food service has a little bit of effect
there but you know maintenance is
maintenance our building is our building
uh so the LNA vacancies are still um I
don't want to interrupt but I can you
can you talk to that because it's
something that people people wonder
about all the time as we go through like
what are your like your census today is
capped because of the Staffing yes and
how much additional Staffing would get
you to a I assume it's steps not yes yes
so I think um so we have when we look at
units like a small unit that I have is a
14 bed unit and to open that unit I need
at least three nurses with relief Factor
so I need four and a half nurses and
then I need um nine lnas with a relief
Factor so when we hit those we can open
another unit right now how we're doing
our growth is that we have some units
that have double beds and we have been
keeping them as singles but they have
the capability of going above and doing
the double rooms and some people benefit
from having a roommate you know we have
to know our residents and know what
their social um ability is and so right
now that's why I'm saying we're capping
at 140 but we're looking at doing an
additional 10 because we can look at
those double rooms and that won't impact
the staff count so we're trying to be
really creative with a current staff we
have getting that census up because the
more the census up the more federal
funds we have um so it's this Catch 22
where we have to have the censes to have
the finances um so each time we can go
another step we can have more residents
come
in vacancy rate combined our overall um
is 36.7 overall some of those are
purposefully um I have as an example I
have um a nurse practitioner that I have
been holding back because at 2:25 we
would need two nurse practitioners but
at 140 we don't need two we only need
one and a half so I've had a half a
part-time position added to our 50 align
50 money and holding on that full-time
which we're saving benefits the same
with Recreation you know we have a
pretty robust recreational staff but if
we don't have 225 residents then we can
hold back to those recreational
positions um until we get to that 225 so
the rate is um
somewhat not clear because some of these
are purposeful they're not all um me you
know we're not all recruiting however
nursing in uh laas we recruit for all
the time and I will say two years ago um
we had a 49% vacancy rate for nurses and
today it's
39.7 and we're seeing applications for
nurses I'm not sure where they're coming
from but we love it and we don't want to
stop it so uh we hope they
continue we have three sources of
revenue that are solely dependent on
Resident census the federal revenue is
the VA per DM that's given to the home
on a monthly basis for the number of
residents residing at the home the
current prdm rate that is called a basic
rate is
$144 and the higher pum rate which we is
called a prevailing rate um is uh
$587 prevailing rate uh residents are
those who have a 70% or more uh
disability rating and because of the
pact act we're seeing a lot more
residents who are qualifying for that
prevailing rate right now we had this
past month 16 residents that qualified
for that higher rate um which helps our
uh Revenue the agency Revenue uh is the
income coming from room in board some of
our residents pay full room and board if
they have assets over three 30 uh
$330,000 until that asset drops they
will pay the full rate which is
$349 per day um or
$1,444 per month once they get under
that
$30,000 then they would go down to a
partial pay and that is decided with a
um long process with the VA of how much
they pay so it goes by income the lower
their income the less they pay
us the general fund dollars are matched
with the federal revenue and agency
income and as you can see to the side
here currently 30% of our uh funds are
paid for are we are paid for by uh
federal funds 24% by residents and 46%
by General funds that changes as we have
more more of a
mix this is just a historical of where
we spent from fy2 to 24 of actual cost
and so we broke this down for from the
federal side of what we um accur accured
from them and then the resident
side again historical where we had
expenditures so you can see where we've
come
from and I know this isn't the place
because this is operational budget but
we did mention our capital budget
requests we have four of them um one is
to replace rooftop air handlers um the
current ones are over 30 years old we
got the the analogy the my operations
officer tells me is we got the motor in
the transmission changed out this year
emergently but the body is rusting all
around it which is going to affect the
motor in the transmission again so we're
trying to replace that motor part uh
excuse me the vehicle part uh we have a
request to replace seven resident tubs
in a bariatric shower uh the tubs we are
now they're so they're aged so much were
taking pieces from the closed units to
fix the old tub so it's a crisis at this
point um and we replace one elevator and
update two as well as bring one of our
our two units that are the oldest to Ada
compliancy some of the rooms we can't
have residents go into with certain
wheelchairs because they're not wide
enough and so we we'd like to work on
that um so we've have a high a high TR
um trans excuse me tradition of
providing high quality care and to be
coste effective when we can um and so
we're hoping with the support of the
governor the new governor and this
committee that we will continue that
tradition I'm open to any
questions thank you uh just to to
summarize your your your current
um census is 134 the budget you've
submitted would allow you to go up to
225 assuming you can find yes sir the
the the nursing staff and other uh
employees to fill those
positions uh if hypothetical question
but if if a if a Plane full of nurses
and custodial staff and uh Food Service
handlers showed up and you were fully
staffed is the demand there right now
for 225 if we look at our numbers right
now today if I could take everybody it
would be 167 and that's without
advertising to our veteran service
organization partners that we have a
short or no weight I do believe that we
could easily fill our facility with no
short or a small weight be right now
traditionally most people say if you
want to go to the New Hampshire Veterans
Home Plan a year uh the process is going
to take that long and again as I said
most most people need a quicker fix than
that we still do do transfers from other
nursing homes they've gone to a nursing
home and they still want to come to the
veterans home um so I think we could we
could go up if a plane of nurses come
and they want to work for us I think we
need thank you very much thank you sir
thank you uh the hearing is now in
recess and we'll uh regroup again at
1:15
p.m.
e
good afternoon I would encourage
everyone to take your seats so we can
session uh to begin this afternoon
session I would like to invite the
department of safety to come up for
their
afternoon good afternoon sir I'm Robert
Quinn Comm commissioner of the
Department of Safety and with me today
is Amy Newbury our director of
administration we're here to discuss the
department of safety's budget requests
for fiscal years 2026 and
2027 the mission of the Department of
Safety is to consistently enhance safety
security and the quality of life in New
Hampshire through professional
collaborative and Innovative services
our departments consist of seven
division each with its own Public Safety
mandate and are uniquely
funded demand for Public Safety Services
continues to grow across all areas as to
the demands on our
Workforce in developing this budget we
followed our strategic plans ensuring
that our primary goals remain Central
While acknowledging the challenges and
constraints that lie ahead we set
expectations at every level mindful that
each division has specific evolving
needs identified through key ke
performance
indicators this message outlines the
challenges faced by the department due
to high vacancy rates budget constraints
and the need for
modernization despite these challenges
the team has successfully maintained
Public Safety
Services however as operational costs
have risen driven by increasing salaries
equipment replacement expenses and a
greater dependence on it infrastructure
some critical positions remain unfunded
this is affecting Staffing levels and
delaying technology upgrades while
online services and system Replacements
as well to sustain essential Public
Safety Services and meet growing demands
the department has identified a funding
requirement of 2.1 million for both
fiscal year 2026 and fiscal year
2027 throughout today's presentation
we'll discuss the impact of these
priority needs on Public Safety across
New Hampshire securing FS for all vacant
positions remains a top priority and we
respectfully request that resources be
allocated accordingly if available
director Amy Newbury will now outline
the essential Public Safety mission of
each of our seven divisions and provide
a summary of changes priority needs and
impacts on the delivery of services
we're happy to answer any questions you
may have during or at the conclusion of
our presentation thank you thank you
commissioner and good afternoon everyone
let's dive into the Pres presentation
beginning on page two which offers an
overview of the Department's
organizational structure as the
commissioner highlighted the department
of safety is composed of seven divisions
each with distinct functions funding
sources this structure makes it logical
to present our budget request on a
division by division basis which is our
approach today before we delve into each
division page three provides a
comprehensive summary of the overall
departmental budget request
for fiscal year 2026 the department of
safety has requested a total of 265
million and for fiscal year 2027 273
million to support Public Safety
Services across the state These funds
cover
1,151 full-time classified positions and
14 unclassified roles though 34
classified positions identified as high
priority needs are not included in these
totals the department is largely driven
by personnel with 60% of its budget
dedicated to salaries and benefits while
the remainder covers operating expenses
including funds and grants distributed
to local and other state agencies the
fiscal year 26 budget has increased by
10 million due to Rising operational
cost in contractual
obligations turning to page four we move
on to to the office of the commissioner
this office not only oversees the entire
department and its seven divisions but
also directly supervises the office of
Highway Safety the department of
safety's legal unit and the Bureau of
hearings on page five the depart the
budget request of the office of
commissioner is outlined with 20.2
million salt for fiscal year 26 and 20.5
million for fiscal year 27 of this
budget 38% is allocated to salary and
benefits for its 45 classified and three
unclassified positions many operating
costs are Federal grant Awards processed
by office of Highway Safety and Homeland
currently there are no unfunded
positions in this unit the office
includes the Bureau of hearings which
handles almost 14,000 hearings each year
and the office of Highway Safety which
in federal fiscal year 24 awarded more
than 2.5 million to 136 local police
departments this year's budget remains
relatively even additionally some
prioritized needs are
highlighted 9,000 for the vium which is
estimated and prioritized by the
department of Information Technology and
317,000 for facility maintenance at 33
houen drive as prioritized by the
department of administrative services
on page six presents the division of
administration's organizational chart
this division provides internal Support
Services across the Department of Safety
Division and comprises of six bureaus
financial management Human Resources
asset and Resource Management Road tool
grants management and Facilities
Management on page seven details the
division of administration's budget
request of 13 million for fiscal year 26
and 14 million for fiscal year 27 of
this 66% covers salary and benefits for
84 classified and three unclassified
employees there are three
unfunded positions in fiscal year 26 and
one for fiscal year 27 identified as
priori
needs Key activities in the division of
administration include the road tool
bureau's collection of 183 million in
fiscal year 23 to support the highway
fund Additionally the mail unit
processed 1.9 million pieces of incoming
and 1 million pieces of outgoing mail
while the plate room distributed 555,000
license plates and 2 million Fleet
decals to municipalities and D&B
substations across the
state the overall budget has decreased
slightly from fiscal year 25 to fiscal
year year 26 in Department of
Information Technology expenses to meet
budget Targets on page eight details
several prioritized needs within the
division of administration including the
necessity of filling a vacant Road tool
position audits conducted in this role
are crucial to ensuring compliance with
the state's road toll gas tax leaving it
unfilled may lead to incomplete
reporting which could negatively impact
Highway fund Revenue Additionally the
training role is vital to advancing
process Improvement initiatives by
focusing on continuous development of
Staff this position ensures alignment
and provides thorough information during
process changes without it the
Department's capacity for ongoing
training and efficiency gains is limited
the mail clerk role is also critical as
it helps prevent delays in processing
the large volume of incoming and
outgoing mail any delays in processing
can have significant impacts on
municipalities and the DMV
substations on page 9 we transition to
the Division of Motor Vehicles the dnb's
mission is to enhance Public Safety on
New Hampshire's roads by ensuring all
drivers vehicles and service providers
are properly credentialed the division
consists of six burea driver licensing
financial responsibility which handles
driv driving history records operations
registration title and an Administration
section on page 10 the Division of Motor
Vehicles presents its budget request
seeking 34.3 million for fiscal year 26
and 34.2 million for fiscal year
27 of this budget 56% supports salary
and benefits for
210 full-time classified and two
unclassified positions additionally
seven classifi positions currently
remain unfunded and are listed under
prioritized needs in fiscal year 24 the
dnv issued
372,117 motor vehicle titles conducted
71,3 skills and road tests and produced
primarily reflects billing vacancies and
pl doit projects attributed to the
maintenance of critical DMV systems the
vision system and the map system both of
these systems are essential to daily DMB
operations at substations and local
municipalities and must be properly
maintained to ensure uninterrupted
service on page 11 outlines prioritized
needs for the
DMV the Department of Motor Vehicles has
has identified personnel as its top
priority requesting funding to fill
various vacant positions to prevent
service delays and here are their key
points number one license examiners
funding is needed to fill three
full-time vacant license examiner
positions two CDL examiners and one
driver license bureau position without
this CDL and license driver license
applicants may experience delays in
eding Road skilled test and some DMV
locations May no longer offer daily
driver licensing tests two division-wide
positions the dnv also seeks funding for
four full-time vacancies across the
division including two internal Auditors
one supervisor for Motor Vehicle
Registration one administrator in
administration cutting these positions
would lead to longer customer wait times
processing delays and hinder the dnb's
capacity to perform essential tests such
as hiring safety monitors conducting
data analysis and managing public
information and lastly number three part
part-time
positions these rules are essential for
handling back office duties and
providing customer service at
information desks counters phone lines
and his safety monitors reducing funding
for ptime positions would result in
increased weight times for both in
office and phone Services overall these
Cuts would significantly significantly
impact DMV operations and customer
service quality leading to slower
processing and reduced availability of
services on page 12 presents the
division of State Police organizational
structure as New Hampshire's state law
enforcement State Police oversees
highways toll roads and interstates
enforcing state laws and ensuring Public
Safety the division operates seven troop
stations a Marine Patrol facility an
aircraft hanger and provides security at
critical locations like the Legislative
Office Building state house and New
Hampshire Hospital
campus page 13 details the state police
and benefits for 574 classified and one
unclassified position 36 positions in
fiscal year 26 are unfunded and 16 are
unfunded in fiscal year 27 in fiscal
year 24 State Police made 91,92 motor
vehicle stops arrested
1,233 impaired drivers and conducted
6,299 criminal
investigations page 14 a prioritized
request of 580,000 is made for
additional
equipment the division of State Police
is currently has 66 vacant positions
which will be filled as students
complete the police standards and
training Council Academy given the fixed
schedule of three Academy sessions per
fiscal year with an average of 12
students per class we are allocating
funding and filling positions
accordingly this phased approach allows
us to align equipment needs within the
budget limits
effectively the a 2.7 million increase
in fiscal year 26 is attributed to an
annual contract increases particularly
for the New Hampshire hospital security
contract and the upkeep of the digital
evidence in camera in vehicle camera and
body camera system a 2.1 million
increase in overtime cost is driven by
Staffing vacancies heightened service
demand and Rising salary expenses
equipment cost ref
a decrease of 1.8 million in fiscal year
26 and 1.6 million in fiscal year 27 due
to the budget
reductions this translates to cuts of 26
tahos and 17 portable radios in fiscal
year 26 and 46 tahos in 50 portable
radios in fiscal year
27 on page 15 introduces the division of
Homeland Security and emergency
management responsible for ordinating
New Hampshire's response to major
natural and human-made
disasters page 16 details hm's budget
request of 26.5 million for fiscal year
26 and 26.8 million for fiscal year 27
with 28% allocated to 42 classified and
two unclassified positions and 72%
towards operating funds mostly federal
grants through famous Homeland Security
program in fiscal year 22 HSM activated
the state's Emergency Operations Center
12 times facilitated 264 exercises and
approved 44 local Hazard mitigation
plans page 17 outlines two unfunded
vacant positions identified as
prioritized needs to continue to conduct
robust number of training and exercises
enhancing capabilities to respond to
Future
emergencies page 18 present prevents
presents the division of emergency
services and
Communications which operates the New
Hampshire's enhance 911 system and
maintains the state radio network on
page 19 the division division's budget
request is outlined at 20.1 million for
fiscal year 26 and 20.6 million for
fiscal year 27 with 74% of these funds
dedicated to salaries and benefits for
130 classified employees and and one
unclassified employee each fiscal year
seven positions remained vacant and
unfunded in fiscal year 24 the division
processed
434,447 urgent law enforcement requests
averaging a
99.66% quality assurance rate completed
123 transfers to the 988 hotline and
managed
1,440 record requests from law
enforcement
agencies on page 20 the prioritized
needs include SE securing funding for
fully to fully stuff five vacant
telecommunicator positions these
essential responders handle all 911
calls in New Hampshire acting as the
critical coordination point for the
state and local agencies during
emergencies reductions in Staffing could
delay respon resp times potentially
jeopardizing lives and slower access to
Patient Care and critical life-saving
instructions in addition funding is
requested to fill two vacant technical
support specialist positions these roles
are crucial to Des um capacity to
support field communications during
unexpected events without these
positions Des support to New Hampshire
State Police HSM during EOC activations
and direct assistance to the radio Chief
would be impacted potentially leading to
delayed and outsourced radio repairs and
maintenance resulting in slower response
and increased cost on page 21 move to
the division of buer standards and
training and EMS which is dedicated to
training certifying and supporting
emergency responders in New Hampshire
page 22 details the division's 11.2
million budget request for fiscal year
26 and 11.5 million for fiscal year 27
with 72 % of funds supporting 40
classified and one unclassified position
in fiscal year 24 the division enrolled
35,6 121 students issued
1,680 certifications licensed 6,76 EMS
providers and licensed 502 ambulances
page 23 focuses on the division of fire
safety which aims to prevent deaths and
prevent property loss through fire
safety education enforcement and
investigation
page 24 details the division's budget
request of 5.8 million for fiscal year
26 and 5.8 million for fiscal year 27
with 80% dedicated to salaries and
benefits for 26 classified and one
unclassified employee in fiscal year 24
the division investigated 87 fire
incidences conducted 1,89 safety
inspections and completed
1,112 building plan reviews a 4 million
allocation from the general fund is
essential as the fire fund currently
supported by fees from driver history
records is underfunded due to a lower
than expected revenues following fee
increases to sustain operations and meet
statutory obligations a 4 million
transfer from the to the fire fund is
requested to maintain existing levels of
service to Residents and local agencies
this appropriation non-aps pursuant to
RSA 21-b
12-d in
conclusion we have developed a budget to
meet our identified targets while also
highlighting areas where additional
support is necessary to fulfill
statutory requirements this budget
sustains essential Public Safety
Services for New Hampshire through
fiscal year 2026 in
2027 however several critical positions
remain unfunded due to budget
limitations Rising salary and benefits
increased equipment replacement cost and
a growing dependency on it operational
costs have also risen due to
infrastructure and system requirements
prioritized needs funding of 4.2 million
is crucial to support Public Safety as
our department works to meet the
expanding demand for services at all
levels any future budget cuts will
impact Service delivery and this
concludes our budget summary for fiscal
year 26 and 27 and we're open to
questioning thank
you um I have a a question over the last
this this really focuses on specifically
for for DMV but but I guess it's a it's
a broader
question uh overall uh in the last year
I know I've I've renewed my driver's
license my car registration through my
town I requested and I requested a title
for my car and I believe I did it all on
my phone
have the and it all worked great have
these technological changes that have
allowed for
Simplicity allowed you to reduce costs
in other areas whether it be uh through
Personnel costs or other areas how has
that techn technological changes to make
life simpler from the consumer side
helped you in in reducing budgets in
other areas to make up for the increase
so I think the the the simple answer to
that is these improvements going online
wherever we can have been going on for a
couple of years now so what we do is we
continue to monitor uh the answer to
that is we monitor customer service in
every every branch of the DMV whether
it's wait times on calls how long it
takes to issue a title there are still
things and transactions that have to be
done uh by a person so we continue to
monitor that but the bu budget that we
present today takes into account the
services that have been uh put online
prior to this and we continue to do this
um as we look forward to our uh etitle
Ean program so we'll continue to look at
whatever efficiencies that we gain on
costs hi um
um couple things oh I was told to not
keep this so close to me I'm too loud
um so is there anything I'm going to ask
a two-part question right so so the the
budget has some significant increases
and and I think your presentation does a
really good job of outlining the the
impact of all the things you had to cut
and would like back so to speak
um if there's anything let's say you
were let's say the the next Governor
looked at the agency draft and went yeah
okay and just kind of went forward with
it um um can you think a little bit
about if there are anomalies in that
that you've noticed since the time of
the agency draft where yeah okay
wouldn't work and there's something you
might want to look at and then the
second part of that is have you have you
started thinking at all about um uh so
you're cut I'm going to guess it was a
4% general fund cut what if in the what
if in the governor's phase of the budget
um the direction is make
four8 and have you have you had internal
discussions I'm not asking for you to
point out things today but have you had
internal discussions about what eight
instead of four might look
like well not specifically to that
number but I mean we are we have worked
very closely with the you know the
division directors on this and as you
know Amy I think stated perfectly this
allows us to maintain more Cuts would
impact you know customer service and and
safety and we would have to have those
conversations and look at not be deliv
it or I mean when you look at customer
service it's it's weight times um so
there's customer service on how long it
takes to get a registration issued or a
title um but uh to get the telephone
answered but then on the public safety
side having adequate resources out there
to meet the demands um for investigating
crimes and we would have to um go back
and and we would have those
conversations and relook at it but we
have not specifically looked at what an
additional 4% would do okay I just was
to I just um second question is about
State Police what are your current uh
Trooper vacancies because they're pretty
high aren't they sure yes yes sir so as
of this I think we put 66 in here
there's actually 67 but what I will tell
you is um as we prepared this budget we
worked on structuring this and being I
would say fiscally responsible and
understanding what we believe we can
hire you know knowing and I believe we
plan on potentially 12 per class and you
can only absorb so many into the
division at one point but what we're
looking at we've got 60 67 vacancies
today we have 10 that are in the
pipeline to be hired we just had a class
on November uh a test November 9th and I
believe we have eight
that are in the background process now
so they are working um as diligently as
possible without lowering their
standards so you think we might have
seen the peak
of you know we rely on a lot on Troopers
for so many things um do you think we
might have seen the peak of the the or
the valley I guess of the sure well
hiring issues sure it's
it's not my opinion but in speaking to
the state police they're seeing more
interest in the testing um the quality
of candidate
uh is improving and um so we're um
optimistic we're optimistic and and if
they do the best they can um they
generally will look at the numbers are
pretty consistent if you know 88 sign up
to take a test they know how many may
actually show up and out of those how
many go to background we'll make it
through um so they're pretty consistent
when we developed this and we looked at
that number 12 we felt consistent that
we were going to be and that was the
state police worked very hard in that
looking at the data and working with uh
director Newbery do you do you think
there's potential for if we
um you know this isn't something we do
in every area right but but let's say we
ended up UNF funding some number of
positions just pick a number um and yet
hiring was going
well
um maybe something we could look at
something like putting language in the
budget that would allow despite those
being unfunded if the recruitment
succeeded to a greater extent than we
thought possible some sort of mechanism
to I don't even know what go to fiscal
or something to fill positions right is
that something you've experienced in the
past no but I think I think filling
these positions is is Paramount to
Public Safety in New Hampshire so
whether you had to delay it as long as
there was a solution if we had a good
candidate and we had um we had a spot at
the police academy and we could get them
in there like I said we've done that now
in this budget so we've unfunded a
certain number of position we have 66
vacancies we unfunded 36 and 26 and 16
and 27 that leaves us 30 to higher we
also know that we um we lose
1.5 per month so over the course of the
year we can plan on attrition of have
being down 18 due to retirements whatnot
so we're looking at the numbers and uh
um we can tell you what we anticipate
hiring and what we've seen and what we
will see so we would we would obviously
work with with you and
um and your attrition numbers are fairly
consistent they I'll let Amy speak to
that because she did she's done a lot of
work in
this we we have um we're continuing to
look at them but we we took like a we
looked at the last couple of years um
particularly um through through kind of
the lens of when we were um reviewing
the incentives with arpa and
um and through recruitment efforts so I
anticipate well I'm hopeful that as we
as we see as we've seen like this um
kind of wave of new folks coming in that
maybe we'll have that will go down but
that is what we've been seeing so we
made some assumptions that that will
continue but
um but of course hopefully that would
change but we just went with the what we
have been seeing just that yeah just
understand if 70 come to take the test
so 70 come to take the written and the
physical out of those 70 give or take
one or two we've got
18 that have gone to the next level
so oh is that a fairly typical it is it
is yeah but we are getting more
applicants and like I said that you know
speaking to the the colonel and the
executive major they're they're
optimistic that it's start starting to
turn our way and whatever we can do to
continue to attract people to come here
and we're seeing a lot of candidates
come from out of state too so um and
we're getting yeah that's good because
it's such a great place to
live I hope that I hope that helped okay
yeah just one follow-up question on that
two years ago when we were talking about
it and talking about the unfunded
positions uh I I think we realize that
the unfunded position especially at the
state police and police in general were
a national problem that certainly
impacted New Hampshire to a significant
degree now that we've seen sort of the
reverse and we seem people start
starting to apply more have you noticed
this or have you heard about this also
in other states or is this just unique
to New Hampshire or the Northeast I mean
are other states uh similarly seeing an
uptick and applications to the police
force yeah and I I want to be clear I
don't want to make it see we're seeing
some improvement a slight Improvement
but I'm not see any overwhelming um
influx and I know the you know director
of the police academy is here so he can
speak you know to to the entire state
but I think there are still significant
Recruitment and Retention issues in the
law enforcement Community uh
nationally thank you any other questions
no great thank you very much for your
you and I think commissioner you've
already introduced the uh the next uh
training good
afternoon good afternoon Mr chairman
good afternoon uh ladies and
gentlemen uh for the record my name is
John skippa and I am the director of New
Hampshire police sers and
training our mission is to shape
strengthen and sustain the competency
and professionalism of New Hampshire law
enforcement in service to our
state the police standards and training
Council regulates the hiring educational
and certification standards for all
police state corrections and probation
parole officers in New
Hampshire we operate the New Hampshire
Police Academy which all Municipal
Police County Sheriff deputies state
troopers conservation officers liquor
investigators and all other full-time
Law Enforcement Officers must attend to
become certified as a full-time police
officer in this
state we also operate the
part-time uh officer basic training
class that all part-time police officers
must complete to obtain their part-time
officer
certification as well as the New
Hampshire Corrections Academy that all
State Corrections Officers attend to
obtain their Corrections offic
certification finally we have also
developed and prepared to deliver the
court security officer basic Academy
that all court security officers of the
administrative office of the courts will
attend at the direction of the Chief
Justice of the New Hampshire Supreme
Court this Academy is also available to
the legislative court security officers
as well as other state employed security
buildings we also provide special ized
Advanced and inservice refresher
training at our facility in conquered
and regionally around the state to
assist officers in completing the annual
requirements to maintain their
certification as part of our
responsibility for regulating over 4,000
certified officers in our state we
convene and rule on disciplinary
hearings that may suspend or revoke the
certification of officers that have
violated Council rules or committed a
crime or an act of moral turpitude
we are an independent executive branch
agency governed by a 17 member police
standards and training
Council we are not affiliated with any
law enforcement or prosecutorial agency
thereby avoiding potential conflicts of
interest with our regulatory function
and decertification du
duties we provide services with 28
full-time and 11 part-time positions
which includes sworn staff
administrative and maintenance employees
our staff is assisted by adjunct
instructors most of whom are unpaid
volunteers and a small number of
contracted
instructors we operate a 77,000 squ foot
training facility located on 20.8 7
Acres of grounds across from New
Hampshire Technical Institute conquer's
Community
College with regard to forming necessary
statutes or rule changes uh we are
requesting necessary changes to several
statutes Within Chapter
106 we are requesting a clarification in
the definition of police
misconduct we are requesting a change
that would authorize the appointment of
a temporary member to the conduct Review
Committee we are requesting a change to
clarify the requirements for reporting
an allegation of police
misconduct we are requesting statutory
language be added
that establishes the law enforcement
accreditation Commission in statute as
it was created pursuant to executive
order
with regard to the efficiency budget
request the department of administrative
Services provided police standards and
training with Target allocations from
6,368 38 in fiscal year 26 and the same
Target allocation in fiscal year 27 our
submitted efficiency budget requests
meets those
requirements our adjusted authorized
budget for fiscal year 25 5 is currently
6,8
5,527 our fiscal year 26 efficiency
368,000
194% decrease below the fiscal year 25
adjusted authorized budget which is a
437,000
$89 reduction in our operating
budget our fiscal year 27 efficiency
368,000 per increase from FY 26 as
requested with regard to new
programs it is important to note that
police standards and training has taken
on a number of new responsibilities in
the last budget cycle these new
responsibilities are the result of
uh
2022 legislation through administrative
rule changes based on recommendations
made by the governor's law enforcement
accountability community and
transparency commission and through
realignment of responsibilities between
state
agency in the state
2022-23 session establish the law enfor
ment conduct revieww committee under
police standards and training this
committee is responsible for overseeing
and reviewing all investigations
regarding allegations of police
misconduct as defined in
statute
sb130 dfn 2023 session assigned the
responsibility at the request of Chief
Justice of the New Hampshire Supreme
Court to develop a court security
officer training and certification
program to provide for the education
training and certific ification of court
security
officers through executive order
43.1 has been amended to increase the
number of annual inservice training
hours for all certified Law Enforcement
Officers as a condition of uh continued
certification from 8 hours annually
increasing incrementally to 24 hours of
with regard to additional prioritized
needs requests our prioritized needs
request for fiscal year 26 includes one
full-time position of a law enforcement
training specialist one to assist with
court security officer and general court
programs also doit has requested an
additional
$68 in fiscal year 26
and $37 in fiscal year 27 for shared
costs in summary our proposed fiscal
year 2627 budget reflects compliance
with Target allocations set forth by the
governor's office while attempting to
appropriately resource our current
obligations of providing contemporary
recruit training to newly hired officers
creating and delivering in service
training regulating and monitoring
compliance with Professional Standards
as well as preparing to meet the number
of new obligations as outlined
above thank you for listening to our
presentation and we stand ready to
answer any questions that you might
have Senator gray uh you listed several
changes in legislation have you
contacted any legislator to get that
done or do you expect those to be in
hb2 uh the uh those
I can tell you my preference is that
that someone you know near and dear to
to uh the representative's heart here
next to me would be the one that you
would contact uh so that it can be
considered when they consider House Bill
one and
two uh thank you Senator gray for that
question uh those new programs uh as
they came to us uh came to us with some
uh type of support in the way of
personnel Andor funding
as the challenges came to us we're still
kind of flying the airplane and building
it at the same time and at this point we
don't anticipate that we would need any
additional funding other than the
request for the um uh the prioritized
specialist and if an RSA needs to be
changed I would rather not do that in
House Bill 2 especially if it doesn't
directly affect the funding and that is
why I would send you to a certain
individual or a person of his choosing
uh to assist you in getting that
legislation drafted because the time
period for drafting legislation
especially in the house is very
understood my question is in the
presentation before US Department of
Safety would would would like to hire 60
some odd state troopers I'm I'm sure
we're going to hear from the
presentation that follows you that there
are a lot of Corrections Officers that
are going to want to be hired as well uh
so my my question is if Department of
Safety Department of Corrections can
hire can find those people does this
$6.3 million budget request of yours
sufficient enough to be able to train
I I believe that we could do it
sir given the numbers that we just
presented it'll be tough but but we'll
do
it I asked this before of somebody have
you thought about if the two things it
it does sound to me like if the if the
incoming Governor says yeah this is good
we'll go with
it you're not there's nothing weird
um in that
um and the second piece is leaving aside
whether we should give you
$37 for
dyt um it just seems like a lot um the
uh if the if things work out the way
they look like they might work out and
you had to make additional reductions
below what you've made have you started
thinking about that started is all I'm
asking yeah I started about uh 10
minutes ago when you asked the uh
commissioner safety no we we actually um
we have discussed that uh and and
candidly uh we would have to
reexamine uh some of uh the deliverables
that we presently deliver uh and that
will impact uh negatively uh training of
law enforcement Personnel for the State
of New Hampshire what's your rough
throughput on on training in a in a
given year like how many people you I
don't know graduate I think is the right
word uh thank you for that question
commissioner we um we on average will
graduate uh about 200 full-time law
enforcement officers uh those people are
completing a 16-week uh basic uh Academy
for full-time
certification uh on top of that and and
I think these numbers are a little
um I don't know that they're accurate
historic Ally uh We've we've seen uh
some pretty small classes with the
Department of Corrections although the
the sitting class that's getting ready
to graduate in a couple of weeks uh we
do have uh a pretty good siiz Academy
for that Corrections Academy uh we
historically would have pretty large
part-time acmy as well uh and we are not
seeing the numbers at all for um
part-time applicants quite
frankly um you know I think it's why
well I mean guessing I don't yeah no
it's it's a great question and I think
it's important to recognize uh kind of
the dynamic that happened about two and
a half years ago when police reform hit
we uh we we were met with two problems
uh the first problem was the the
retention problem there was a lot of
people in our business that decided to
leave
early uh on top of that we had a
recruitment problem because people who
maybe thought about law enforcement as a
career uh decided against it and and
because those two things happened at the
same time it created a pretty
significant uh problem where we had to
fill the ranks of people who just
left plus the selection pool uh became
very shallow and over the the course of
the last two two and a half years in an
effort to make sure that anybody who we
could hire to get them back uh to their
their home
agency uh through permission of the
council we were running overlapping
policey much like they do in the
military where they'll start a class and
then within you know halfway through
that session we'll start another class
and that was just to try to stay on Pace
to get those recruit officers back to
their home agency
um to uh commissioner Quinn's
point I don't know that we're seeing uh
a a real steady hard rise in interest in
in law enforcement we are seeing a bit
of an uptick we've also kind of put out
the fire to fill not all but some of
those uh people who left early we were
able to fill those spots so things are
starting to maybe be less urgent when we
talk to local and state law enforcement
agencies where uh the the the real
widespread hemorrhaging has has stopped
uh but we we are still slowly building
those ranks while maintaining uh the
standards that New Hampshire law
enforcement holds themselves to right
thank
you and I'd like to invite up the
Corrections good afternoon commissioner
everyone my what if asked me that
question piles especially commissioner
Arling
house for the record my name is Helen
Hanks I'm the commissioner of the
Department of Corrections it is with
great pleasure that I present a budget
before this uh hisem uh committee uh
that meets the targets as presented I
think it is creative uh to meet those
targets while also ensuring we continue
to make progress in our uh ctional law
enforcement ranks uh to my right is
director of administration for our
department Lisa Stone I'm going to start
on page one the mission of the
Department of Corrections is to reduce
recidivism by providing safe secure and
Humane uh supervision and evidence-based
Rehabilitation to enhance Public Safety
in the state of New Hampshire you're
going to find at the end of this packet
we've added additional resources that
mission statement is profound in that
our goal to reduce recidivism is being
achieved starting in 2020 we started Ed
to see a marked decrease in the returns
to incarceration in 2018 our return rate
was as high as 48% in 2020 we've reduced
that to 40% and as we continue to look
at those released in the first 12 months
post relase which is that critical point
where we see people return to
incarceration in 2020 we saw 291 people
return to our care and custody either
through parole violations primarily or
uh other forms of return um then in 2021
we saw
256 and then in 2022 we saw 251 those
are good Progressive numbers you're also
going to see a road map with regard to
the things that we've engaged in on
evidence-based Rehabilitation to help
build stronger people we are very firm
in our charge to be part of the restored
justice system we can arrest we can have
our Judiciary sentence but if our
Correctional Department cannot provide
that confinement and rehabilit
then our justice system in New Hampshire
will not
succeed the Department of Corrections
was created in July of
1983 I've uh listed our statutory
charges I will let you read those on
your own accord but today we have
1,989 individuals incarcerated in our
Correctional
Facilities those on probation and parole
we have
468 with regards to supporting victims
of felony level crime we support
6,300 individuals in impacted by crime
in New Hampshire felony level
crime turning to page two I found it
very important to talk about both our
challenges and our accomplishments it is
important to understand this department
as I've testified to before had a very
um significant loss of Staff post the
covid pandemic and as I've testified and
spoken to those staff who deserved to
retire after a pandemic and the
adjustments in which we had to operate
uh deserve that retirement so we have
spent the last several years making up
the difference uh with regard to
Recruitment and Retention and bringing
on new members to support that Gap and
in law enforcement primarily but it
affected the other ranks of our agency
with that stated prior to the pandemic
the US Department of Labor had already
forecasted a marked decrease of 7% in
the corrections profession across the
country and so I as part of the
correctional leaders Association have
worked with my uh colleagues across the
country to both tell people what
Corrections is and is not and I'll get
into some of those strategies a little
later in the
presentation we have appreciated the
support of arpa dollars to incentivize
coming on and becoming a correctional
law enforcement uh member of the State
of New Hampshire with our $10,000
recruitment incentive that has been a
motivator for people to choose
Correctional law enforcement over other
ranks of law enforcement in the state
we've um we've really seen a marked gain
and you'll see some numbers again in the
back of the packet associated with that
uh we continue to be challenged with the
Aged infrastructure at the Hampshire
state prison for men the infrastructure
is a recruitment and retention challenge
uh individuals certainly uh appreciate
the infrastructure at the New Hampshire
correctional facility for women and even
our new Northern New Hampshire
Correctional Facility is designed and
better equipped to support staff as well
as those incarcerated
there uh We've continued to implement
because we're cognizant that working
Corrections uh can be a challenge it can
result in uh post-traumatic stress
disorder and other issues with regard to
what you encounter the 24-hour stress
and pressure of not knowing what's going
to happen when you look into a cell or
search cell or things of that matter our
neighbors to the South Massachusetts had
a recent significant assault on an
officer who was stabbed repeatedly um
those things happen uh they happen
across the country in our neighboring
states and and we work every day to
prevent that from happening in our
Correctional environment when we're not
naive that it could so so we want to
build employee Wellness programs to help
continue to develop the resiliency and
strength of our
staff we've increased the amount of a
substance use disorder treatment and I
know this is a budget meeting but all of
the things that fund these activities
are critical in our mission forward uh
including for people who return on a
parole violation they're directly linked
to substance use disorder and return to
criminogenic behavior so we have to have
multiple paths for people once they're
assessed for treatment during our
incarceration and right now we had one
primary path which was a modified
Therapeutic Community but we've created
a targeted parole violation program if
they assess to that level to participate
that and to revive those skills they had
previously generally learned through
their treatment
Service uh critical to keep our
Corrections Officers in the facilities
both for safety reasons but to use their
skill set and primary posts our medical
forensics team have even implemented
colag guard if you're a person of that
age I want you to know there's an option
to have that experience at home instead
of going and having colonoscopy and we
in Corrections have finally gotten there
into some modern medicine and it is
important because it reduces the use of
corrections officer and transportation
and we can fill those unfilled posts
better at the correctional
facilities we continue to align our
nhdoc formulary to the Medicaid
formulary that's both important for
affordability and continuity care but
also to try to reduce the cost of
pharmaceuticals uh that are charged
against the general fund we have been
privileged to be granted a waiver from
the centers for medicated Medicare
Services referred to as an 1115 a waiver
that becomes really important because as
I uh lean into the budget as we move
forward the CMS will fund and pay for a
30-day supply of medications at this
time the department the general fund
pays to for at least 14 days suppli of
those medications so we'll be able to
defer those costs but as well as
increase the continuity of care upon
release we've updated our uh Dental
operatory Suites I want to thank nht for
that because they donated to us four
Dental operative operative chairs that
did not have to come from the general
fund and we've been able to install
those uh We've collaborated with
Partners like White Mountains Community
College to really Implement uh the
second chance pel Grant and help people
again with evidencebased Rehabilitation
and education become stronger citizens
and more employable and we're also
working with nhti to move forward we
have uh actively right now 23 students
in that program and uh White Mountains
is offering a business associates degree
and a Lial arts
degree we've expanded a choose love
social emotional learning program the
founder Scarlet Lewis lost her son in
the Sandy Hook massacre and said
enough's enough we're going to do
something about changing the way which
people resort to violence and this
program helps teach people fundamentals
around gratitude and courage and heroic
action and compassion fundamental
elements that some of us did not have
the privilege to understand in our youth
and we need to continue to move people
forward to make nonviolent decisions and
their actions this has been well
received has demonstrated a decrease in
violence for those that have
participated in our Correctional
environments and we've deployed it
across the three primary Correctional
Facilities we participated in the New
England Commission on the future of
higher education in prisons and that
report has been published and we
continue to strive because providing
education and Vocational opportunities
statistically demonstrated one of the
strongest impacts in reducing people's
return to
incarceration um so we really you're
going to see us finding multiple lines
of effort that we want to reduce returns
to incarceration because it costs the
state of New Hampshire and it costs our
communities those adverse outcomes of
Crime After the passage of Senate Bill
376 and I want to thank all the Senate
sponsors for that action the corrections
education and Vocational Planning Group
um was formed and we're starting down
that road to continue to advance those
opportunities around education and
post-secondary uh efforts within our
Correctional envirment
we've implemented several initiatives
interestingly enough at our trans
transitional housing units including a
cell phone program uh sounds uh strange
but it's really not it both affords us
GPS uh tracking tools for individuals
but also acclimates people back to
technology it helps to create a
connectedness to their provider and
tella health and other T resources can
happen on that uh telephonic device um
and I spoke about the 1115 a waiver that
waiver is also going to provide two
provider contacts prior to release as
well as two peer-to-peer contacts uh
nationally the research has demonstrated
reinforcing connectivity to health care
and your treatment provider and
experiencing that provider before you
release shows that you're more likely to
continue to go to get those Services we
know in looking at parole violations in
the state of New Hampshire one of the
most connected things we can do is to
continue the work that is expended
through the general fund on helping
people engage in treatment continue
post- relase and so with that we're also
implementing tella Health booths so that
Community provider doesn't have to drive
to a correctional facility but we can
normalize that interaction through tella
Health on page four yes finally those
numbers are coming surfacing and
explains all those challenges and
strengths the department has been moving
forward uh you'll see that we are
primarily a Personnel driven
organization and that is the driving
cost our prescri prescription drug cost
has also been a driver as well as our
Medical payments to
Providers understanding that we have
major initiatives moving forward the
1115a waiver will start January 1st of
2025 and so with that we're taking a
cautionary approach and reducing that
line to meet the governor's Target um as
well as our prescription drug
line uh in addition to uh those are the
two primary
reductions is uh moving forward and a
you can see all these very large numbers
on page three
uh moving to page five I really dive
into those Personnel lines I want you to
know that our current fill rate for all
positions is approximately
77% we've had a marked decrease
specifically uh identifying Corrections
Officers in that rank because that is
the primary rank of uh that we use
across multiple locations it was as high
as 50% in January of 2024 it is now
dropped to 44% that's an excellent
decrease we on the other hand have
approximately over 170 corrections
officer positions in which we are
recruiting and filling and trying to
accomplish that uh every day and like to
see that continue to go down so with
that stated our strategy um with regard
to the budget because I don't want to
overlook uh the previous page was to
change in the way in which we manage U
requests for overtime expenditures uh no
I do not think we'll only need
$2,100 or $2,100 in 2026 and 2027 but to
ensure the morale of our staff we really
do not want to unfund uh vacant
positions we want to continue to recruit
it has been an effective strategy and in
the absence of filling those positions
continue to ask for the footnote to
transfer those funds to the overtime
line You'll see another ask different
this year this banian budget that if
that uh initiative is not successful in
covering those costs then we would
shepher a request to the fiscal
committee for an additional
appropriation followed by a request and
approval through governor and executive
councel
on page six is a demonstration of the
historical overtime costs and you'll see
uh different in this slide we've
actually put the number of hours
associated with that overtime cost
you'll see in 2023 versus 2024 the cost
of overtime costs more it simply does
our agency had been um had a
significantly lower starting wage as
starting Correctional law enforement
ment than any other branch of law
enforcement and with the support of the
legislature after the reallocation we're
in a much more um Equitable competitive
Place uh but in addition to the uh
bargaining outcomes of double overtime
and the 10% and the 12% overtime costs
more uh base wages cost more for all
state employees but the primary driver
um is lifting that wage and continue to
try to fill those vacant
positions we've had a lot of uh Staffing
strategies all our Corrections Officers
when they leave in good standing we ask
them to come back and continue to work
part-time but knew over the last couple
of years for individuals who either
physically can't continue to meet the
law enforcement standard in New
Hampshire we've created a correctional
line support position um that we refer
to as our pum relief pool and so those
individuals can come back and fill
non-armed security posts and help ensure
that someone doesn't have to get forced
that day and this prum relief pool comes
out of our part-time uh class line
rather than our regular uh Personnel
lines of overtime and has been a really
uh wonderful truly relief pool for our
Corrections Officers and getting uh
initiatives moving forward while
continuing to
recruit we've also um taken our group
two Correctional line personnel and if
they want to they can go through the
Corrections Academy and be dually
certified and after their regular
full-time Duty post they can choose to
pick up overtime posts and some do
that's on a voluntary basis and it works
in Reverse as well our certified
Corrections Officers if they change into
a group two Correctional line Personnel
position they can maintain their
certification under police standards and
training councel standards and also work
all forms of certified corrections
officer posts within our department so
there's a lot of good supportive
interactivity with with the Department
of corrections employees and it has been
a success for us in addition to all
general department of corrections
employees once they go through a certain
set of training and skill acquisition
demonstration they can also work
non-armed control room posts and some
limited support posts that are
transitional housing units as well as
when we have somebody in crisis and
they're in observation room they can sit
on that onetoone post so we've tried to
maximize a lot of the skill sets we have
in corrections as we teach our staff to
participate and be a member of our
department um that we're one team and
we're going to we're going to get
through this together and we're going to
continue to move
forward on page seven it's important to
show you what we've been doing and
trending you'll see the spike in 2022
post the pandemic you'll see us starting
to make strides in 2023 and continue to
do so in 2024 I love it when the dark
blue bar is higher than the other two um
and we have right now as of today 27
correction officer trainees uh in the
Corrections Academy and we have between
24 and 30 prepared to go to another
corrections officer Academy so we're
headed in a much uh better Direction
than we've ever seen as a department
we've uh never had a solid consistent
effort on Recruitment and Retention
which has been interesting to me in my
career and started to Pilot some
initiatives that I have found to be
successful so we now have three
dedicated Recruitment and Retention
sergeants as well as two Recruitment and
Retention committees driven by our staff
one southern team and one Northern team
um it really is important as a as an
organization that everyone is involved
in the retention of uh each other I like
to affirm for my staff I don't work side
by side every day with all of you we
work side by side with each other and
how we interact with one another and how
we engag how we think about where we
work becomes critically important to
retaining staff um so on this page we
describe in detail initiatives that
we've engaged in including employee
development our department has not had a
strong employee development meaning
leadership program so we've partnered
both with uh entities within the State
Granite State Police career counseling
as well as we've really tapped into
what's referred to as our Northeast
Correctional leaders Association as
Correctional leaders in the Northeast we
uh came together and said why are we
trying to accomplish all this by
ourselves so we've started to
regionalize some leadership training
specific and Corrections and other forms
of training and really trying to
maximize the use of all of our um
leaders and training and employee
development to bring together the
Northeast uh Correctional professionals
to help the employee development path
across the region in in addition to I
talk to you about the post- traumatic
stress disorder and other things that
have been founded in research about
those that work in Corrections and I
want to thank the governor's Commission
on Alcohol and Other Drugs for affording
us around $86,000 to contract uh with
nami New Hampshire to do work around
Crisis Intervention training that has
been tailored to the correctional
environment talking about trauma and
resiliency as well as other mental
health topics that are both important to
our staff but also to those that we
serve and we are trying to um engage in
change so that we restore them to
Hampshire communities most of those
1,989 people incarcerated today 90% of
them will hit a minimum parole date and
will parole to our community we want
them to parole successfully and be
successful members of our
society on page eight I continue to
demonstrate the work we're doing around
recruiting St strategies we've been to
90 Career Fairs 32 classroom talks 33
community events and 47 colleges and
High School tours we continue to off
offer a program at Groveton high school
and Berlin High School teaching young
people about what being a Corrections
professional is for all layers of the
organization and these efforts are
because we acknowledge that our overtime
expenditure is a major hit on the
general fund budget and we want to
resolve that um and continue to make
strides to reduce that impact on the
state budget we really have a strong
social media presence we want to give
accolades to the things that we do on
Rehabilitation and we really want to put
out the good work that our staff are
doing
um as individuals in a Corrections
Department we went as far as renting a
billboard on i93 I did not see any of
you apply so I did not continue to renew
that billboard um but we still
tried um we really have been involved
with our communities that our facilities
reside in uh working with Berlin PD and
having a National Night Out in Berlin um
and really want to show that we're
community members with that stated the
city of conquered has a wonderful
holiday parade in the department for the
third year uh in a row because last
year's was canceled we'll be in that
parade I hope to see you there to throw
you some
candy on page nine the other Major
Impact uh our our budget has to the
state is our medical service and so here
you'll see the percentage in the amount
that we've allocated for those and as I
stated to you uh why we reduce them uh
it's not exactly a science but it's an
understanding that we're going to see a
reduction through the work on the 1115 a
waiver we would continue to ask for the
footnote we've had in the past which is
for uh reasons within the delivery of
Medical Care both pharmaceutical and
medical care that if we did not have
enough monies that we would go before
State fiscal and then governor and
executive Council to continue to provide
the constitutionally appropriate care
we're required to to
deliver what is of an important note and
different we did make a purposeful
marked decrease of $1.39 million out of
our medical budget uh in FY 26 and
1.46 in FY 27 that represents contracted
money that we uh contract for for the
office is referred to as the office of
forensic examiners we reduced it not
because we don't think the state needs
the service but we the Department of
Corrections are not charged under the
statute which references compeny to
deliver that service that has sat with
the department since the 1980s when the
secure psychiatric unit was transferred
under the Department's responsibility
and with it came criminal competency
evaluations criminal competency
evaluations is a pre-sentencing
pre-adjudication service provided to the
Judiciary it is a service that used to
be 300 competency evaluations a year
that has gone up to almost 890
competency evaluations a year and that's
not a count of the number of refer
referrals but the number of evaluations
completed um I would advise that this
area of service be considered to be
funded either through the Judiciary or
New Hampshire hospital that section New
Hampshire RSA 135 is entitled New
Hampshire hospital and quote insane
persons it is not entitled the state
prison um so I want to I want to point
that out
specifically as we continue on on page
10 these are the other operational costs
uh each represent U you know more than a
million uh in our critical areas of
service obviously food and current
expense uh we over uh 5,700 meals are
serve daily meeting religious and
dietary needs I'm not sure how they do
it but I do see it and took a picture of
it just yesterday morning when I was
walking the institutions to ask exactly
what we had served that day uh but we do
have a full-time dietitian who looks at
the meals makes sure they meet dietary
Services um and that the quality of the
food is such that individuals find it
palatable and digestible as we move
forward on page 11 uh the utilities um
given the history of the department um
and also learning the opportunities
available we would ask for a continued
footnote that if these costs that are
not controlled by the department did not
meet these targets we could come back
and ask for additional Appropriations
the N Hampshire state prison for men is
far from an economical uh resource when
it comes to utilities electricity and
water uh so we we just don't want any
surprises to the state our office of
Information Technology expenses uh these
represent the shared costs and work
we've been doing uh both to create
technological efficiency with a a
decreased uh Workforce so things such as
as um improving our Fender management
system increasing the use of
Technologies to do rounds uh We've uh
contracted with a partner called
Guardian RFID um it it literally is um
interesting technology in which we don't
have to do paper rounds to count the
individuals it's important to know you
have everybody who's supposed to be in
your care and custody multiple times
today that's uh to assure we don't have
any escapes uh but we don't need to
continue to do that on paper so we're
moving forward with technology as a tool
and those are some samples of the
resources as well as fusus technology uh
which is surveillance technology so we
can really see from multiple different
areas what is going on in our
institution and provide the appropriate
visual protections to our staff and
those in our care and
custody on page 10 uh excuse me 12 these
are our additional prioritized needs um
I have to pay commissioner Arling housee
additional monies for rent so I want to
make sure that's in the budget but not
significantly a lot uh that's literally
um and and then office of Information
Technology uh are our additional
prioritize needs on page 13 is a more
detailed demonstration of a high level
overview of our budget in FY 26 we
reduced it by approximately 4% and then
in FY 27 approximately 1.5% with the
permission granted that the Personnel uh
costs uh that were bargained um equated
uh to a reasonable place for the
Department to continue so you'll see
some increases both in our class 27 and
those are to take over the technology
contracts it's about just under half a
million dollars to create efficiencies
for our staff uh in addition to the
reductions in both our medical uh and
pharmaceutical lines as the primary
areas in which we've uh reduced so at
this time the following Pages again are
areas of information uh that you I think
are important to talk about the
department and I'll let you look at
those at your leisure with that happy to
answer any
questions except for commissioner Arling
8% uh commissioner
the um the large project we've been
talking about for the last few years is
is the The Men's prison as you as you
mentioned that the current Men's prison
is is aging and needs to be replaced uh
the legislature I believe has a
appropriate approximately $50 million
$10 million through the last budget and
then $40 million through the
session
realistically uh assuming the remaining
funding
comes uh on a on
a a scheduled basis or a schedule that
that uh you would agree
with what are we looking at as far as
time and when that prison can come
online what's the earliest I mean are we
looking at five years 10 years where
does it sort of fit thank you for that
question that is the question that was
asked during the testimony I'd like to
thank Senator gray and other co-sponsors
for that $40 million uh to add to the 10
that was appropriated before that's a
critical foundational uh amount of money
so that we can get to bids speec
documents to put those out so that the
state of New Hampshire understands
whether it's $550 million or some other
maybe the economy changes and that
number goes down um your question about
how long will it take is it to move into
a fully uh constructed building it is
anywhere between 5 and 10 years as I've
testified to before
uh we've moved forward on that 10
million appropriation we're working on a
request for proposal for the $40 million
plus we're also working to get that uh
bonded and into our budget post the um
end of the last uh legislative session
so with that stated if we continue a
good track and inertia on the getting
the information working with those
vendors by the time we're building the
next budget we should be able to have a
number to place there and then move
forward with construction and that
construction will take anywhere between
that moment 5 to 10 years depending on
um who we get for construction
partner thank
you I bet you nickel is closer to
10 um I'm being optimistic and cautious
at the same time just saying last thing
I need is people going why are you so
late
um I have a couple of questions uh one
is just a couple of observations I I
will
resist asking you if you've already
begun discussions at home about reducing
this to more like eight than four um or
10 um because you've sort of answered
that already we we would Mission failure
at that point
um yes I do understand that uh one of
the things I think is going to be
helpful for the next Governor's budget
team is to know what in the agency
budget is problematic in the sense that
it was part of an exercise to reach the
target M but in looking at it you think
ooh that was an issue that might become
a problem so you might start thinking
about that there only two other things I
I want to mention and some some of this
goes for almost anybody listening but
the one is uh in the past one of the
things that we've occasionally done is
allowed agencies to go to fiscal if if
this or that fall short and they can go
to fiscal and ask them for money like
fiscal is a giant piggy bank and it's
worked because for the last eight or 10
years fiscal has been a giant piggy bank
um with lots of pennies inside their
little pig um so to speak um and we're
about to enter a time when there are no
money there's no money in the pig and uh
I I want to say that to agencies with
caution because just can because you can
go to fiscal doesn't mean they can give
you money if they don't have any and I
so in the back of our minds um we think
about this all the time with like
utilities like we don't want to under
budget utilities because um um we can't
just go get more money if there isn't
any so that's one thing out there the
second thing is I I think you're very
well aware of some of the Oddities the
state budget does with how we pay for
salaries and benefits at Corrections and
in past years we have artificially
impoverished class 10 MH to allow a
multi-million doll hit on the salary and
benefit adjustment fund
um by transferring the money out to
overtime and then paying for that and
that ends up accidentally giving you a
few million dollars more money um that
wasn't budgeted in in that respect and
I'm not saying it's the wrong choice
because people had to get paid
but we're also entering a time period
where if there's not money in the salary
adjustment fund you can't have it and I
and I I want to I want to hit you with
that now because if everyone gets rid of
all their
vacancies as is likely to happen in the
current budget the salary and benefit
adjust the salary adjustment fund will
have like $8 in it which would be enough
to pay for the prioritized need for
police standards but not much else so
those are two cautions just out there
well commissioner Hing house I
appreciate that especially the last
sentiment as I don't sit on employee
bargaining and uh through the process
the bargained uh raises associated with
overtime were and shift iial my agency
were not in included in any additional
appropriation we were not able to absorb
those and at one point somebody said to
me then just don't provide them so I
don't have the option of not providing
them sure um so I appreciated your
support and ensuring that those uh
bargained outcomes uh happened within
our department no it's good I just I
want everyone listening to know that um
the runway is narrower than it used to
be and uh not everybody always gets that
I have have two more legitimate
questions for you okay
um one is collections yes I um I I I'm
looking across agencies to see if there
are functions that multiple agencies
have that we can find efficiencies for
to save multiple people money and I
think there are four or five different
agencies that have a collections Bureau
of some kind within them can you talk to
me a little bit about and maybe you
don't know this off the top of your head
I wouldn't expect you to but collections
certainly uh we have a statutory charge
to collect uh the court fines
restitutions and in addition to if
individuals in our care and custody
destroy state property and incur
Financial Obligations we have a
statutory responsibility to collect that
in perpetuity uh we collect
approximately $2 million through uh
roughly five full-time employees who are
also funded through their collection
efforts uh with that stated there's a
approximately over $10 million in fines
fees that are left uncollected but this
group does the best that they can in
seeking those collection funds by law
some of the uncollected is is not
because of staffing issues but um
ability to pay so the like somebody can
pay like 20 bucks a month for like 18
years they can exactly so anything like
that to individuals who uh walk out and
write a check for $118,000 and uh clear
their uh just I'll call it justice
obligation off the Record would you be
interested in exploring maybe through
the doj collections Bureau some sort of
efficiencies with other agencies I'm
always excited about efficiency sir I
knew I knew you were I thought that was
an easy thing um the other thing is I
read your your uh very colorful charts
and graphs which I found very
interesting thank you um recidivism yes
so I don't know which page this is it
says page two at the bottom but it's
about 25 pages in
um under Focus
unit that particular program well so I'm
looking at this and res recidivism rates
total released
1015 and about 380 of them came back
which suggests a general recidivism rate
of about
38% but then the
program it's
40% so feels like the program isn't
dramatically successful or are you
targeting uh I'm very interested
recidivism broadly certainly so in
comparing I don't know if you're looking
at this slide I'm looking at hang on Yep
this slide so that is a very specific
targeted review of individuals who are
at high risk to return to incarceration
who absen this program were coming back
at a rate of
48% and so through this program we've
seen a reduction uh in around their
substance use disorder of 40% so if they
take the program they're more likely to
stay in the community if they do not
return and your broad recidivism though
is is closer to like 35 38% in that
range no I don't know where that number
came from but if you look at the road to
reducing recidivism you'll actually see
it broken down by biological gender um
and it shouldn't be a surprise that
females recidivism rate in 2020 went
down to 30% when you average the two
it's an overall of 41 and it's even down
lower uh now but that number um in
comparison to 2018 when the women moved
into the New Hampshire correctional
facility for women the infrastructure
had a difference in addition to the
rehabilitate
programming oh it went down dramatically
dramatically in addition to we uh
through the use of State opioid response
dollars implemented re-enter care
coordinators as I started my testimony
and talked about the criticality of the
first 12 months during that 12 months
that re-entry care coordinator
voluntarily worked with individuals with
opioid use disorder and Other Drug uh
use disorders to help in a barrier
removal navigation system and it showed
uh a decline in their return to
incarceration so the governor in his
last uh budget and the legislature
supported transitioning those from Grant
dollars to State uh employees and it
continues to have strong affectedness
with those with substance use disorder
and it it looks like um total population
of the I'm going to focus on on men cuz
um it looks like mostly men get locked
up um I don't know what that says about
us um the um dramatic reductions uh 26%
in the last seven or eight years and and
like 100 before that and I imagine that
goes back to I don't know when we peaked
and started coming down but we've been
coming down a lot why yeah we peaked in
2010 and 2011 somewhere around 2,700
individuals were incarcerated The Marked
decline in incarceration is State
judiciary's implementation of specialty
courts and I'm really glad you brought
that question up so as those came online
and we increased the use of drug courts
across the state and now we're seeing a
marked increase in mental health courts
we started to see more diversion to the
use of probation rather than
incarceration and we started to see more
successes even for those on parole who
are in drug court um the legislature
passed a veterans court bill but was
passed without additional probation of
pro law for to participate in that piece
of legislation and the Judiciary is
working through a mental health court
Grant expansion and we don't have
additional provation parole officers to
provide that resource so what this shows
is diversional courts make a difference
uh and also in addition to this layering
the implementation of the doorway and
other uh no no uh other is um excuse me
treatment expansion in our New Hampshire
communities uh as if there's no bad door
to walk through for treatment in our
state that all has made a marked uh
difference for people's sustainability
in New Hampshire communities do do you
think you'll see that continue if the
infrastructure for the doorways and and
the Hub and spoke model continue and the
diversion courts continue I would expect
this to either stabilize at the number
it is now but I say that cautiously
because any change in sentencing law
that would increase uh terms of
incarceration will uh get us closer to
what we were experiencing 2010
if you're if you're aware of models
across the country I imagine you talk to
people in other states um that ought to
be brought to the in the attention of um
budget writers it would be good to know
I I just say that because
um prison reform is probably the biggest
budget thing that you could do rather
than finding pennies here and there it's
true and again with the legislature's
support of things like earn time credit
during incarceration and learning from
those opportunities we could look at
similar actions uh for people on
probation to reduce uh terms of
probation when people are complying um
and again last uh last session or the
session before the legislature supported
uh an adjustment and a reduction of
Maximum uh law which affords a more
framed opportunity for probation parle
officers to understand the
legislator's path for considering before
the Adult Parole Board of who the right
person is to consider uh taking off that
case load so as we look at trying not to
incarcerate people we also need to take
a measured look at how long should
somebody be on Supervision in the
community and really use those resources
to maximize high-risk
individuals okay thanks I'll shut up
now thank you very much for your
testimony thank you everyone have a
wonderful
day like to call up the Adell parole
got
good afternoon my name is uh Roger
Phillips and I'm chairperson of the
adult Pro board um and with me today is
Jay Mackey who's a director of
programming um we
uh I'm getting a a little bit horse and
a little bit laryngitis I presided at
meetings all all morning long including
two uh contested hearings so we're going
to U Jay and I prepared our that page
and a half narrative together uh and he
will uh
um outline U what the pro because we
have a a rather small budget as compared
to the Department of of corrections but
a very substantial function in paring
people who does deserve parole and for
those who violate the law for the terms
of parole uh who are brought back u u in
for some period of time so I'll turn it
over to J Macky and we'll begin our
presentation good
afternoon the Hampshire Adel parole
board is comprised of five board members
being the chairperson vice chairperson
and three board members currently there
are six office staff that provide
support for the pro board with me
included we are a small agency that is
administratively attached to the New
Hampshire Department of Corrections for
budgeting and clerical support uh by
Statute in order to meet the target
number for this budget we had to cut a
full-time support uh office staff
position um we are planning to request
for this position to be reinstated and
funded in house bill
to uh in pages one and two of the
handout we do have copies of our
organizational chart the current one
right here uh is page one and the
proposed one with that position removed
is on page
two the New Hampshire do parole board
was audited in
2019 there were many areas that needed
Improvement the audit described the
parole board office as being staff by
Personnel who are overwhelmed and unable
to effectively manage their rapidly
increasing workload due to the audit
recommendations a new position in 2020
was approved to be added to the proboard
office staff if we are unable to
maintain the current Staffing levels we
risk failing to comply with the 2019 LBA
audit
recommendations another area in need of
improvement was the amount of
information provided to the parole board
hearing panel the audit found that many
of these parole packets submitted to the
hearing panel were incomplete and at
times
inaccurate the parole board worked with
the Department of Corrections to provide
more information to the board for proper
decision- making prior to the LBA audit
the size of a parole packet would range
from 30 to 50 pages the most recent
parole hearings we had last week they
average 90 to 100 digital Pages
um proboard office staff are responsible
for compiling the information received
from Department of Correction staff in
addition to Gathering the documents that
are available in the doc's offender
management
system losing a staff member in the
office can directly impact the ability
to continue to provide the hearing panel
with the most recent complete and
decision uh in addition to cutting a
full-time offic position we have also
decreased our request in the areas of
organizational dues instate travel
expenses and oit money
we have requested increases in
interpreter Services out of state travel
and
Telecommunications the increase in
interpretor Services is due to us
already exceeding the budget the
budgeted amount in the current fiscal
year um we're probably going to at least
double it um for for this year's this
fiscal
year the slight increase in
telecommunications is to meet the
expected cost of replacing or expanding
the communication equipment the board
currently
has we are requested an increase in the
OU of State travel budget from $4,000 to
$10,000 another recommendation from the
2019 audit was for the P Board to
implement a weighted decision-making
process for PE
hearings board is currently in the
process of of adopting the structured
decision-making framework model sdmf is
called this model was originally adopted
by the pro Board of Canada and has since
been implemented in approximately 14
States an article describing this model
is in the handh out provided beginning
on page three
which is the one from parole board
Canada two of our board members and the
chairperson have received initial
training in this model in order to fully
implement it we need to have the ability
to receive the training from the
National Institute of Corrections and we
anticipate required traveling out of
state the New Hampshire Del parole board
is also a member of the association of
paroling authorities International
APA the chairperson and I have attended
the the annual training conferences
provided by APA the information received
in these conferences is
invaluable we are very small agency and
have the ability to interact with
agencies both inside and outside the
United States to learn the
evidence-based approaches and best
practices they utilize is extremely
helpful agendas from the last three
annual conferences are provided in the
handout and it just goes to show that
the different topics that are
discussed uh amongst uh all the three
days three and a half days that we're
there we have executive meetings with
just chairpersons and directors um also
creating a network of communication
amongst the states that we can reach out
to people whenever we have an issue that
we haven't uh encountered yet to to see
about what what type of you know
decision making that they they've been
situations the increase in the request
for out ofate Travelers for the board
members all board members to receive the
necessary training to implement the sdmf
model as well as attend the ual training
conferences provided by apai this will
ensure the New Hampshire Adult Parole
Board is utilizing an evidence-based
decision-making framework to support the
decisions being made as well as being
able to keep up toate with the best
practices and Trends throughout the
Nations and towards the end of the
handouts beginning in page 22 we have uh
put together some of our own statistics
that we
keep uh
regarding Pro violators intakes per year
the decrease in that
revocation data how many rules are
violated the average amount of rules
what types of rules are being violated
over the past two years of uh revocation
hearings we are conducting our own
recidivism study um being I I did come
from the Department of Corrections and I
am very
um well learned in their offender
management system and I know a lot of
the um drawbacks of it which there's a
new system version coming out
in in the spring which should actually
alleviate alleviate most of these issues
that we do have um but with this
we've we are tracking the people that
have all the people that have been
released on parole for the first time in
the year 2022 the calendar year and with
this we've come to the conclusion as of
right now as of September 9th 2024 is
about a 39% recidivism
rate which was about 34% in the first 12
months
the final page is the proboard hearing
statistics showing how many release
hearings revocation hearings and what
our approval rate is um throughout the
fiscal years beginning 2016 through
2024 um
currently over the past eight or nine
months we're at about a 75% rate um I
see fiscal year 2024 we're at
72%
um early on you will see 75 to 77% and
that was before before the audit once
the audit happened you're looking at
2019 2020
2021 the approval rate dipped due to all
the changes being
made uh the pro board had to make in
their decision-making processes so a lot
less people were being approved now that
these changes have been
in uh have been made and are in
process the PE the approval rate is
climbing back up as these people are
preparing to go in front of their parole
hearings as the doc staff are preparing
them and making sure they're doing
everything that they know the parole
board requires of them to be
questions uh the the only thing I would
I I I appreciate you and and thank you
for bringing us uh for the reinstatement
of that funded position through hb2 how
how this will most likely work is that
uh it now that it's been brought to our
attention the incoming governor will
decide to include it in her budget or
not if if she does it'll be in the
operating budget in her operating budget
uh it would not be an hb2 item but it
would just be placed directly into the
operating budget so so that's how it
would work uh I don't have any other
questions on that can I ask about
recidivism again or are people sick of
it
um uh your stud's is interesting you
have 402 people released to parole I
presume that
um not knowing as much about corrections
as as I should cuz I refused every
invitation from Helen to velcro me to
somebody um which just seemed abusive um
the 400 are released to parole there's a
subset that are released not to parole
so this this group of people were being
released to parole for the first time
from their sentence this does not
include people that were brought back on
a parole revocation and then released
back onto parole oh and there are also
other people that are released that
complete their sentence Max their
sentence out do you think the the
recidivism numbers for those three
subgroups are different I imagine they
would be yes and I know the the docc has
done recidivism studies over the years
that include all all those different
subsets um unfortunately being the small
agency we are we it's just trying to
track our our trying to see if our
numbers do actually match with the doc's
and just for our own as we're looking
for evidence-based practices you know
and and all that that we have you know
the numbers and what we're looking to
achieve do you look at the numbers and
think I'm releasing too many people or
too few people or we really no we really
take each case on a case-by Case
basis I guess that makes sense right
yeah okay I've looked I've looked at the
the numbers and the trends over the last
few years I've been in this position for
about three and a half years now I was
formerly the administrator of
classifications for the doc um so I I I
looked at the number numbers Co
obviously had a huge hit to the amount
of inmates we had which the commissioner
was speaking about all the diversionary
courts and how those were used a lot
more during covid um a lot of sentences
were being suspended as because they
weren't bringing inmates into the prison
they lost about 500 5 to 600 inmates
between 2019 and 2020 um those numbers
have not climbed back up there was a
little bit of an increase yearly by
about 50 or 20 intake wise um but they
those numbers have not come back up and
I don't foresee them going back to the
way they were just based off of as she
talked about the actual success that
they're having with these diversionary
programs do you think that we I don't
know what the right verb is rid um more
than average uh compared to other states
or are we sort of in the range I believe
we're right right around the middle
there there are some states lower some
states significantly higher I I want to
say between and 50 is uh we were in the
50% range a few years back and it's it's
dipped down and I know I I I met with
the public information officer we talked
about numbers during one of our other
meetings and it they were they were
their numbers were pretty similar to
mine as well so right around the 40%
Mark or a little less and it's important
to understand that states differ a great
deal in their sentencing structure I
mean we have indeterminate sentences
some just have a a single sentence that
they're
they they're they have to go away for 10
years oh like if I get convicted of X I
do three years right okay and and but
before that time they could become
eligible for Perl there are some states
that have no programming Behind the
Walls um I I think seems like that's a
mistake New Hampshire is really when I
speak the other other parole chairs from
other states um um um Plus presently uh
surprised at at how well we do with
programs that are offered so that people
can be rehabilitated and and safely put
back into the
community cool okay thank
good I think she just wanted my cookie
recipe good after Commission
I feel like so my sta whole staff corner
is like gone like they don't want to
talk to me I feel that's
terrible um not that terrible uh I'm
Charlie Arling housee I'm the
commissioner of administrative Services
um with me who are you Cassie Keen I'm
the Deputy Commissioner of Das
unfortunately um our assistant
commissioner could not be here today
Sher
Rockburn um I have with me behind me
from one side to the other I think I'm
going to get this right Moren Hoffman
Moren Ryan Hoffman is our
CFO uh Stacy Duffy is our Deputy CFO and
Karen Tamaki is our director of plant
and property if you ask me about
deferred maintenance I'm going to make
Karen come up um so don't get too
excited
um I want to be briefer and I have fewer
slides than
average um because I figure you're all
bored by now um I'm going to talk to you
a little bit about what the Department
of administrative Services is broadly
speaking um and then we can ask
questions about anything else I'm going
to start with the second slide because
the first slide is a title page and it
is boring um so the second slide let me
stick with that how do we spend I I want
you I want to explain to you that our
department is both it's a department and
it's retire health so think of it as two
budgets retiree health is a benefit
program is is part of the state benefits
that certain retirees have Healthcare
provided for them it is a separate thing
it's not part of an operational piece of
a program if you want me to find
efficiencies that's a separate separate
thing entirely almost like a separate
Department um although obviously it
isn't because we administer it um and as
you can see from our from our budget 71
million of our budget in fiscal 25 going
down to 66 is retire Health everything
else that we
do um actually goes from 90 down to 78
um to give you a sense why did reti
Health decline I will tell you this that
we recently went to a Medicare Advantage
program for both the prescription side
and the medical side and there are
significant cost savings associated with
that and um our staff in that Arena led
by Joyce Pitman the director of risk and
benefits and her predecessor who's now
Deputy Commissioner but we won't say her
name um have done a real good job over
the years of managing that program and
doing a good thing but everything else
you can see where everything else is and
did we hit our Target indeed we did um
because it'd be kind of weird if we
didn't um secondly I'm going to talk to
you about where we spend and hierarchy
is the wrong word for expenses but this
is by rank order of the large
things one of the reasons our budget was
big in fiscal 24 is we bought a building
for $21 million we're not going to do
that again this year we bought enough
buildings so um that goes from 21
million to zero so savings right there
but you can see salaries went up and and
that's largely a function of the of the
10% and all of that benefits are going
up cuz raise your hand if you think
healthcare is getting cheaper um
thankful to see no hands um utilities
are a significant expense with the
number of buildings that we maintain and
I'll tell you how many that is in just a
short while we do a lot of Maintenance
as you can see a huge portion of our
budget if reti health is half our budget
half of everything else is plant and
property that is taking care of building
Etc which is a fairly expensive
proposition um dyt transfers is there
proper and Casualty Insurance is
something that something that we do
directly and other operating expenses
but I'm going to move you ahead quickly
to page four where we talk about where
the general funds are by
division and we have we have eight major
divisions if you count the
commissioner's office as one and I do um
because it includes the state budget
office for example but you can see where
the where the general fund portion is in
a lot of these areas uh the plant and
property general fund expense was 26
million going down to six not cuz Karen
is particularly efficient at saving
money because we're not buying a
building again so although to be fair
it's her decision not to buy a building
so maybe we should give her credit for
that um but you can see where the you
can see where the rest of our expenses
are and risk and benefits is listed here
absent retiree Health cuz the the it's a
it's a small program and and a lot of
the is the property side of the equation
um so you can see where we are and how
we're down down 4% 4.02 and then up a
bit in the second year like everybody
else with um that's because of uh
salaries and benefits and the seconde
cost of those which the governor
graciously let us figure into the
budget
um chart five is nine boxes to remind
you mostly of U The Brady Bunch or
Hollywood Squares before we talk about
which in each one of those boxes and
I'll warn you when I get the poll in
um so I'm going to start with the
Commissioner's Office what do we do in
the Commissioner's Office well as many
of you know the origins of the agency
were in establishing the office of the
com controller in
1931 um and and at one point we had a
division called the division of budget
and control and that's to make sure the
budget is controlled that there are
controls on the budget that we track the
budget that we that we make sure
something's going on at the budget that
we have a budget
oddly before that we didn't necessarily
have a budget people would kind of spend
whatever they wanted and like nine
months in call you guys up and say on
the legislative side and say hey we ran
out can we have some more people thought
that we should have a Control Function
so the Control Function helps ensure
that what we spend matches what you
approve and that if you don't approve it
you're not allowed to spend it um in
fact
technically if you spend more money than
you've been approved to spend it is the
personal Li ability of the commissioner
of that agency to make restitution to
the state for the amount that was
overspent um given the size of my
personal bank account we try to make
sure that doesn't
happen um we have a business office
think of it as a Central Finance office
to manage the various things we do um
the office of Cost Containment which
people don't think about too much but is
where we collect for Indigent Indigent
defense hence my question to
commissioner Hanks about collections we
have a legal office we have a couple of
people inside
um technically within the commissioner's
office we pay for the Deferred
Compensation commission's administrator
or executive director although they are
independent of the agency um and there's
discussion with the governor right now
about exactly how they are to be
independent of the agency then a couple
of assorted special dispersements
including the governor's transition fund
which I wish I could have been able to
say when governor elect aot were here um
but there are other things we do a we do
a uh a property tax like payment to
conquered fire um although it's a
relatively pathetic amount so it's not
really like property taxes but it's a
small amount of money um and we pay for
parking cards for downtown employees who
don't have parking because that way as
it is if you take a job with me it's
like taking a pay cut because suddenly
you have to pay thousands of dollars a
year for parking and we don't like that
so what do we do what are the major
areas at the state that that we run as
an agency we we run
um there I always say in interviews um
there are eight major divisions in the
in administrative services that run an
enormous spectrum of things one of them
I count as the state budget office which
is Michelle um and her team some of some
of whom you see floating about here and
there um one of them is the division of
accounting services the state com
controller and some states as an elected
official here here it's a it's a
division head in our agency anybody
who's on fiscal has seen Dana call
periodically regularly uh we produce the
Aur we pre-audit we um we pre-audit
things we do a single uh single federal
audit on all the financial documents of
the state we do lots and lots of things
that people minimize as oh that's the
accounting stuff that you do without the
accounting stuff that you do people go
to jail and the state can't open for
business one of the other functions at
sort of another end of the spectrum is
Public Works we build stuff we don't
build roads and bridges that's do but we
build everything else we take care of
the Deferred maintenance needs of the
state we happen to be building a parking
garage on a site very nearby that looks
like a big puddle um we're building a
new YDC over in Hamstead for example
we're doing lots and lots of we fix
roofs and we do all sorts of things like
that um and that's to ensure a
consistent standard across state
agencies engineers and architects who
all do a very good job and are all very
smart people um as as is everyone um of
Enterprise application management which
used to be called fdm we manage New
Hampshire first doit does most of the
computer operations of the state we
manage the state's enterprise system the
piece of software that governs Personnel
payroll
accounting all sorts of functions
purchasing all sorts of the functions of
state government it is the thing that
sits on everyone's desk or it's like the
thing behind the thing that sits on
everyone's desk is a enormously
complicated process and it is currently
being upgraded dramatically um in in
quote unquote going to the
cloud um and it's the it's the machine
or the software program through which on
some basic level we pay 13,000 people
every two weeks I would argue to you
that there's no more more important
thing that Cassie and I do then pay
13,000 people every two weeks do you
agree with that yes that way we live yes
there we go that way we live that's a
good point uh Personnel the state is the
state is 10 or 11,000 employees and it
and and or 13,000 if you include
part-time and um we manage the state's
Personnel function including the very um
complicated task of negotiating
contracts with 14 different employee un
unions and we do some Education and
Training significant amount plant and
property and Karen's behind me here um
we manage more than 4 million square
feet of office space which is a lot um
we manage more than 90 buildings in the
state Enterprise we occasionally buy
some and sell some uh we bought Grant a
place in Hall Street we hope to sell
some in lonia which are shall we say
less functional than some of the other
buildings of the state this is a
significant task and it is it is an area
where where much money um shows up in
the budget as a transfer and is quote
unquote double counted because it shows
in an agency's uh in an agency's budget
as transferring to us and it shows up in
our budget as the spend um which is a
which is a common accounting way of
paying for things like that um we also
do Statewide Energy Management which is
a significant function that
started I don't know when representative
wer might be able to correct me if I say
enough the Statewide Energy Management
when we started that office let's say
2008 and pretend I'm right it's just
easier that way uh procurement and
Support Services a catchall division and
a catchall agency we do Statewide
purchasing it's actually one of the
oldest areas of the department where the
state created a purchasing AG agent in
something like
1915 um to um to do purchasing for two
reasons right one is one is for
competitive purchase and two is to
assure that all the citizens of New
Hampshire had a shot at the state's
business which is equally important that
uh we don't get we don't get suck on a
guy we like and goes oh everybody likes
Fred everybody likes Tina let's just
keep using them nope we bid things and
we do a lot about 850 contracts more
than 500 million in annual spend
but in addition in that particular
division of the state we managed the
procurement card program which is a
credit card we use to buy things we
manage the merchant card program which
is a when we take a credit card mostly
at liquor but in a lot of places um we
manage a surplus property if people have
been to White farm and bought an old
desk that was um uh in need of rehab
that's us unlike the federal government
who just dumps their um Surplus property
we actually sell ours to make at least a
little bit of money we run a federal
food Sur plus distribution program out
of a warehouse on store Street which
people don't always know about the
current governor actually said to me
once when I was talking about this he
goes what I never heard of that and and
he was on the council for six years um
and that's one of one of those things
Fleet Management we track uh track cars
which has been a particular interest of
people in the state since about 2010 We
Run The Statewide mail operation out of
the basement of the state house um we
manage lots and lots of things there uh
and and I'm going to talk about risk and
benefits we risk and benefits began uh
buying insurance and paying for workers
comp and involved into a
self-administered state-run healthc care
plan which is a big thing $500 million
per banum 37,000 retire retirees workers
and family members we pay for health
care for an awful lot of people it's
actually a very good program and it's
probably the one of the best parts of
our state benefit package our salaries
tend to be a little less than um they
might be in the private sector and their
health benefits tend to be a little bit
more and for those of us who are aging
um and consuming more healthc care
benefits that would be me um It's a
grand and glorious thing um but it's a
lot of work in a lot of people um and
and they do a very good job and so the
retiring Health portion is more than
12,000 State retired state workers and
spouses um I shouldn't tell you this but
it was in the news recently as you might
remember some couple of issues here and
there with Anthem and the way we were
able to get through that was not because
of uh an outside company but because of
a very dedicated benefits team um who
currently sit in a building on Pillsbury
Street doing a very good job so we do a
lot of everything and I I like I like to
say in job interviews it's almost like
the legislature stuck everything they
didn't know what else to do with in one
place and it might seem that way but
it's not we're actually a central
Service
Agency um we don't run the state's
Medicaid Program we don't regulate Banks
we don't regulate Insurance uh we don't
sell lottery tickets we don't sell
liquor at least not legally um but none
of those people can do their job if we
don't do our job we're like the pit crew
Richard Petty wins the race raise your
hand if you've never heard of Richard
Petty thank you um Richard Petty wins
the race but we're like the crew and you
can't win a race unless you got a good
crew um and so uh so that's who we are
and that's what we do because of that in
addition the legislature when it creates
very small agencies with 1 2 3 4 7 8
people in them will routinely append
them to the Department of administrative
Services as quote unquote
administratively attached you'll be
hearing from a whole bunch of them when
I finally stop talking um and um they're
mostly array behind me um and what that
does what that means is they're
completely independent but we have we
help them with HR we helped them with uh
with financial operations because um
you're unlikely to have a CFO if there's
only two of you and you're unlikely to
have an HR Director if there's only
three of you and so we do that and it's
it's something that we do why again
because we're a central Service Agency
it's a function that we provide why
should you care about us and not just
cut us as annoying
overhead um which is a comment people
occasionally have and it's because um
nobody really can do their job if we
don't we touch every agency every day in
every way and the processes and
procedures that affect the way state
government works um are things that we
administer whether it's the governor and
counsel process whether it's going to
fiscal every fiscal item every GNC item
passes across Michelle's desk for
example um before it gets to the
legislature or the governor depending on
the on the body um the way we buy things
the way we pay people the way we account
for things the way we budget for things
um every in every way we solve problems
in every way over over the course of
time we have I have a little I have a
little icon here with the little with
little dinguses that summarize this for
you but one of them has three people on
it and and an arrow and we do this and
all this and more despite losing
something like 41 full-time staff
between
2010 in 2017 out of a total of about 300
staff we are a very efficient
organization
um we are sadly occasionally overworked
um but we're happy to do it and I have
said in budget hearings in the past um I
have all the smartest people in state
government who work for me um and some
agency got annoyed with me and wanted to
play triv Pursuit to test that but um we
didn't do that but I do I have very very
very good staff um and that's why you
can rely on the work that we do with
that I'll stop talking and let you ask
any and all questions
answer thank you thank you commissioner
I always enjoy your presentations and
your sense of humor but I frequently see
a friend who is a retiree who always
complains about this money you saved on
the retire health insurance and Caroline
the subcontractor that does a lousy job
every time I talk to him so is there
going to be any change that I can relate
to him yeah do you want to
um I our retirees have already
experienced change we've been working
with Caroline since January what
happened was we went out to bid and um
we bid our retire Health uh coverage in
the alternative and we got prices on
doing just the medical which we had been
doing for years and this time we also
priced out the um the pharmacy benefit
so um that that um contract was very
advantageous to us I think we saved five
million-ish dollars like and um we were
um stunned quite frankly because as you
know representative Anthem has been a
partner to the state of New Hampshire
for 20 plus years right and um so we
were stunned when when um the operations
of their home delivery service was um
quite frankly a mess all right and what
had happened was that they had
transitioned to a platform that they did
not tell us they were transitioning to
and it wasn't really working the way it
was intended to work so today it is
largely working the way it is intended
to work because we we worked very very
hard with Anthem I think that's one
thing Charlie might have told you about
our division of risk and benefits is
that we work very very um diligently
over the years year in and year out to
deliver good service to our members and
so we have um recently um we're working
on an audit of Caroline to make sure
that all the oper issues have in fact
been fixed across the board systemically
so that our members are guaranteed good
forward commissioner this may be a Karen
question because it's about deferred
maintenance and I I've heard you mention
on a couple of different occasions that
that your estimate for what the the
state has in far as deferred maintenance
is roughly a billion dollars so my my
question is how are we how do we
prioritize that is it just you know
who's what roof is leaking the most or
or what's your order of prioritization
and number two how are we doing over
time we it's a billion now but are we
gaining on it or are we falling behind
for example if I were to ask that
question two years ago was it 1.2
million two 1.2 billion and now we've
we've gained or going the other way I
I'm going to let Karen talk in detail
about sort of how we how we prioritize
and what we prioritize I I want to
caution like I a billion is a big round
number which is why I picked it
um we don't have the level of precision
to tell you it's a billion precisely
because there's no point in doing that
level of analysis if you gave me a
billion dollars I could fix stuff and
you would you would notice um but you
wouldn't think I did anything that was
silly um and uh it's sort of a big
ballpark number and and I remember six
or seven years ago when I started um at
a meeting with with Karen and and Steve
Lorenson and we talked about this and he
said I don't I don't have a good number
I have to know what the priorities are
because I know we're going to we're
going to do about a million of it this
year and and I have to prioritize for
the capital budget but I don't I don't
need a precise number and and we are
making some strides toward toward being
precise and I think it's getting better
but I'm curious to see if Karen who's
smarter than I am will think it's
getting
better thank you um I think one of the
things that we have that's working
against us is everything started costing
more recently and so what we thought was
maybe 500 million um a few years ago and
then we were infused with a lot of arpa
funds and were able to do a lot of work
that money didn't go as far as we would
would have expected it to a few years
ago so um one of the things that we well
I want to touch on a couple things we
asked for about $150 million in the
capital budget this year those were the
things that we thought needed to be done
in the next two two years um we know
we're not going to get 150 million um we
also put some things aside that we said
these can wait because as Charlie
mentioned what's the point of asking for
more than 150 million when you know
you're not going to get it um the other
thing that we're in the middle of doing
currently is we're conducting a facility
condition assessment on uh the majority
of our facilities which will detail all
of our infrastructure the age of that
infrastructure the condition of that
infrastructure so that will be a really
useful tool going forward and saying
these our immediate needs so you know
maybe this is the100 Million worth of
stuff that we should be doing this year
here's what five years looks like here's
what 10 years looks like so we are
getting a better handle on um not only
the overall cost but kind of scheduling
that stuff out and prioritizing it in
that
way thank you very much for your
presentation
next um right up there he is doing that
we only have copies for you what we have
thank
afternoon Kristen monani here for the
office of the advocate for special
education uh we are a new agency as of a
year ago and um I believe we had about
five minutes budgeted here so we it is a
short Pres presentation to try to comply
with that um just to highlight a couple
of things you know I think I I'm going
to stay focused predominantly on budget
um we when I took the office uh in July
of
20123 it was with a very expansive State
Legislative mandate that really covered
um ensuring that I Services were
provided as federally and state mandated
for 30,000 students with IEPs in the
state of New Hampshire we spend about
$900 million on special
education um for some districts it's 25%
or more of their education budget um if
that wasn't enough the statute went on
to say we also were tracking metrics of
all sorts of disabilities um Staffing
and Personnel to provide for those um we
were working on
legislative um initiatives that we found
based on our work needed to be
implemented and a whole host of other
things that gets us involved across um
multiple agencies that really touch
special education so vocational rehab
under doe the area agencies that work
with um a lot of the families that have
uh students with special needs and we're
finding more and more that there is a
crosscurrent between doe and DHHS in
terms of how we're placing students and
where responsibilities are lying it's
very unclear in a lot of situations and
so we are triaging multiple cases where
um because of that lack of clarity
there's a lot of finger pointing and we
have students and families in and out of
hospitals
constantly drugged to be honest when
they shouldn't be Etc so there are a
whole bunch of different priorities um
in terms of systemic work for the agency
that I detailed in just a few pretty
broad priorities in here in addition to
dealing with all of the cases um just to
give you a sense uh my colleague Tim
Lenahan joined me um really in late
spring you know may into June of
2024 um and between the two of us we've
probably handled about 40 cases um
within a year we do not want to be an
agency that just provides information to
parents so that's one of the things
that's really been debated there are
lots of groups within the
state that have funds to provide
information to parents of students with
disabilities um all of the families that
come to us have more than exhausted all
of those informational based resources
um and are still in situations we've
we've triaged predominantly cases where
students are out of school sometimes out
of state in treatment facilities um many
of them have been out of school for
multiple years because they can't agree
with their school districts on something
that keeps the child safe and educated
within the schools so um it it triage is
a very accurate word many of those
families caregivers have gone through
um really terrible circumstances um as I
said in and out of hospitals
Etc we don't want to be just triaging um
there are 30,000 students with IEPs um
we have worked the state systems are
really antiquate so tracking even
complaints even
um indications that parents are
rejecting their IEPs which doesn't mean
they don't want services for their
children it means they think the
services being offered don't provide any
benefit or don't provide enough benefit
or the children are in the wrong place
and that's creating constant issues and
and as we said you know often ends up
with a child out of school um suspended
constantly Etc so uh we were not even as
a state really looking at how many
rejected IEPs there were it turns out we
think um based on work we've done to get
um amended s SP 340 in place it's
probably at least a th000 a year which
is a number that I thought was pretty
low um we rely on doe to track that for
us but that you know we did push
legislation over the year to start to
get that
tracking um you know we're saying of
those we'd like our office to be able to
address about 200 a year and again that
is a tiny fraction 200 cases a
year providing much more than
information really trying to resolve
those cases so that we don't end up with
these crisis situations um you know
that's a tiny fraction of a total um but
in looking at what it's taken to to do
40 uh we have a proposed org chart you
know in here on the second page um
and those positions we you know some of
them are actually approved but unfunded
at the moment so that is the big
difference between um our prioritized
needs and our efficiency budget again
the efficiency budget was created before
the agency existed um and I think
without any reference to what it was
actually going to take to attempt to do
our
job with that I would just take
questions
do you do you mostly meet with people
like do you go to IEP uh meetings yes
absolutely and is that is that arguably
the the focus of your job mostly so um I
would say we need just as much focus on
the you know big pieces like how voke
rehab interacts in for students age 16
to 22 and the fact that families don't
think they're getting any of those
Services despite Lots being spent on
that so there are a lot of big policy
pieces
and agency pieces but yes when I say
we've triaged kind of 40 cases it has
meant either Tim or I being there front
and center in IEP meetings it's never
one it's multiple and then we've also
assisted families in bringing multiple
cases to doe process the state doe
complaint resolution mechanisms we're
seeing such a small number you know 10
to 15 a year maybe of out of out of
thousands right who were saying we
reject the IEP very few were getting to
an actual resolution and it's because
families felt like they didn't have the
resources to go through that process I'm
going to tell you they really didn't for
us to do it effectively and we have been
effective with doing it to get to
resolutions um Sometimes some of which
save the state quite a bit of money
because that money is being triaged
elsewhere in hospital care and in
long-term pieces um hundreds of hours on
cases that we actually have to get to a
dispute resolution but again we're doing
that after years of crisis do you think
most families don't are are moderately
unaware or at least a lot of families
unaware of the dispute resolution
process no they know about it um they
just I have a la I practiced litigation
for six years before I went on to run
schools um it takes me a lot of time to
get through it we're dealing sometimes
with you know thousands of pages of
documents produced on both sides
obligations to produce obligations to
meet you know all sorts of Court dead we
just went through a hearing last week um
you know where there was argument
constantly about whether the witnesses
should be thrown out whether we'
properly complied with processes and
procedures so for parents it it is just
really daunting so they do know about it
all of the parents we work with are are
fully versed in the understanding peace
they've been through parent information
centers they've been through all sorts
of trainings they believe they can't do
it themselves and I can't tell you that
in all cases they're wrong it depends on
how
vigorously they're going to be up
against attorneys on the other side do
you do you find that um are you uh uh is
your relationship with
doe adversarial or no actually um I I I
think I worked hard on cultivating this
Tim has worked hard on cultivating um
some strong relationships with DHHS
because um in bringing him in he came
from a different background that had
more of that DHHS component than I did
um so I'm going to say no I actually
think it's collaborative we worked um
really hard with them after the first
special education audit came out this
year that was of dispute resolution
about hundred and some pages pretty
negative towards doe and I said I think
some of this is fair some of it isn't
but worked with them very
collaboratively to try to do a first
piece of legislation and try to start
tracking precisely you know where are
these complaints going and what's coming
to the state what's getting resolved
another big special education audit do
out almost immediately that is not just
the dispute resolution it's the whole
shebang of the 900 million spent on
special ed so we'll see what those
results are I'm sure there will be a lot
to address there as well um as I said it
is impossible for us with two of us
right now to meet what's in that State
Legislative um creation of our office uh
so so either we need the Staffing or we
need to really readdress what it is that
we're expected to do and in the cases
that you're involved in are you mostly
um it's the district on the other side
the school district all of whom are
represented by
attorneys okay thank you I'm sorry all
thanks
sure thank you very much your testimony
appreciate it thank
you okay going to bring up the
thank you good
afternoon uh good afternoon my name is
Steven Walker director of the
conservation land stewardship program
CLS for short and with me is Charlotte
Harding our stewardship
specialist the mission of CLS is to
ensure the state's Investments and
conservation interests are looked after
uh we refer to the overarching function
that CLS performs as stewardship and
monitoring we do this principally
through through regular Communications
with participating land owners and
municipalities in conjunction with site
visits most land conservation projects
occurred during the acquisition phase of
the land conservation investment program
lcip that ran between 1987 and
1993 the stewardship and monitoring
phase was first staffed in
1994 the lcip was considered such a
successful Endeavor that the more
familiar lchip
um was created in
2000 each year CLS prepares an annual
status report for the Council on
resources and development cord this
document found on the CLS website
succinctly explains the program RSA 162c
governs cord and includes all lands
protected through the
lcip 87% of funding for CLS comes from
an endowment held at Treasury and
administered by cord that was set up in
1993 to provide for the Perpetual
stewardship of lcip conservation
interests the endowment also includes
additional non lcip properties the
remaining 133% comes from a contract
with New Hampshire fishing game CLS does
not receive General funds the attached
charts illustrate the breakdown of the
categories of properties CLS works with
for fiscal year 26 there is one item
that differs from all previous banal
budgets we have the purchase of a new
vehicle listed as a prioritized need in
the budget as we address our
transportation need as the properties we
work with are spread with throughout the
state and I did want to just say we
thank the commissioner Arling house and
the business office and the HR office
because as a an um administra
administratively attached uh agency um
we couldn't do it without them and
they're just been fabulous so thank you
when when did you start
with conservation land stewardship uh 22
years 6 months
ago and am I right that you're retiring
in a matter of weeks we weren't going to
bring that up but yes we were going to
bring we were going to bring it up um I
just on behalf of the State of New
Hampshire I want to thank you for your
services it's without question true that
this program would not exist without you
would not be as successful as it has
been without you and um I know that
everyone who deals with you knows how
what a great job you do and how
important that is and so thank you for
your service thanks and and we have some
very
capable hands that have left things in
so very capable very good but without
the
vest it it's a
[Laughter]
philson thank you very much rich thank
afternoon my name is David Rogers I'm
the chairman of the housing appeals
board with me today uh Stephanie verile
um a fellow board member um we have two
other board members we are a small
agency of only four individuals Edward
Rogers no relation is a professional
engineer and certified land surveyor who
is on the board and then Elizabeth
manard who was unable to be here today
is the clerk of the housing appeals
board the board was created in 2020 um
by legislative act and we hold hearings
on housing matters related to appeals
from local planning and zoning boards of
adjustment um we have concurrent
jurisdiction with the Superior Court um
in these matters although the supremor
court jurisdiction is somewhat broader
but we we proceed in much the same way
um we are administratively attached to
the Department of administrative
services our um budget is really uh
pretty Bare Bones there's no significant
deviation from prior years other than
the 4% reduction that was um requested
and we've accomplished that um we do
have one program that is being
implemented currently called Legal files
it's a case management software package
that was purchased last fiscal year uh
and is being implemented now and there
is ongoing expense with that for
administrative purposes with the vendor
uh that's being uh conducted primarily
through the uh Department of um
Information Technology at this point um
we have
um in comparison to the court system in
terms of the hearings that we conduct
our membership is made up as I mentioned
of Specialists people who have either
extensive backgrounds in land use and
planning or land surveying in the case
of um Ed Rogers um Stephanie is uh a
land as a planner and has had municip
experience in that regard and I've been
an attorney since 1988 and have had 12
years combined experience on various
planning and zoning boards in different
municipalities in the state so we bring
an an a level of expertise that uh may
or may not be available in a court
system we also um process appeals from
the appeal request until the completion
of the appeal in approximately six
months so that's far faster than getting
before judge and having a hearing and uh
decision rendered by a superior court
judge so we do serve a purpose on the
housing side of things um as I mentioned
our budget is essentially um unchanged
from prior years with the exception of
the uh legal files process that that I
mentioned uh with that I'd be happy to
okay I'd like to call the office of the
child
advocate hi good afternoon good
afternoon Cassandra Sanchez child
advocate for the State of New Hampshire
attorney Lista massio I'm the associate
child
advocate and as you may know the Office
of the child advocate is an independent
impartial state agency we are mandated
through RSA 21v to provide oversight
over executive branch child serving
agencies um we do have what is called
expanded jurisdiction which occurred in
2020 which expanded us to oversight of
all child serving executive branch
agencies where initially in 2018 when we
were established the sole focus of the
office was oversight over our child
protection and Juvenile Justice
agencies um we have grown as an office
over time you will see in our booklet
here that we have currently uh nine
full-time employee positions within the
office we do have three vacancies at
this time um two of those which were
just um became vacant as of the end of
October so we are currently hiring for
those positions the third of that was
within a reclassification process
throughout the summer months and was a
approved at the um September 25th GNC
meeting and so that was also recently
posted so um although we do have three
vacancies they we do not expect them to
remain vacant very long we are actively
hiring and we have received a number of
qualified applicants for um two of those
positions and one of the positions was
just posted last week um so we do expect
to be able to fill them rather
quickly um and so you will see in our
budget ask here um that we are asking
for additional positions in our
prioritized needs um and that is due to
the growing number of um inquiries that
we take in as an office um so if you
look under the office overview page um
three of the slideshow here um you will
see that we receive review and respond
to um so this is our last annual year
our preliminary data shows 349 citizen
complaints came within a year's
time um during that time frame we also
reviewed
2,939 incident reports um and so that's
inclusive of critical incidents from DCF
and restraint and seclusion reports of
children um and so we continue to
receive a growing number of those also
you'll see the last bullet point there
reports to the last three months of case
loads that are carried within the office
our two assistant child Advocates carry
each um approximately with an average of
45 cases at any given time our legal aid
carries an average of 20 cases at any
given time and I myself carry an average
of eight cases at any given time um I am
carrying cases and the legal aid is
carrying cases due to the rising numbers
and our inability to quickly close them
um leading to more cases than can be
managed by two individuals so we are
sharing that load right now but even
sharing that load is an overwhelming
number for our office to try to manage
with the small numbers that we have um
so given that we are asking for that
additional assistant child advocate
position to assist with taking cases um
and reducing them down to a reasonable
number um which would be a a reasonable
number ideally should be under 20 each
even with the additional position we do
not foresee us being able to be under 20
each um so we're really asking here for
as conservative as we can to be able to
make cases more manageable ensure that
we're getting to the safe need safety
needs in a timely fashion um we also
have in our prioritized needs and ask
for a case Aid position the case Aid and
the legal aid in the office they do the
review and monitoring of all of those
incident reports so that almost 3,000
incident reports that we receive they
review and read every single one of them
look for any immediate action we may
need to take as an agency to ensure
safety of those children and work with a
larger team to make sure we are fully
assessing uh dcf's response to those
incidents um and that they are acting
timely to safety of children um those
continue to grow year toe um as you will
see here under the the case Aid slide um
there is a 17.2% increase from the last
bium when we looked at um what we were
taking in so we continue to um grow in
year also in our prioritized needs we
have a reorganization and
reclassification of positions um this is
due to the growing office and the need
to have a um more management position in
between myself and the office staff as
we continue to grow I'm currently
responsible for all of the um in office
HR tasks um as well as a supervisor over
the case Aid positions because they have
a very unique role um and need constant
supervision on a week- toe basis which I
cannot offer at this
time um and so then to quickly wrap up
we um here also made note of other line
items um our overall operating expenses
have been impacted in every other line
item due to this 4% decrease um in order
to get to that 4% decrease we did unfund
a position in the office and still had a
significant loss in operating expenses
so the the charts um on the next couple
of pages actually show those changes
compared to fiscal year 25 and if you go
to the um the bar graph it shows um our
operating expenses in fiscal year 25 are
at 70,000 and and um in the efficiency
budget for 26 we're down to 18,900
that's a 73% decrease in operating
expenses that is because we cannot
control the pay and benefit expenses
that we have in the office and we cannot
control our rents leases and payments to
other state agencies so the only aspect
of our budget that is within our control
is so minuscule that we would not be
able to continue the functions of our
office we would not we would run out of
paper and pens at some point um as well
as our ability to travel um travel is
very important for our office to be able
to get to see children in person and we
would have to drastically cut our
instate and out of state
questions with the uh with the incident
reports and citizen complaints um and
then you you mentioned that uh you
carried an average of 45 cases each are
those a combination of the incident
reports and the citizen complaints or
what what constitutes a case thank you
for clarifying that no the um the cases
would specifically be the citizen
complaints that have come in the
incident reports we do not count those
in case numbers those are managed
separately and as IID mentioned everyone
is viewed and looked at but if it's a
considered a case it comes in through
citizen complaint and then we find that
there's um justifiable reason for us to
dig deeper into that okay how how how
long does it take on average to resolve
a
case I would say in past years it would
we would in a couple of months be able
to resolve a case as of recently cases
in particularly those involving DCF are
a lot more complex um there with those
complexities it requires many more
meetings and so we're carrying cases for
a significantly longer period of time
than we ever had before we've had cases
that have been open for more than six
months that are not resolved that
require multiple meetings with the
agency with children with providers um
and so the
workload associated with a case is a lot
more cumbersome now than it ever has
been before for our office okay thank
you any other questions thank you very
much for your testimony greatly
appreciate thank you thank
you like to call now the New Hampshire
Aging good
afternoon if microphone yeah good
afternoon uh my name is is Rebecca Sky
I'm the executive director for the New
Hampshire State Commission on Aging the
Commission on Aging was created during
the 2019 legis legislative session we
are administratively attached to the
Department of administrative Services
the commission's chief charge is uh to
advise the governor and general court on
policy and planning related to aging
additional staff supporting the
commission and two two part-time
employees a Project Director that um
provides an admin support and runs our
older Americans volunteer Awards program
at 20 hours a week and a Communications
and Community engagement director who
works 16 hours per week the commission
itself is 26 members very committed
people who include legislators
representatives from various state
agencies and uh governor and point some
of whom I think are still listening
today um page five of the packet before
you this packet here um outlines the
commission's activities the full
commission meets um monthly um as does
has three commission task forces and two
commission subcommittees one of those
subcommittees turns to weekly meetings
during the legislative session as I said
the commission's um main charge is to
assess existing and potential public
policies Effectiveness in providing the
opportunity for all of us to thrive as
we age uh and be a part of the fabric of
the communities in which we live over
the past year we tracked over 60 bills
in the state state legislature providing
testimony on over 23 bills
we also investigate current issues and
respond to concerns raised by various
stakeholders including the public at
large to hear those concerns we conduct
Community engagement sessions throughout
the state and throughout the year we
also publish a monthly newsletter
targeted to older adults in the state it
is intended to capture a news you can
use uh sharing valuable information on
programs and services and and public
policy it's volunteer it's a volunteer
editor that actually produces this
excellent newsletter uh and a member of
the
commission as we um Implement an annual
Awards program um also we Implement an
annual Awards program honoring older
adult volunteers across the state that
has been a tradition in the state since
1962 uh we publish an annual report on
November 1st a copy of the executive
summary as the first four pages of this
packet I have um a couple copies here
for those of you who might be interested
of the 41-page report that sets a policy
um let's see so turning again to page
five of the packet that I put before you
um you can see um the very last bullet
uh talks about the fact that we are
overse that the commission is overseeing
two ARA funded projects this year and
next um other agencies running projects
often will hire a Project Director to
oversee um um a project no additional
staff were hired to oversee this work
and complete this big
lift the driving reason the commission
was uh was created is is in response to
uh changing demographics currently over
onethird of the state's population is
over the age of 55 the 80 plus plus
population is currently 4.2% of our po
our state's
population the Department of Business
and economic Affairs population
projection suggest that by 2050 close to
12% of our state's population will be
over the age of 80 uh this rise is set
to have significant impact on our state
and how on our how our communities
function and on our County and state
budgets so with this I'm just going to
shift to talking about what is actually
in the budget um by looking at
Pages um in your in your packet your
budget packet uh Pages 2011 and 202 you
can see that we're a very small agency
with a very basic office operations 85%
of our budget um is for salary and
benefits in fiscal year uh 26
if you turn to page uh 203 and view
expenditures uh line 60 benefits um
you'll see that the largest increase to
our budget compared to um to previous
years initially when I took this role I
did not utilize um the health benefits
um and and that has changed and and this
really is the the budget cycle to make
this a permanent necessary feature um of
the commission um so fiscal year 25 uh
allocated almost $2,800 school year 26
asked for 72 uh ,000 it's that's about a
$45,000 change so that that's what the
biggest thing you will see in looking at
this budget um regarding other Personnel
expense fiscal year 26 efficiency budget
reflects a loss of 5 hours per week of
part-time assistance this is a signif
significant loss in a in a very small
office reviewing the remaining
non-personnel parts of the fiscal year
26 budget in comparison to 25 um um the
increases except for class 46 the
consultant line um are largely the cost
of keeping the lights on and and not
controllable um instate and out of uh
State travel in fact were reduced uh
Pages 20 uh um 212 and 200 and um 216
display how the decreases um to budget
lines were made where they were possible
to be
made um the increase in the consultant
line is to make the commission compliant
with Federal Regulation and the Ada
um our meetings are public and
communication access is a requirement we
have members of the public who attend
who are deaf and uh for whom ASL English
interpreters are needed uh given our
audience many of whom use hearing aids
uh cart reporting whereby spoken word is
typed and viewed on uh uh available
displayed in real time on a screen is
needed as well that's about uh
$7500 um per year for that um
purpose um fiscal year 26 and 27 budgets
are not flat but nearly so uh even with
required salary increases and to achieve
that um the dollars for communication
access services that I just mentioned
were moved into the prioritized need uh
request for fiscal year 27 so just
quickly moving to the prioritized need
um budget uh items uh top of the list is
for communication access services to be
compliance with the Americans Disability
Act um that is um um there's a request
for 2500 in fiscal year 26 and 6,000 in
fiscal year 27 please note that there
was a zero that was dropped um in the
budget book on pages 2011 203 and
219 um it again it's the request is not
for 600 but for for
$6,000 um in that prioritized need um
the second request is for additional
staff uh for the commission to have the
desired impact one full-time staff that
is running running essentially an agency
on its own is not enough um the ratio of
administrative work that I do um to
Mission oriented work uh tilts against
achieving the purpose for why the
commission was was created um and if and
if I'm being a little transparent I'm
actually retiring before the year is out
and in part of that is is is a bit of
burnout um from trying to start up an
agency during a
pandemic and and just the the um uh the
amount of work that's involved in in the
role a policy an analyst with the
ability to study the state budget will
make an outsized impact uh to the
expenditure difference in the quality
and in the breadth of the work that the
commission is able to address um and it
would create the opportunity for the
next executive director to be able to do
to um do things such as writing Grant
proposals to bring in additional
resources to the
state uh item number three on the
prioritized need list is to maintain the
current parttime employees hours at 20
hours a week versus the reduction um
even if we're not able in this budget
cycle to get an additional staff person
here maintain ping current staff levels
would would be so helpful um and that is
about um 8,800 in uh State fiscal year
26 and about 8,900 inisis uh State
fiscal year 27 um item number four is
for is about is $1,000 per fiscal year
for subscription services to support
communication uh engagement and
Communications activities these dollars
are just a hedge against the need to
hire outside for services um and and um
which would cost more and the final item
on the prioritized needs list um also is
is an increase in inter agency transfers
uh for class 28 property and plant as
requested by Das and I'm happy to answer
any
questions seeing done thank you very
much for your testimony greatly
appreciate it you're welcome
congratulations on your retirement or
burnout retirement retirement it's going
for a good thing you want to you want to
share with people what you're going to
do yes so my husband for over 25 years
was the life and health actuary for the
Department of Insurance here in the
state um and he retired a couple years
ago and he decided he was going to go on
a bike trip to Southeast Asia and I
decided a monthlong one that he couldn't
do that without me so that is what I'm
luck okay would like to call up the
good afternoon thank you for being
patient with
afternoon if I dare use a Boston
Marathon
metaphor you have turned the corner and
day um my name is marily Ian and I am a
member of the Personnel appeals board um
I have with me attorney uh Charles
Russell who uh is our acting chair of
the
board New Hampshire state law provides a
process for full-time classified state
employees to appeal a variety of
employment decisions rising out of the
application of dop administrative
roles the Personnel appeals board was
established in 1986 as a qualified
independent panel appointed by the GNC
under the provisions of RSA 21i col 45
to hear those
appeals the PAB receives 25 to 35
appeals annually the work of the board
includes convening iners
uh
hearings uh and prehearing conferences
with the parties deliberating on the
concluded cases and pending motions
responding to supreme court filings and
right to no requests and conducting
periodic business
meetings historically the PAB has been a
component of the division of personnel
until the upcoming 2627 budget we have
relied on the staff and resources of dop
in order to function the past
legislative session Senate Bill
487 which establishes the PAB as a
wholly independent state agency was
passed thus we are coming before you
with our first budget as an independent
state
agency um in the interest of brevity I
am going to skip the brief section
around transition activities just know
that we are transitioning out of admin
services to become our own agency and
are analyzing our needs um and
particularly budget priorities in order
to do
that our budget request for uh fiscal
is
$334,700
those figures are well within the
perameters that were provided to us uh
by the governor's
office uh the PAB budget essentially
requests routine uh operating expenses
including part-time staff rental space
current expenses it licenses and board
expenses uh for fiscal year 2026 you'll
notice that our first year of the buyan
name is a little higher than the second
year that is because we um have budgeted
some one-time costs that will not need
to be replicated in the second year
those costs include simple things like
um computers uh software systems that
sort of thing um so with that that's a
fairly simple budget compared to what
you heard um already today and I will
entertain
questions I'll just note for people that
um how this happened um people probably
know that um in the in the late 50s
early 60s they created a Personnel
commission with a executive director who
couldn't be fired and a and a board of
directors um in 1986 after ad admin
ministrative Services was created out of
edmin and control they merged the that
Personnel Commission in made the
activities of the of the department um
the division of personnel and decided to
take what used to be the board of the
Personnel commission and turned it into
the Personnel appeals board which used
to hear
appeals um for since 1986 it's been a
little bit awkward in that the people
making Appeals
are usually us to a board to which we're
providing support which some people
would argue is legally a conflict of
interest um and at some point starting
about two years ago we created a process
to um make reality out of What's um or
to put down in writing what's actually
reality which is that it's not the same
thing and I'm not the boss of you um and
um I mean literally for example I can't
talk to Charlie after the meeting even
though he's a friend of mine because I
have an appeal before him and it would
be awkward um to do so and so we're
doing this that their budget happens to
be exactly the fiscal note of the piece
of legislation that was passed which
seems which I suspect is why James gave
Target thank you very much for your
testimony greatly appreciate it thank
you and with that the hearing stand
in recess until 1 p.m. tomorrow
afternoon